oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
frederick douglass is not my real name
fugitive slave
but year i was born i do not know
my mother and i were separated when i
was still too young
to know her as my mother
as a child i
you indescribable hunger
i remember fighting with yard dogs for
scraps of food
thrown away as garbage
i've often been utterly astonished to
hear persons who
speak of the singing of a slave as
evidence of his contempt and happiness
this is a terrible mistake
the songs of the slave
represent the sorrows of his heart
i've sat on kennard's war at the foot of
philpott street in baltimore
and i've seen men and women chained
and put on a ship to go to new orleans
still
hear their cries
budget too
i'm just going through some old files
and notes
i might find something interesting for
the women's conferences after me
you're not expecting me to make a formal
speech do you not even have breakfast
i won't be wrong
just want to be prepared
h
i
j
k
what god's name do you think you do
you are taking me anyhow you give a
[ __ ] of an inch he will take a mile if
you teach that [ __ ] how to read there
would be no he would forever ruin him to
be a slave
we carried you here to take care of
thomas
you'll learn a trade when you're bigger
ain't no need for you to be reading boy
no need at all
i understand
i'll teach you that it's not allowed to
be near immobile there's nothing more
need singing
oh
[Music]
i have little hope in the freedom of the
slave by peaceful means
more than two centuries of slavery
place the slave holders
beyond the reach of moral and humane
consideration
[Music]
the only
penetrable point of attack
is fear of death so you mean to resist
me
yes sir horror conceived nothing without
a demand
it never did
and will
the limits of tyrants are prescribed by
the endurance of those whom they
appreciate
i shall not marry you as a slave then i
reckon you should go up north
words come easily
i'm caught this time lord knows what
might happen get you off the plantation
now fred
they'll patrol us to stop you in
baltimore you learned yourself a trade
in a shipyard
there's work for you up there and
freedom
i saved up some
got some belongings i can stand
look for the new york terrain
[Music]
[Applause]
please
come up and share your thoughts with us
mr kaufman i'm not very used to speaking
like this
just speak the french
douglas is not my real name
i am a fugitive slave
what year i was born i do not know my
mother and i were separated when i was
still i resolved that whatever power i
had should be devoted to the freedom of
my roots
my friends have we been listening to a
thing
a piece of property or to a man
will you allow this man to be carried
back into slavery
[Applause]
we get you started here in massachusetts
until he comes accustomed to traveling
and speaking
to douglas
i don't believe you've met mr garrison
i'm honored sir
i was deeply moved by your address
you have a great gift mr dennis
thank you mr garrison
say you never had any formal schooling
no sir not even after you escaped
no sir
i've been teaching myself ever since i
was a youngster
amazing
really um
you speak with full conviction and
authority
if there is no struggle there is no
progress
the struggle may be immoral
or it may be a physical within or
without the union slavery must fall a
long crushed negro must rise
ethiopia what to the american slave is
your fault of july
there is not a nation on the earth
guilty of practice is more shocking and
bloody
than other people of the united states
at this very honor
two leaders
no senator calhoun
no
slavery cannot last
melancholy as the truth may be
for the dealers in human flesh
no constitutional change
no legislative enactments
no human contract nor agreements
can save the accursed system of human
bondage
from the death
and decay
through which god and nature
[Applause]
who is it
sorry to disturb you like this i should
have known it the very thing we were
afraid of has happened but we never
dreamed the reaction would be this great
you booked my dear fellow you've named
your masters you've marked yourself for
the fugitive catchers my dear man
i have no choice
my effectiveness as a speaker was
diminished
the enemies of our cause claim that i'm
a fraud
that no slave could be so literate
you've talked of taking our message to
great britain
yes
this seems a propitious time for such a
journey
giving time for this trouble to blew
over frederick mr garrison may be right
that means i'll have to leave you and
the children for a while
but you still have your freedom
[Music]
so we can't persuade you to stay in
england
it's been over a year
i must go back here
it's not an easy decision
the british people have taken me to
their hearts have you any plans
frederick oh yes when i get back
there'll be speeches more speeches
meetings and more meetings
but julia
i'm thinking of starting a newspaper
i want to call it the north star if you
do i'd like to help
i could raise funds celsius
humanitarian deed mr richardson
but i fear the reaction of our
abolitionists at home why should anyone
object
to agree mr garrison
but
let's speak to mr douglas
the more that's known about slavery the
better don't you agree
[Music]
frederick
my sister and i have hired an agent who
has been in contact with you all
he
is willing to sell you
so to you
well as soon as the transaction is
completed we can give you your freedom
freedom
[Music]
freedom
[Music]
i like this that's good
thank you very much
rosetta
yes papa
harry this is my friend from england
julia griffith she's been helping to
straighten out the paper's finances
i'm so honored mrs tubman i've heard so
much about you even in england your work
is known
i'm just an old lady that loves doing a
lot of walking in the great outdoors
most times at night
and she spawned the bloodhounds too
wherever i go i hear folks talking about
john brown
[Music]
brown
the identity of your deeds in kansas
they say you freed over 100 slaves
several hundred
we escaped just ahead of the shall we
say
friendly posse
douglas
my words are for your ears only
what do you mean by that
i intend to seize harper's fairy i want
you at my side
seize the town yes
first we'll capture the army oscar
and we'll
hold the leading citizens hostage until
the slaves are freed
but don't you see you can't fight the
entire united states army alone
you and your men
are overwhelmingly outnumbered
they'll annihilate you
but this mission
will arouse all america
it will force the people to take action
against this tangible institution
john
you know i have supported and will
continue to support you in all of your
other efforts
but my dear friend this
this scheme is doomed to failure
this is the wrong place
this is suicide man
whether we live
dying
this deed must be done
shields for the love of god
mr douglas
i believe i'll go with the old man
[Music]
because of events in harper's ferry
the press butchered the public
had declared john brown to be truly mad
but he is
not john brown is a man who simply
believes
the declaration of independence to be
truth
and the bible
be a guide to human confidence
the future will write john's epitaph
upon the hearts of a people freed from
slavery
like samson
he laid his hands upon the pillars of
this
great national temple of cruelty and
blood
when he fell
that temple
began to crumble to its final tomb
mr douglas a word with you please come
walk with me sir
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is i'm a telegraph operator
i have in my pocket a wire that just
came to the united states marshall
it orders him to place you under arrest
for rest
what is charges conspiracy and accessory
before the fact of murder they plan to
extradite you to virginia to stand trial
with john brown
mr douglas i am a friend of your cause
i know that virginia justice will surely
see you go to the gallows
i'll hang on to this message until
you're safely out of town i have to
leave for britain next month it's been
planned for some time mr douglas go at
once
i'll make for canada sail from there and
go quickly mr douglas and godspeed i
must get back to my work
[Music]
richard the women on the council know
you've been fighting their class for
nearly half a century
yes
it's the men i'm trying to reach at that
meeting
many of them still unconvinced
women must have the right to vote
really think you can change their mind
perhaps
i think i've changed a few of my time
[Music]
let us stop the war on the soil upon
which it originates
and among the rebels and traders who
originated yes
organize yourselves into societies and
communities
purchase arms for yourself
learn how to use
yes let us not only be ready when call
but let us cast about for the
opportunity
to strike for the freedom of the slaves
yeah the rights of human nature
for we shall be caught and we must be
ready
[Applause]
thank you
thank you sir for consenting for this
visit
mr douglas your reputation precedes you
we appreciate your efforts in recruiting
so many legal troops
now
tell me your concern
to put it bluntly mr president our negro
soldiers are receiving inferior arms
inferior training
lower pay
and in other ways of being unfairly
treated by the union army and when
captured by the confederates
are murdered in cold blood
mr president
the negro soldier is willing to fight
and die in this great war
but he must receive some sign from this
administration
that he simply isn't exchanging
one form of oppression for another
mr douglas
if this administration goes too far
we will bring down upon ourselves all
the hatred that is spelled toward the
negro
this would greatly hinder our ability
to successfully conclude this war
for we
both of us
have much to gain in this regard
let us pray that this family is never
separated again
well what happens now papa now that our
people are free
there are papers that supposedly satisfy
those
but in my heart i fear the danger
of the victory that you and
charles 170 000 other black men fought
the game will be lost
but papa president johnson i fear
andrew johnson is no friend of the negro
people
you mean we've been suffering all these
trials for all these years for nothing
without the vote
liberty's a mockery
the negro will no longer be a slave to
an individual master
you will be a slave to society
and at the mercy of the bomb
[Music]
it is the spirit of hate
spirit of murder
spirit that would burn a family in their
beds
but one thing i know
and that is
there is no middle ground for us
we must either have all the rights of
american citizens
or we must be exterminated
for we shall never again be slaves
hey
do you like it
[Music]
maybe you might do great
well president hayes wouldn't have the
united states marshal
the district of columbia living in a log
cabin
mr lincoln lived in a log cabin
[Laughter]
[Music]
everything's fine
what is it
[Music]
i met with president garfield today
first he
thanked me for supporting the party
and then he informed me uh
no longer the united states marshall
[Applause]
i'm to be appointed the recorder of
deeds
glorified clerk
lincoln never took a step backwards but
every administration sent says
he's not going to take that job are you
is there a choice
our people's pride demands
that a negro holds some position in the
government of the united states
[Music]
i must put their battered pride
ahead of my own
you've done the right thing for me
[Music]
you usually do
[Music]
papa
[Music]
good
[Music]
what a pleasant surprise
i can't stay but i'm moving
but i couldn't come to washington
without stopping by this day
it's been so long harry
it brings back such pleasant memories
you know harriet
most of what i've done in my life
has been public
but you blame it in a private way
i've had the
paws of the crowds
while your greater deeds have been known
by only a few
trembling scared foots or bondsmen
midnight sky
silent stars witnesses to your heroism
all day showing thomas that silver
tongue of yours
[Music]
you must be terribly lonely frederick
with anna gone and all the children
growing up now hello
[Music]
harriet
anna was the anchor of my life for 40
years
what
i have rosetta
charles lewis
fred
and i have my work
i hope this is hot enough for you
thank you
miss fitz yes mrs douglas do you have
the file in the ramsey properties
i'll get it
thank you
chris
yes
i understand you enjoy bars that sir
very much mr duffy
perhaps
[Music]
perhaps
you wouldn't mind accompanying me to the
concert today
i'd be happy to
i'll have to get back to my
correspondence
[Music]
papa i speak for the entire family
how could you do such a terrible thing
rosanna it so terrible
for an old man to seek the comfort of a
loving wife
evening of his days descent upon him
but you are not just anybody papa you
are the leader of our people what kind
of example is this if you insist on
marrying at your age why turn your back
on our women to marry this
fuzzy that's nonsense
of life rosetta or female
we all have the right to follow the
convictions of our hearts
not to marry helen simply because she
happens to be white
go to my grave
and self-convicted moral power
is that it please don't deserve that
oh papa
really
please
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for those wonderful
words thank you thank you
mr douglas how would you sum up your
involvement in the women's cause
when i ran away from slavery
it was for myself
advocated
emancipation
[Music]
it wasn't my people
but when i stood up for the rights of
women
myself was out of the question
i found a little
nobility in the act
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello mr douglas
hello i'm martin andrew
i heard you speak last week in mountain
island oh yes that was an inspiring
affair
can i talk to you from for a moment mr
douglas
well martin i have just left one meeting
i barely have time to suffer
before i have to go off to another
why don't you stop back by tomorrow
afternoon i'll have more than just a
moment
but i just have one question
all right just one
sir you lived in the old days when our
people were slaves
and in the new times both
but it seems like all those rights that
we're supposed to have won are being
taken away from us
what advice would you have for a young
fellow like me who wants all people to
live in liberty and justice
[Music]
agitate
[Music]
agitate
[Music]
[Music]
if there is no struggle there is no
progress
the struggle may be immoral
or it may be a physical one and it may
be both moral and physical but it must
be a struggle
horror concedes nothing without a demand
i had little hope of the freedom of a
slave
[Music]
no slavery cannot last
melancholy
the rich landowners of other countries
it's hardly necessary for me to say
[Music]
stepped upon the free soil of
massachusetts let us never forget well i
took that justice to the negro
is safety to the nation
museum will have all those features
beginning at 2 40.
[Music]
next a portrayal of abolitionist
frederick douglass by storyteller guy
pear tree he gave this performance in
february at the community church of
boston the program runs half an hour
[Applause]
the year is 1859
and i
am very thankful to all of you
abolitionists who have gathered here
because at this very moment i am a
fugitive
a fugitive from what you may ask
some say that i'm a fugitive from
justice
no
not a fugitive from justice
but from the barbarity
of an institution that has enslaved my
people
for several generations
on october 16th
1859
a man by the name of john brown captain
john brown
he assaulted harpers ferry virginia
with the one purpose
of taking the armaments giving them to
the slaves
and having them revolt
i told john brown
that this effort
was going to blow up all around him
that the entire united states army was
going to gather around him and crush him
and it did
he was captured
and he was hung
and john brown
has become a premonition
and i too have become a premonition
brown's premonition is
that thousands and thousands of men just
like him will rise up and crush
this abominable abominable system of
slavery
my premonition
is that i
speak the truth
of slavery
the slave owners and the slave system
want my voice to be silenced
what the slave owners wish more than
anything else in the world
is for everyone to believe that the
slave is happy and content being
enslaved we are not happy and content
being enslaved
no man child or woman
is content being a slave
for a man
to be content to being enslaved
he must be kept ignorant of his humanity
and that
is the position
of the slave owners
they strive day and night
to keep down the people of this nation
to elude the truth
that men are not half men
that slaves are not half people
but whole human beings
with whole rights under the under the
laws of god
the slave owners want you to believe
that we are content
it is not so
no man is content being enslaved
and i was a slave
and i did not know i was a slave
i was born
on a little farm
in maryland
not only was it a little farm to me
but it was a big farm to me
it was a huge estate for me i used to
play along the fences
and my grandmother betsy was the most
beautiful woman i had ever known
my grandmother betsy she used to she
used to get out into the water with her
waist high in water throwing the nets
out over the water sane hauling they
called it
and as she threw the nets out over the
water
she would sing
the waters of jordan
are flowing
to zion flowing home
home to my lord
the waters of jordan are flowing to zion
not only was she a famous fishing woman
but she was also a famous planting woman
in those parts
all of the farmers wouldn't let their
seeds go into the ground unless my
grandmother's betsy's hands had put them
in the ground nor would they let the
plants come out unless she took them out
they said she was a magical woman
and so we children
we had
plenty to eat
one day
someone said to me that
as we youngans got a little bit older we
were gonna
be sent to old master
old master what what's an old master i
said
and grandma says to me
you see this
this estate
this little shack here we live in and
all of these children and myself and you
we belong
to old massa
and the way she talked about old
it sounded like she was talking about
god
who was this old masa
and then one day she said to me fred
we're going to go visit your kin folk
come on along we're gonna go to the main
plantation
and so
with my bare feet
and my grandma with her white scarf
around her head we walked for 12 miles
grandma
i know there's a lion out there i can
see it grandma there's a there's a
dangerous lion gonna get me grandma
it wasn't a lion
it was an old tree stump
but my child's eyes could only see
danger on the road
when we finally got to the main
plantation i saw
the most
assorted assemblage of children i had
ever seen
they were white and black and red and
brown and yellow children running
everywhere and she said look there's
your brother perry there's your sister
eliza she said look all of these
children are your kin folk
they're not my kin folk i said
they run and play like like they're
going to destroy each other i've never
seen these children before
the truth was that they were all my kin
folk
they were either great-grandchildren
or great-great-grandchildren of this
lady
and so she said go around the back and
play with them
go around the back and play with them no
grandma i don't want to play with them
they're they're strange and they're
crazy they're going to hurt each other
she convinced me to go around the back
and as i saw them playing rough and
tumbling
someone came
a few minutes later and said fred frey
your grandmama is gone
my grandmama gone
she wouldn't leave me and i ran around
the front
grandma
grandma
grandma
my brother perry said here take this
apple and take this pear
and i took both of them and threw them
as far as i could
and i fell to the ground
and i cried right there
and i stayed there all night
they couldn't get me up
i know my grandma didn't want to leave
me
i know she didn't want to leave all
those children either she had to leave
them because she was a slave she had no
choice
but the next day
i was sent to the kitchen
aunt katie was the was the mistress of
the kitchen
and aunt katie took a special dislike to
me
she didn't like much of her children
anyway her own children
but she took a special dislike to me
to this day i don't know why
but one day she said to me
i'm gonna starve the life out of you
child
she had
gotten a big piece of bread and cut it
in several pieces and gave it to all the
children
took the crumbs and gave them to the to
the chickens running around and said to
me you're not getting a crumb
and i went outside and i cried like a
fine fella
that night i i slowly crept back into
the to the kitchen and everyone was
asleep and
i was looking for something to eat
because i was starving and i went over
to the
to a place where i saw a piece of corn
and i took it over to the fire and i
threw it into the fire
and i wait till it got really hot and i
took it out
and then the door opened
i said she's gonna beat me if she finds
me eaten in this house
but it wasn't
aunt katie
it was my mother
my very own mother harriet i hadn't seen
her but twice in my whole life
she
she's farmed out they call it they farm
out everybody
12 miles away 15 miles away i don't know
how many miles away but in order for her
to see me she had to walk all night
and she would have to walk all night to
return to be up at sunrise to work but
here she was and she said fred
what's the matter with you child
you don't look good
what's the matter baby
on katie said she was gonna starve the
life out of me
well she gave on katie report the likes
of your ears i don't want
you to hear
but something to the effect
don't you ever let me see you
or hear about you starving my child
my boy
he's my boy
and on and on she went
and then she came back into the kitchen
and she made gingerbread for me and cut
it up and fed it to me
and milk
and she
rocked me in her arms and i fell asleep
but the next morning she was gone
she had to get back
to the plantation
12 miles away
but i know my mother loved me
that memory shines
in my heart
and she was a beautiful woman
she reminds me of the
of the famous egyptian princesses i've
seen her face was so beautiful
but even though aunt katie took a
special dislike to me there was a woman
miss lucretia who took a special liking
to me
oftentimes when i was hungry i'd i'd
walk down past her window and i'd start
singing
walking down the road
and she'd know that i was hungry and
she'd come out and give me food
one day
i was in a scrape with
some hooligans
who lived on the other plantation and
they hit me upside the head in my it was
bleeding so and i ran to aunt katie and
i said on katie please help and she
looked at me and said
serves your right messing around with
them lloyd slaves
and then i ran out the house and miss
lucretia found me and she she put her
hand on my cut and she said come here
son
you're very hurt bad and she sat me down
she said
listen i'm gonna put some some salve on
it and bandage it up for you and she did
so
and i realized that her soft touch
meant more to me
than anything in the world
it wasn't that the cut hurts so much
but the meanness of on katie hurt even
deeper
time passed and i knew one day that i
would have to grow up
and then i would have to go and work all
day
but miss lucretia
she saw different
she said to me fred
we've decided to send you to baltimore
and we're going to
let you stay there
with my with my brother-in-law and
you're going to help raise the child
there
baltimore
i couldn't believe it
my i was getting ready to explode
baltimore i had heard about baltimore
baltimore
tom the cabin boy
who starts to stutter
baltimore
is the most
wonderful place that i've ever seen
really tom yes it it's got mansions much
much better and bigger than the ones
here really top yes baltimore is is a
grand city
so
tom the cabin boy got me prepared for
baltimore
and so i left
one night
i was on the
on the on the boat that left this
plantation you see the plantation could
only be accessed by boat
and it was
mr lloyd's boat the main plantation
owner it was called the salah lloyd
named after his daughter
and so i sailed on
on the sally lloyd
and we went we went out
i
and all of those animals underneath me
i forget if they were sheep or pigs
i guess they were going to slaughter
but not i
i was going to baltimore
when i got to baltimore
i walked down the beautiful streets
and tom the cabin boy was
he was right
baltimore was a beautiful city
and when i got to the home
of the alls
i put my head down because you're not
supposed to look at white people
directly in the face
and the woman at the door came to the
door and said son and she lifted my chin
up you looked me right in the eye
you're a beautiful child
don't you ever look down
be proud
and i thought i was looking into the
eyes of an angel
and she she treated me just like her
very own son tommy and she would sit
down with me and we would she would read
books to tommy and read the bible to
tommy and
i'd see her sitting silently reading and
i said
do you think you could ever teach me how
to do that and she said of course child
out i'll teach you
now what you have to remember
is sophia all this her name
was not raised with the logic of the
plantation owners she was an independent
woman who had married into the
plantation owners she had a very strong
christian upbringing
she did not know that you're not
supposed to teach a slave to read
and so out of the goodness of her heart
a heart whose kindness i have seen
overflow to countless people
she taught me the rudiments of reading
my abc
she was so excited that she said
hugh look what fred can do
you what
he told me to leave the room
i heard the book slam down don't you
ever teach a slave how to read
it will forever
unfit him
to be a slave
he should know only the will of his
master and obey it if you teach him how
to read he's going to want to learn how
to write and then he's going to run away
with himself
i heard
something that rang right through my
bones
that i was unfit to be a slave
he did not want me to read
in time
miss sofa
sophia
she turned against me and i would be
alone in my room
and she thought i was reading and she'd
run in what are you doing child
and the angel that i had met at the door
became my arch enemy
but i did not
desist
i continued i went out into the street
and i had people teach me to read
i played games with all the children i
know how to spell this word
and i put it into the dirt
government
no that's not how you spell government
and they'd spell it for me
thousands of times i did this and i
learned words and words and words and
words and words and when tommy the
little boy was out on mondays
well i'd go into his room
silently and get out his spelling books
and copy everything
assiduously until i knew it well
but my fate changed
things have had changed on the main
plantation
there was a
bitter argument between
mr alden
my old plantation master
and
they called me back
and anthony
he said to me
you've been up north to baltimore and
you've gotten a little uppity in your
ways
i'm gonna have to teach you something
for you see he would have me go out and
take the horses all the way out
and feed them but i'd let them run away
now you wonder why i'd let them do that
not because i was uppity it was because
i was hungry his new wife was just like
on katie she wanted to starve the life
out of me
so when i let the horses run away
they went down to the other farm
well they knew they were going to be fed
and i followed them and i knew i was
going to be fed too
so he said
i'm going to send you to a man who's
going to teach you how to be a proper
slave
mr covey
the snake in the grass
who changes men
into animals
i was beat every day for six months
one day the hot sun pouring all over me
we were threshing wheat
four of us was doing it one step at a
time
i was the one who had to pick it up
the heat got to me and my my head
started swooning and i fell down to the
ground
and i couldn't get up
instead of getting up i crawled over to
a tree to rest in the shade and covey
comes over and says
why is the work stopping
fred's sick they said you're sick get up
and he starts kicking me kicks me in the
side three times
get up
he walks away and comes back you ready
to get up
and i tried to get up and fell down
then he kicks me in the head
and the blood starts to gush
my hair was much thicker than it is now
and so the blood started to mat up
and so it stopped it from bleeding too
fiercely
but
his kick was a blessing in disguise
because it let the pressure off my head
and so i started feeling a little bit
better
and so my thoughts
they said to me
this man is going to kill me
and i said to myself i have to get out
of here
and so i got off the ground
i watched his back
i turned around and went into the bushes
he he ran after me but i escaped
i was determined to go to my master and
say
he's going to kill me
12 miles later whole day i walked
in the thickets
not only did i look like i was bloodied
up but it looked as though i had been
cut up at every place because all the
brides were cutting me everywhere
because i had to stay in the thickets
i was a sight to see
and so when my master looked at me
he you wonder what he would say to me
what you doing here
i'm a sight for sore eyes aren't i
what are you doing here
covey's gonna kill me
he's not gonna kill you
i'm gonna kill you if you don't get back
there immediately i'll let you stay here
tonight but you get back there
i couldn't plead with him
and there was
i guess you call it a hard place and a
stone
and i was right between the two of them
so the next morning i
i went back into the woods
finding my way back to kobe's farm
and i knew someone was coming to get me
i could hear them and
walking in the grass
but i turned to look and it wasn't
it wasn't a slave owner
it wasn't a slave catcher it was my old
friend sandy
he was one of those
deep african men
who know everything
mysterious
so he takes me to his house
i tell him what my problem is and the
next day he says you know
i've had a root in my pocket my right
hand pocket for five years and for five
years no man has beat me
i want you to take that same route
i'm a christian boy i said i
i don't believe in roots
come here he said his eyes started
glowing
he went over to the place where the root
is he dug it out here you take it
put it in your pocket
and go back to covey's farm
so
to humor him i kept it in my pocket
and i went back to kova's farm
and when i got back
it was a saturday afternoon
covey looks at me and says
good afternoon and he smiles
now what do you think that is all about
i said to myself
the next morning was sunday
he was very happy he was going to church
the man who goes to church beats his
slaves all week but goes to church i
don't know how he could live with
himself but he went to church
he was happy all day didn't bother me
monday morning he says to me
go go into the stables and hitch up the
horses so i went into the stable i
started hitching up the horses early
early it was five o'clock in the morning
he comes in and closes the door
he looks at me and says
no you you go over there take your
clothes off cause i'm gonna whip you
i said no i'm not taking my clothes off
he says you mean to disobey i'm not
taking my clothes off
he takes a big rope and throws it around
my legs and then he throws me to the
ground but as he's coming to try to grab
the clothes off me i
grab him around the neck determined that
he was not going to beat me today
and so i held him tight
and i could see the blood rushing from
his face
you mean to resist
i am not being beat and i'm not taking
my clothes off
and i held him
like steel
and he calls robert
one of the helpers come in here robin
and help me
robert comes in and looks and says what
do you want me to do get this man off of
me
i wasn't hired to help you beat on
anybody he said he walked away
then he called caroline
his the slave woman there
he owned her
she was a
statuesque woman in my condition she
could have knocked me clean across the
bar
caroline come in and help me
well something happened that day
caroline looked and said
i ain't helping nobody
she turned around and walked out
knowing that she could get beat for that
so here we were covey and i
two hours
stuck in battle
at the end of two hours
he was breathless and he said to me i
would have beat you better if you hadn't
resisted so much the truth was he hadn't
beat me at all
i drew blood from him he didn't draw
blood from me
but ever since then
kovy never laid a hand on me
oh he could have had me thrown in jail
he could have had me sent
way way down into the deep south never
to be seen again
i imagine the reason he never did
anything to me after that is because of
his reputation his reputation of being a
slave breaker and here i am a 16 year
old boy and i broke him
and so he would have lost
his employ
no
but my fate changed again
and i was sent back to baltimore
god was smiling over me i suppose
i even had made a an escape attempt at
one time
and and and and it was discovered put in
jail
taken back out
they finally sent me back to baltimore
and there
i decided to improve myself i worked day
and night
i mastered everything i could i even
learned to play the violin
i was teaching people how to read and
write
i even met my
my future wife to be
and i decided that i no longer wanted to
be
owned by anyone
and i decided to escape
finally escape
i got dressed in sailors uniform and got
some some other papers and
on the train going out of baltimore i
looked out the window
and there was
a very close friend of mr hugh
who knew me quite well
and he looked straight in my eyes
i said oh no i've been found out
but i don't think he recognized me in
the sailor's uniform
and on i went i finally arrived in
boston i set my feet on this free soil
of the north
and i i lived in boston for a great time
and i learned
about the abolitionist movement
and i went to nantucket in 1841
and there was william lloyd garrison
leading
a great assemblage of people
and he invited me to speak
and i got up to speak
much as i've done today
and after i spoke
he jumped up out of his chair and said
do you think this man
should be sent back into slavery do you
think he should be chained like like a
cattle and and and made into a brute
and 3 000 strong the people got up and
said no no
i could hardly believe
what was happening
people were cheering
my humanity
i found people
who thought slavery
was
barbaric just like i
and here i was among them and i knew
that i had to become an abolitionist
therefore i have become an abolitionist
and i speak out against the barbarity of
slavery
i frederick douglass
i am a man
and because i am a man
i am an abolitionist
thank you
[Applause]
about books it's a page from history and
[Music]
you're looking at the view frederick
douglass had from the front yard of his
home above the anacostia river he called
this place cedar hill
this week c-span's american writers
series features the first of four
programs focused on slavery in the civil
war and today we're at the home of the
man who in 1845 wrote narrative of the
life of frederick douglass an american
slave
this place in washington dc is now the
frederick douglass national historic
site
it was at the end of his third
autobiography
douglas declared that he had quote
live several lives in one first the life
of slavery secondly the life of a
fugitive from slavery
thirdly life of comparative freedom
fourthly the life of conflict and battle
and fifthly the life of victory unquote
we'll examine these lives with you and
our guests starting with professor david
bide of anhurst college professor blight
who was frederick douglass
well frederick douglass was the most
important african-american leader and
thinker of the 19th century he was born
frederick
augustus washington bailey on the
eastern shore of maryland 1818. he
escapes from slavery when he was 20
years old
and he became a renowned editor orator
abolitionist
and thinker
he's one of the greatest examples we
have in american history of what we
might call
leadership through language language was
in essence his only real weapon or his
only power
his life stands really across virtually
all of the 19th century
since he had been a slave
and stole his own freedom
as a symbol of in many ways the worst
and the best in the american experience
he's he's the slave who stole his own
freedom and then explained
freedom and slavery probably as well as
any american ever has
professor edna medford of howard
university that's a tall order
can you think of a modern day equivalent
of frederick douglass
potentially perhaps there are many uh
modern day equivalents of douglas but i
don't think that anyone quite reaches
his level at this time at least not in
terms of
tenacity
spirit commitment facility with language
he was a truly extraordinary person one
of the most extraordinary people of the
19th century of any race
and i i think it would be difficult to
identify any one person who would have
the kinds of strengths that he he did
but as i said the potential is certainly
out there well you're both historians
and writers and thinkers about this do
you think that his place in history
is where it ought to be
um i think that more people need to know
about him i don't think that americans
in general know nearly as much about him
as they should he was such
a tremendous influence on developments
throughout the 19th century and
they were the kinds of developments that
still affect us today so i think that
he's very relevant to our times and we
certainly need to know more about him
david blight his standing historically
well douglas in many ways vanished from
popular consciousness
in the early 20th and mid 20th centuries
although he never vanished from
consciousness in african-american
communities his narrative for example
went out of print
for nearly a century until it was
brought back into print in 1960
but his stature today has risen very
very high the narrative has become
canonized if you like it's widely taught
in american history and in literature
courses
and uh i think in many ways douglas has
become a symbolic figure in public
education
but perhaps too often he is still a kind
of
cardboard cutout in school rooms without
perhaps people
investigating the meaning of his life
deeply enough
david blight is the author of frederick
douglass's civil war keeping faith in
jubilee he is a history and black
studies professor at amherst college
edna green medford is a professor of
history at howard university
graduate of hampton institute university
of illinois at champaign urbana and the
university of maryland our phone lines
are open we'll be taking your calls
as we go along here this morning talking
about the life and the
historical effect of frederick douglass
edna medford talk about america in 1845
what was the political landscape at that
time
it was a very interesting period
a period of american expansion
the mexican war was about to begin uh
and as a consequence of that that war
there was greater discussion over the
expansion of slavery americans had
dealt with the issue of slavery's
expansion for quite a while by that time
douglas is writing during during an era
in which uh the majority the vast
majority of african americans are still
enslaved
slavery had ended in the north excuse me
but continued in the south
and douglas was very much concerned not
just with uh preventing slavery's
expansion but ending it entirely and
also extending the rights
of all americans to african americans as
well so it was a very difficult time for
african-americans um
very difficult time for americans in
general because of this whole issue of
what to do about slavery i think we can
show the audience what the population
figures were at that time around around
1860 and we're speaking roughly here uh
the population as you'll
soon see on your screen is divided up
between
those who are a slave and those who are
free and as soon as that's there it is
in 1860 the united states population was
about 31 million there were 3 million
950 000 slaves
and of and the rest was free colored
persons at 476
000 now david what do those numbers tell
you about america uh leading up to the
civil war
well for one thing it shows us that
the american slave population was a very
large slave population in fact the north
american slave population was the only
such population
in the history of the new world that had
naturally reproduced itself slavery was
booming and growing across the american
landscape
in fact douglas comes of age as a public
man in the 1840s at this very time as
edna says of tremendous expansion
westward and it is during the 1840s that
the problem of slavery in the west
explodes into american politics
slavery was expanding in great part
because of the cotton kingdom in the
mississippi valley
uh the wealth had had been defined by
this time in the south by slave
ownership by land ownership and slave
ownership and that old ideal that old
jeffersonian ideal from the
revolutionary era that somehow american
history and society would rid itself of
slavery
was no longer the case at all
abolitionists by the 1840s had come to
realize that if slavery was ever to be
ended in america
it had to be ended by their agency by
their by their crusade by their efforts
it wasn't going to simply fade away on
its own it was the source of so much
wealth in the south and in the north
professor medford the political parties
in 1845 through 1860
the whig party still in existence uh the
democratic party uh the jacksonian
democrats as they recall still being
called even though jackson had left the
scene
the liberty party what's happening in
the 1840s is there are people who are
either anti-slavery or abolitionist and
there is a difference between the two
but both groups of people are
forming these parties that address the
issue of slavery uh there there are two
groups of abolitionists primarily the
the garrisonians who believe that there
should be um
an embracing of moral suasion or trying
to appeal to the slaveholder
to do the right thing that this is a
horrible sin and so they should repent
of their scent
there is also that group of
abolitionists who believe that you
should engage in political agitation
including of formation of third parties
because the democratic party and the
whig party were not doing enough in
terms of the issue of slavery's
expansion or demise
and so you have the formation of the
liberty party and uh
a little bit later you have the free
soil party forming as well
that latter party is quite interesting
in that it seems to embrace two
different types of people
abolitionists who want slavery ended and
anti-slavery people who would be
satisfied if it simply did not extend
beyond its present limits
david white
cedar hill is the home of frederick
douglass
why did he live here and um what did it
mean to him
well douglas purchased this this great
house and these acres i believe in 1878
after he had moved to washington from
rochester where his house had been
burned
i think douglas was tremendously proud
of this site i don't think there's any
question about that he was tremendously
proud
of the status and dignity that he had
achieved after all people need to
remember that he had grown up as a slave
just across chesapeake bay from here and
from his front porch you could see the
u.s capitol by the time he buys this
house he is already a republican party
functionary in washington dc he wanted
to live near the seats of power
but i think douglas very much enjoyed
the sense of status that he gained from
cedar hill and one can see that inside
the house is as well as outside
i realized we just made a big leap from
1845 to many years later when he moved
here and we're going to cover all that
time in between but in the meantime our
phone lines are open so that our
audience can participate in the
discussion using the phone numbers on
the bottom of your screen shortly area
code
202-624-1111 for those of you who live
in the eastern or the central time zones
and for those of you who live in the
western and mountain time zones 202
202-624-1115
is the number for you to call our guests
are david blight from amherst and ed
named from howard university and our
first call
to talk about the life of frederick
douglass is from buffalo new york go
ahead please you're on the air
yes my name is virginia chambers and
i've been an admirer of frederick
douglass all my adult life in fact i
named my only son
after him but my question today
is how much education did he have
because i know he spoke everywhere and
in a commanding way and i was wondering
where he got his
education what kind of parents he had
and i'm a very proud african-american
thank you
thank you david blight
well he had very little formal education
although it would be a misnomer misnomer
to say that douglas had no education at
all he comes by his uh alphabet
with uh miss sophia all his mistress his
owner in baltimore when he was a child
he also studied the bible and studied
language with a black preacher in
baltimore named father lawson
he had a burning desire to know words
and language he also came by language
from a book called the colombian orator
a book uh emmanuel about oratory that he
was the first book he ever owned
he bartered for it when he was 12 years
old in the streets of baltimore there is
still some mystery frankly as to how
exactly frederick douglass came by
his uh musical uh sometimes almost
magical use of language in words
um but his formal education is extremely
limited but it's important to remember
that in the 19th century that wasn't
necessarily that unusual what douglas
did have was a burning desire to use
language and to use knowledge however he
could get it first as a means of getting
himself out of slavery then eventually
as a means of telling his own story and
then even after that of course as a
means of developing his critique his
analysis of the american problem of
slavery and racism in terms of his
parents as you asked
his father was a white man probably his
master aaron anthony although we've
never conclusively known
his mother was a slave owned
by aaron anthony
he is in virtually every way you can
define it an orphan
he was orphaned in essence by the time
he was seven years old in terms of his
direct parents he was first raised
actually by his grandmother betsy bailey
but after that in many ways douglas was
always kind of
searching for a home
as an orphan often does
but um in terms of education
it is really his grasp of language that
ultimately leads him to this insatiable
desire to read and understand the world
around him
we're going to see the copy of the
colombian orator it's in the house and
we're going to see that as we go through
this morning miami florida go ahead
please
um yes i'd like for both of the
professors to discuss
the integrationist views of frederick
douglass throughout his life and
juxtaposed that with these separatist
views of w e b du bois at the very end
of his life given both of their
experiences if both of you all can
expound upon that
thank you very much carl you're jumping
ahead of us but that's just fine edna
medford
keep in mind that du bois uh changed
opinions over the years boys was never
the same person uh
he he really did grow from one
period to the next
in terms of douglas's uh integrationist
attitudes
douglas believed that
african-americans were americans first
and foremost and were entitled to the
same rights and privileges of all
americans and consequently
should be allowed
the same public accommodations should be
allowed to attend the same schools as
did other americans and fought
throughout his life for that right
uh when he's in rochester and his
daughter is not allowed to attend the
school there he fights to have the
schools integrated and eventually that
does occur
he does not give up what we think of him
so much as an abolitionist but even
after
that particular part of his life was
over when slavery was abolished as a
consequence of the 13th amendment
douglas continued to strive for the
rights of all americans
african-americans women anyone
living here and so uh that's something
that did not change
although we have a lot of cameras here
on the site it's hard to tell exactly
what it's like we're on the top of a
rather steep hill
and below us is a visitor center where
we have a camera
where you can there's a little display
of of a number of
things having to do with frederick
douglass and because this is a national
park service maintained site there's
also a area where you can watch a
introductory film in the life of
frederick douglass but also down there
is a wall that has
a number of excerpts from the writings
of frederick douglass and yesterday we
asked each of our guests to
choose one
but for one reason or another it struck
them and
i want to ask edna medford to
read the one that you have selected into
and the comment on why you thought it
was worth us hearing today
the american people had this lesson to
learn
that were justices denied where poverty
is enforced
where ignorance prevails and where any
one class is made to feel that society
is an organized conspiracy to oppress
rob and degrade them neither persons nor
property will be safe and that's from
the southern uh barbarism speech on the
occasion of the 24th anniversary of the
emancipation in the district of columbia
in 1886
douglas made this speech and along with
it this particular passage
after a number of african-american men
had been massacred in i believe it's
collington mississippi
uh carrollton mississippi and uh they
were unarmed men uh
had been minding their own business
evidently and were massacred and he was
so enraged at the idea that
african-americans even now that they
supposedly had freedom were not truly
free and he was saying that when you
tread on the rights of any one group of
people then actually you damage yourself
because there's that possibility that
you will suffer the consequences as well
this is the time in 1886 it's post
reconstruction
uh
douglas and african americans had such
high hopes uh after the civil war that
there would be full equality and
inclusion in american life for african
americans and by the 1880s uh indeed by
the 1870s they realized that that's not
going to happen very easily and he's
very
despondent
that
things are not happening the way they
should that african-americans are not
being included in american life and so
this is a response to what's happening
during that period next call is from
crete illinois good morning good morning
uh it's my understanding that frederick
douglass spent time in europe
and my question is to what extent was he
influenced by the writers and
thinkers of that era on the european
scene
david
well he did indeed spend time in europe
he first goes to
england
in 1845 right after the narrative was
published intending only to stay perhaps
for the summer he stayed in nearly two
years he was greatly influenced by
british abolitionists many of whom he
befriended and indeed befriended him in
fact it was a group of british
abolitionists who in 1847 purchased his
freedom from his master thomas old
in a very public way
douglas also returned to england on the
eve of the civil war actually escaping
right after john brown's raid at harpers
ferry
in late 1859 and spent
much of 1860 in england he later tours
the continent
as an elderly man
in the 1880s douglas was greatly
influenced in particular by the british
anti-slavery tradition and british
anti-slavery writers he may indeed also
have been
influenced to some extent
by the german romantics by writers like
gerta and schiller and feuerbach
who helped develop
a romantic uh tradition that led to to
german reform and wider european reform
by the revolutions of 1848
his reading was very very wide uh he was
also greatly influenced by a so-called
race theorists or by people who wrote
about the nature of race in the 19th
century and this goes back to an earlier
caller as well one of the things that
douglas tried to make himself an expert
on without any formal background was
what in those years was called ethnology
or the study of racial groups and he
gave a remarkable speech in 1854
called the negro ethnologically
considered i think was the title where
he tried to develop his own analysis of
just how
race as a biological entity is is a
fiction a very a very modern idea that
was frankly very much ahead of its time
but he had to read race theorists from
around the world even to develop
that point of view and that kind of
analysis
douglas collected books widely and was
greatly influenced also by by novelist
and fiction writers particularly sir
walter scott charles dickens
shakespeare indeed and not not least of
which by the bible particularly the old
testament
let's go back to the visitor center and
we'll take a look at the
display of all the quotations and david
blight you chose one the meaning of july
4th for the negro
what to the american slave is the fourth
of july i answer a day that reveals to
him more than all other days in the year
the gross injustice and cruelty to which
he is a constant victim
to him
your celebration is a sham your boasted
liberty and unholy license your national
greatness swelling vanity your sounds of
rejoicing are empty and heartless your
denunciation of tyrants brass confronted
impudence
your shouts of liberty and equality
hollow mockery your prayers and hymns
your sermons and thanksgivings with all
your religious parade and solemnity are
to him mere bombast fraud deception
impiety and hypocrisy a thin veil to
cover up crimes which could disgrace a
nation of savages
this comes from douglas's famous fourth
of july speech delivered
uh actually on the fifth of july in
rochester new york in 1852 he was
invited
frankly by his friends the ladies
anti-slavery society of rochester to
deliver this speech
but it became frankly i think uh the the
rhetorical masterpiece of the american
abolition movement it is douglas the
ironist it's it's douglas at the height
of his satirical and ironic mode it is
it is as though he invited his friends
into a hall had the doors locked chained
them to their chairs and said now you
will enlist you will listen to my
indictment of your country it's
obviously douglas's uh
claim about the hypocrisy of american
liberty and american slavery um
it's it's a
it's a it's a speech full of ridicule of
indictment
and it's it's a classic douglas speech
in the sense that at the beginning he
greatly admires the founding fathers uh
he talks about the founding fathers as
the geniuses of of the enlightenment and
how they had created this ingenious
uh constitution and the declaration of
independence he greatly honors the first
principles of the declaration but then
in the whole middle of the speech he
says over and over with that accusatory
pronoun this is your declaration of
independence because we black people are
not part of it however in the end of the
speech again a classic douglas move the
last page or so
he lets his audience up a little bit he
says i end on hope any anyway and in
essence he says america is still young
it's still malleable it can still be
changed but nobody who would have heard
that speech or read it could have
resisted this accusatory uh tone
of of that speech columbia south
carolina is on the line go ahead please
yes uh just to kind of follow up on the
last caller's question i was interested
in specifically what uh the
british funding of
frederick douglass's different reform
initiatives
the influence that that had on his uh
more radical bent in his break was
william lloyd garrison
and uh also i was interested if we have
time to hear about
what douglas thought about the whole
women's rights movement that was uh
gaining prominence at the time
tell you what car why don't we let edna
medford respond to the first part and i
promise you we'll get to women's rights
and suffrage later on
um in terms of the the influence of the
british
and their funding of him
he considered them very much an
important part of that funding process
his lectures were about spreading the
word of the horrors of slavery and also
about raising money for the cause and
certainly the british people
came to his rescue uh in many instances
to the point that
they actually fund
the the beginnings at least of his first
newspaper the north star
and in fact that ties in with his break
with garrison garrison was already
editor of the liberator it had been
established in
1831
when douglas decides that he's going to
establish his own newspaper
garrison and some of the abolitionists
grow concerned they believe that douglas
should stick with what they felt he did
best which was talking about his
experiences under slavery as a lecturer
and not as a journalist not as an editor
and uh it's like the the parent telling
the child you're not ready to leave the
home yet
and so douglas felt he was all grown up
uh he was ready to move on with his life
he wanted to
involve himself in new things uh of
course all of those things were to
further the cause of abolition and he
went on and did it anyway and so
garrison uh became very concerned but
the actual the final split
uh was a consequence of douglas uh
supporting the liberty party garrison
was one of those abolitionists the
premier abolitionist who felt that moral
suasion was the way to go
and that one should not get involved in
politics because the constitution itself
was a pro-slavery document
and that americans uh should not en
engage in any kind of um
appeal to the government for if for the
uh ending of slavery because any
government
that was based on that pro-slavery
document could not be trusted to do the
right thing
after uh this next call we're going to
actually go to the house and take a tour
inside with uh kim elders who's the park
manager here but first philadelphia
pennsylvania you're on the air thanks
good morning i'm very pleased to see
that the program on frederick douglass
there's there's a a troubling or
perplexing problem that that looms great
in my mind are
very often these days and and
and that is when when scholars when
people when individuals talk about uh
the black community or the
african-american community or what's
troubling is that it's a false picture
that's painted
all of us
and uh frederick douglass and and and or
and and uh oh colin powell and julian
bond ward connolly everybody is a mixed
race is not black american is not
african-american
that's reducing a full human being to a
simple part and it's much more
interesting to see the full human being
and can and and and consider the whole
background for example
edna green medford i'm sure you have
mixed our background all right
why why do we edit out the other parts
and just leave one
all right thank you edna medford do you
think we're editing things out no not at
all and douglas didn't either douglas
certainly understood
and and appreciated uh embraced his
mixed ancestry
uh but he also
recognized that he was a man of color as
well
and that people of color needed his
assistance and so he dedicated his
entire life to giving them that and uh i
don't think that means that you um sort
of just forget any other part
of who you are but it's it's what you
choose to put up front and douglas did
in many ways in other ways however uh i
i think just in terms of of uh his
insistence that he get uh certain kinds
of rise uh his attitude was uh i am a
man first and foremost i am a human
being and so i am entitled to the rights
of all men so and women of course so i
think it's humi it's his humanity it's
our humanity that means more than
anything else rather than color david
played any comment well by ancestry
douglas was obviously of mixed race and
and he as edna says never ran away from
it and sometimes in fact he would even
joke about it in speeches he would make
jokes to audiences about what part of
his behavior might come from his white
blood and what part from his black blood
which of course was his own ironic way
of trying to remind people that race was
essentially a fiction but of course by
experience and by reality in america he
was black he was a former slave american
society would always define him as black
and and he was in his own ways very race
conscious very very conscious of
representing black people
sometimes that was a burden for him and
sometimes he embraced it well now we
want to say good morning to kim elders
she's the park manager here at the
frederick douglass national historic
site ms elder thanks for being here on
the holiday
good morning thank you for coming and
visiting with us here at cedar hill glad
to be here now give us a few facts about
this as a historic site who operates it
and how often are you open well the
frederick douglass national historic
site is a unit of the national park
service system it was in
enacted into the national park service
in 1962 on february 14 1962 the home was
reopened for the general public
frederick douglass lived here in this
home for the last 17 years of his life
purchasing it in 1877 for six thousand
seven hundred dollars in fact it was a
gift for his first wife anna for all the
years with him raising his children
taking care of their home when he was
away out of the country and again on
september 1st he and anna moved into
this beautiful home that again is now a
unit of the national park service system
so if somebody wants to come visit what
are the hours what does it cost well the
park is open 362 days a year from nine
until four during the winter months and
summer hours nine into five we do have a
toll-free number that number is
1-800-967-222
for visitors who are interested in
visiting the site coming out and touring
frederick douglass's home and i guess we
should point out today is one of those
days that you're open for tours so we're
probably going to see some people
walking around while we're in there with
you aren't we we sure are we have
visitors expected from all over the
country this morning in fact well why
don't we we we begin our tour what what
do you say to us when you open the door
well i want to again just welcome each
of you all here to cedar hill it was
here that freddie douglas lived as we
mentioned for the last 17 years of his
life
and again it was here in this foyer in
fact that frederick douglass collapsed
of a heart attack on february 20th
1895. he actually suffered a stroke
heart attack i'm sorry and collapsed
here in his second wife's arms in
helen's arms again at the age of 77
years old the workplace is right here
we're looking at the place where the man
died yes that's correct frederick
douglass collapsed right here in the
hallway
i would like to now take you inside the
east parlor where you would have been
greeted by frederick douglass's butler
again we're talking about a very wealthy
gentleman frederick douglass had persons
to take care of his home and it was here
in the east parlor that we as guests
would have been seated um and
taken out
our coats and our hats and at that time
frederick douglass would then sit down
to talk with us about a number of issues
i'm
specifically about your travels here to
uh washington dc
and um of course your stay here your
intentions here while here at the cedar
hill home
i'm sorry i was just going to say we see
a lot of things here how much of what
we're looking at actually belonged to
him
unlike a number of historic sites within
a national park service system within
historic homes frederick douglass's home
is quite unique in that it contains over
90 percent of the original artifacts
everything inside the home is original
with the exception of the wallpaper and
carpet straps and curtains i'd like to
mention that unlike persons during that
time frederick douglass took a very
extensive inventory of his home in fact
i can't even think of many of us who
take inventories of our homes today took
extensive inventory lots and lots of
photographs of his home and it was from
the same photographs and the inventory
that the park service was able to
recreate the home to appear just as it
appeared when he lived here over a
hundred years ago now i interrupted you
you were going to point out something
else i was going to point out to you
this beautiful oil painting of frederick
douglass it is in fact the only oil
painted he's ever set for in his
lifetime we're talking about a very busy
man we're talking about a man who was
involved in so many different things but
he did take the time in 1883 to sit for
a very different of his sarah jane eddy
who painted this painting of him again
it's the only oil painting that he ever
sat for in his lifetime and i want to
point out that this was doing a very
troubling time of frederick douglass's
life he had just lost his first wife
whom he often referred to as the anchor
of his life um and again just prior to
deciding to remarry his second wife so
again in 1883
sarah jane eighty painted this portrait
of douglas do you have any idea what
he's holding in his hands um he's just
actually holding paper as though as a
scholar would
again this is a very unique portrait
again because it is the only painting
that frederick douglass ever set for in
his lifetime and no we don't know the
exact um document that he's holding but
i'm imagining some scroll of paper of
some sort and what else do you have in
that room well in this woman and
throughout the entire home there are
thousands of artifacts but i'd like to
point out to you this beautiful bust of
wendell phillips of course an
abolitionist during the anti-slavery
movement douglas often referred to
phillips as one of his very best friends
he's often described in all of his books
in fact the last two books as a very
fine gentleman and in fact it was
wendell phillips who often encouraged
douglas to continue to speak out to
continue to
go on the circuit and let people know
exactly what he was doing and why he was
doing it
i'd like to now at this time take you
all into frederick douglass's library
it's probably one of his favorite rooms
in the home and it was here that he
would spend some time as many as eight
to ten hours a day just reading and
writing
and of course we know born into slavery
and denied that right to an education he
not only taught himself to read and
write he also taught himself to speak
several languages we know he spoke
spanish french
german and italian
now that desk is there any particular
story behind the desk that we see well
the desk was a desk that douglas
actually found
out just outside of the house
representatives
near the united states capital it was
actually being thrown out and douglas
brought it home refurbished it and used
it here in his library so again he was
very proud of this desk and often told
the story that someone else's trash was
his treasure
uh we just showed the audience a
photograph of him at his desk with a
bookcase full of books
are those books there today no the books
have now been removed and they've been
removed for conservation purposes there
were over 1700 books here in the library
and we want to point out that they will
be returned here to the home sometime
around december 2002 to conserve um the
the number of books that the park
service has now has custody of it's
going to take a considerable amount of
time as well as considerable amount of
monies but we are going to be conserving
each of these books um and we'll be
bringing them back to the home back to
douglas's library now
kim elder before we leave you
david blight had mentioned the colombian
orator
isn't is a copy of that book in his
study it sure is i want to point out to
you that just on top of the desk here is
a copy of the columbian orator and we
know that douglas obtained his first
copy of the orator while in baltimore as
a 13 year old he actually purchased it
from a bookstore in baltimore for the
purchase price of 50 cents in fact we
also know that the colombian origin is
one of the very few items that he took
with him from um as an enslaved person
to freedom and from the baltimore area
and then just next to the orator of
course is the life and times of
frederick douglass written by frederick
douglass in 1882 right here in this
library here at this desk and again
these are just the number of the books
that we have here douglas's titles range
anywhere from the holy bible to the holy
quran
all right thank you kim elder we'll be
coming back to you to see the rest of
the house a little bit later in the day
thank you very much
uh let's continue with our next call
from denver colorado go ahead please
yes good morning
good morning
good morning sir you're on the air yes
good morning dr madison please turn down
the volume of your television set please
okay
how's that
just fine okay uh good morning dr
medford dr blight
i'm uh
with uh two questions
uh i'm reverend eric pearman i'm here in
denver
doing uh working on the last chapter of
my dissertation for the phd
and i'm an african-american male
and i want to ask two questions one
what was douglas's relationship with
other african-american leaders
particularly after he married helen
pitts and the second question would be
what was his relationship
with ida b wells barnett she's the
subject of my dissertation and i just
finished a chapter looking at her
relationship in chicago
during the world's colombian exposition
in 1893. i'll hang up a list okay
sir thank you very much first of all uh
edna medford who is helen pitts helen
pitts was the second wife of douglas
she was 46 years old
when he married her
he married her 17 or 18 months after his
first wife anna murray douglas
died
she was a clerk in the recorder of the
deeds office
and
both african-americans and white
americans many of them were very upset
about the marriage
douglas lost a few friends as a
consequence
but douglas being the person he was did
not care
felt that that he had the right to marry
whomever he wanted to
so a lot of people
objected
one of the people though who continued
to befriend him was ida b wells uh i see
their relationship as being um
a mentor-mentee kind of relationship
almost father-daughter uh i think they
adored each other
she was
the young agitator i think she got her
schooling of at least partially from
douglas
and was certainly
just as
capable
of being obstetrious as
douglas was they had a wonderful
relationship as i recall douglas um
spoke about the fact that ida b wells
was one of the people who when invited
to his home treated his second wife as
if she was the mistress of the household
and that's not the case with some of his
friends david blind did the first part
of the caller's question was did he lose
any uh relationships with black leaders
as a result of marrying a white woman oh
as edna says there were many black
leaders
particularly the younger generation who
chastised douglas for this because he
had become such a
symbolic public persona
and for the most famous black men in
america to marry a white woman
in 1884
was controversial it was also
controversial for douglas's own children
but to the earlier question as well
douglas had many
abiding relationships with other black
leaders reformers abolitionists editors
orators he also had a lot of battles
with a lot of other black leaders and
real divisions with him a couple of his
closest friends early in his career
among black leaders would have been
james mccune smith
uh probably the most educated
african-american of his time a physician
a medical doctor
a prolific writer and he's he's the man
who actually writes the introduction for
douglas's second autobiography my
bondage and my freedom which is itself a
fascinating
essay it's one of the best biographical
essays we have from the 19th century
about douglas douglas had close
relationships with other black
abolitionists he also had as i said
tremendous conflicts and battles
particularly over these questions of
integrationism and separatism which
tended to play out at least before the
civil war tended to play out over the
issue of whether blacks should emigrate
from the united states or stay a very
vexing problem for black leaders in
black communities in the 1850s and he
particularly had
battles over this issue with the likes
of martin delaney henry highland garnet
and others
douglas also broke as you've learned
with the garrisonian abolitionist uh by
the early 1850s and that indeed lost him
a few friends among the black
garrisonians who
like charles lennox ramond and a few
others who remain so loyal to garrison
through those years but it is also worth
saying that douglas was always his own
man and very protective of his own
symbolic persona he enjoyed this status
as
a sort of
primary spokesman for black america
whether that was in the press
on the platform or eventually in
advising presidents and that gained him
some resentment as you would guess from
other particularly younger black leaders
who had other agendas especially by the
civil war and the reconstruction period
um i hope that when the caller's
dissertation is done he lets us see a
copy of it we're all academics here i
just wanted to mention that this is the
book that our guest david blight has um
written it's how would you characterize
this book uh frederick douglass's civil
war keeping faith in jubilee well this
was also originally my dissertation so
the caller can take heart they actually
do become books sometimes
this is an intellectual biography of
douglas it treats douglas as a thinker
by and large
it treats douglas
douglas's life in relation to the civil
war and it particularly uh tries to
analyze the way douglas
uh interpreted the american civil war
what the war came to mean in douglas's
life and thought
and and also in the life and thought of
many african-americans douglas came to
see the war
once it came and once it developed into
an all-out struggle against the south he
came to see it
as as a kind of
divine reckoning for america he saw it
almost in a religious world view and he
came to see the civil war is really the
second american revolution the
recreation of an american republic
out of the crucible of black freedom a
quick note to educators uh we have an
american writer's website
that
we'd like to be aware of it's
americanwriters.org and if you were to
click on the classroom link you'll get
lesson plans based on
this program and some guidance on other
references that you can use as you
teach your students whatever aspect of
frederick douglass's life you choose to
teach our next calls from st louis
missouri go ahead please hi uh good
morning to both of your guests uh i was
i have two questions but i would like to
thank you all for having frederick
douglass uh this series and including
him in the series today but uh
the first question that i have for you
all uh is what was the relationship
between frederick douglass and booker t
washington
during their time i know frederick
douglass preceded booker t washington
and death
and i have been doing just like catch-up
greeting because we didn't cover a lot
of this information when i was coming
along in high school so you know i have
a book that lists all of the black uh
uh
people that were doing a lot of great
things during
for the poor black people during my time
and times before me
that's the first question the second
question that i have is what are the
similarities and differences uh in
general mental attitude between
frederick douglass and uh blacks
today who are struggling with similar
conditions and that's all i'm gonna hang
up and uh receive the answers to those
questions
thank you ma'am edna medford it's
sure it's interesting that you would
bring up washington because the two men
were similar in some ways um
certainly booker t washington was
arguing well let me let me back up just
a minute um
washington becomes the leader sort of of
uh of african americans
as a consequence at least from the white
perspective as a consequence of his um
atlanta cotton exposition speech in 1895
so he as douglas is moving
away from the scene
washington is advancing
both men
certainly had interest in industrial
education industrial arts education
douglas attempted to establish a school
for african americans that would teach
industrial arts we know of course the
book of t washington was instrumental in
the founding and development of tuskegee
institute which was the premier
industrial arts institution of
the late 19th century at least one of
them certainly
but the two men differed as well in
terms of
washington being willing to
forego
political equality
social equality
for the moment
and
embracing instead economic opportunity
with the belief that eventually african
americans would earn the respect of
white americans as a consequence of
their economic abilities
douglas too believed that
african americans would earn the respect
of white americans through that same
process but douglas was not willing to
forego
social equality and political equality
he wanted it all now and so i think
that's the difference between the two i
want to move on to the next call this
one from um
college park maryland you're on the air
yes good morning
my name is karen needles
i'm an education resource specialist
with the library of congress
we have our american memory collections
online and we have many of frederick
douglass's writings online
i would like to have the commentators
talk about the parallel between the
educational background of abraham
lincoln and frederick douglass
and possibly how during the lincoln
douglas debates frederick or lincoln
said that
the black was not his parallel or his
equal but when he met frederic frederick
douglass i think he did meet
his equal thank you all right thank you
professor
um blight lincoln and douglas it's a
very good question they had a
conflicted but eventually very rich
relationship
lincoln's education as most people know
was very limited in terms of again
formal education
both lincoln and douglas ironically read
the colombian order one of the one of
the first books that abraham lincoln
purchased in salem illinois when he was
a teenager or a young man in his 20s was
the colombian order this manual of
orator in this collection of speeches
about reform from the age of the
enlightenment
both of them had
an almost mysterious
use of language
an ability to to find the beauty in
words
which is quite stunning now lincoln of
course developed it over time as a
lawyer and as a politician and as a
voracious reader just like douglas did
their relationship is fascinating
they met three times
at the outset of the civil war douglas
like most black abolitionists was not
certain at all whether to trust abraham
lincoln whether to trust the republican
party he supported lincoln he supported
the republican party but in the first
year or so of the civil war douglas was
one of lincoln's fiercest critics
because of course the lincoln
administration was not moving to end
slavery
but what happens during the course of
the war simply put is the two of them
actually evolve
ideologically toward one another
the vision that douglas had of this war
that it ultimately had to be a
sanctioned crusade to crush slavery in
the south in order to save the union is
eventually of course what the war became
it took lincoln a while to fully
understand that but once lincoln did
embrace
emancipation once he issued the
emancipation proclamation he never
really went back on it
and in many ways the most extraordinary
meeting during the civil war that
lincoln has with
a public leader is the time in 1864
when he called frederick douglass to the
white house this is the summer august of
1864. lincoln doesn't believe he's going
to be re-elected that fall the war isn't
a terrible stalemate in virginia
sherman has not yet captured atlanta
lincoln invited douglas to the white
house to ask douglas to help him
organize a system of funneling fugitive
slaves out of the upper south into the
north so that as many slaves as possible
could be freed before that fall election
when lincoln believed he probably would
be defeated
i would
suspect although lincoln never wrote
this down and told us
that that both of them must have looked
at each other in their astonishment
because where they had been in 1861
was in bitter disagreement about where
this war was going here they were in
1864 trying to plan together how best to
free as many slaves before the war would
end and of course after the war and i
won't go on about it but after the war
douglas contributes greatly to
the the eulogies and to the legacies of
abraham lincoln he gives a whole variety
of lincoln speeches late in his life
of very different kinds
of different places the uh caller had
mentioned booker t washington and you
are going to meet a little later in the
program the
woman named niddy washington douglas who
is the great great granddaughter of
frederick douglass and also the great
granddaughter of booker t washington
she'll be with us as we continue but
right now i'm going to talk about
that first part of frederick douglass's
life when he said he lived the life of a
slave
and
where his life
where he spent his life in this world we
want to show the audience a map of
of this country that were that features
the key locations of his
activities that includes
a place called talbot county
on the chesapeake bay not only is london
in the picture but so is the chesapeake
bay area and
the place of his birth has always been
um a little bit unusual in that no one
really knows exactly
where it is but we do have video that
you're seeing on your screen right now
something called aunt betty's lot and
cabin site now i know that you had been
there dave david what what's your
impression of this place where frederick
douglass is supposed to have been born
well my only experience of trying to
find it was with the late dick preston
who wrote a book in 1980 called young
frederick douglass preston was a retired
journalist who was living on the eastern
shore and i was a fledgling graduate
student trying to do my research i
contacted dick and he took me out there
he took me on a trek back through a
muddy cornfield on a day in july to a
bend in tuckahoe creek where he informed
me this is where uh
douglas's grandmother's cabin would have
been and this would be douglas's
birthplace i had no reason to dispute
that
and i suspect he was probably right at
least within
some feet or some yards
i was also taken at that time on an
extraordinary tour of the eastern shore
by preston who knew the site so well
um
to the y plantation where douglas lived
as a child to the freeland farm where he
also lived as a slave and also to the
property of edward covey who was the
slave breaker
that douglas was sent to for a year when
he was 16 years old
those those places on the eastern shore
are the formative years of douglas's
life he lived there and in baltimore the
first 20 years of his life and that's
about 80 miles from where we're sitting
here today huntington beach california
go ahead
good morning sir
uh what i wanted to ask you was you said
earlier in the program that
douglas understood the declaration of
independence and he understood the
constitution
and you also said that he taught himself
how to read and write
now it seems to me that if he understood
the constitution and declaration of
independence
then he understood that it it didn't
include it and in particular at that
time it did not include uh black people
and so then years later uh
he criticizes it or he criticizes white
america for what
he understood already as being something
that didn't include him anyway as far as
original intent was concerned
thank you edna medford
um
he he did understand that uh he was not
included uh
in a very specific way
but he felt that uh there was enough
embedded in the constitution and
certainly in the declaration of
independence that would suggest that at
least the constitution was not
pro-slavery and that certainly was
enough to give him uh sort of a foot in
the door to sort of press the issue he
believed that the constitution would be
fine if americans would simply abide by
it that
there were certain principles that
existed upon the founding of the country
that if americans would only embrace
those principles
then uh all people would be included in
the nation's society
kim elder is uh
back in the house we're going to take a
short look with her at uh kim elder what
room are you in right now bruce i'm in
the dining room now it's the largest
room of the home
and what is it that's notable about this
this room and and what does it say about
frederick douglass's life well i want to
first note that it's a very very
beautiful room um it houses some of the
most exquisite china's and silverware
that you'd find probably throughout the
world which we of course know that
douglas acquired during his travels um
and again it's here in this room that i
would almost say that douglas
shows just how wealthy he was we're
talking about a very very wealthy
gentleman a lot of times people visit
the home not assuming that this was not
a very wealthy man when in fact he was a
very wealthy man and he and his family
lived very very well
and he ate from some of the very finest
china in the world
let's take a call from fort washington
maryland go ahead please
good morning my name is kim short kim my
name is tina short and i'm the very
proud mother of kim short elder and i
like to tell the entire listing audience
that i think it's so wonderful and it
still goes without saying to train up a
child in the way you'd like them to go
and they will not alter she's been
visiting that home ever since she's
approximately seven years old and has
read everything that she could possibly
read on frederick douglass so again i
take my hat off to you i am very proud
of you and continue to find work with
the national park service your mom
well well well well kim
i heard that thanks mom
well we ought to mention that you've
been here quite some time how many years
have you worked in this i've been with
the national parks now for 14 years and
believe it or not all but three of those
years was spent here at the frederick
douglass national historic site and
that's your last caller my mom just
stated i've actually been
working here at the douglas home as a
child
as a junior ranger and later on as a
volunteer with the national park service
so the douglas home is a little bit more
for me than just a job or a career well
let's take a look at the west parliament
okay well let's go inside and take a
look in the west parlor where we know
the family would have been entertained
by their father grandfather when they
came to visit cedar hill let's keep in
mind when frederick douglass purchased
this property in 1877
he had five children and they were all
grown but they were frequent visitors to
the home and again it was here in the
west parlor that the family would
entertain one another now keep in mind
no electricity no tvs radios and vcrs
bruce so when they gather together they
often entertain one another through
music song dance and poetry
this family enjoyed entertaining one
another through music his oldest
daughter rosetta and second wife helen
played the piano and frederick douglass
not only taught himself to read and
write he also taught himself to play the
violin but he didn't stop there he also
taught his grandson joseph joseph
douglas to play the violin is that his
excuse me is that his violin on the top
of the piano this is one of one of
douglas's violins here in the home there
were approximately three violins that
the park service is aware of that he
actually had here in the home
and i think that you're going to point
out to us a photograph of abraham
lincoln i know you all have been talking
about lincoln and lincoln's photograph
is always hung right here in the west
ball of the home these gentlemen were
very good friends douglas served as an
advisor to lincoln often advising him on
the treatment of african-american
soldiers who were enlisted in the united
states army
of course we know that douglas had two
sons who actively fought for the 54th
regiment of massachusetts and and a lot
of times the question that visitors want
to know is did this picture actually
hang here in the west parlor a room so
near to the family and yes it did so we
know that this was a a very genuine
friendship that douglas and lincoln
shared amongst one another elder thank
you very much your mother thanks you we
thank you we'll come back in a bit in
the meantime chatham new jersey is next
go ahead
hi
my name is roberta francis and um i do a
lot of work with women's rights and i'm
aware of the very
i would say simplistic characterization
of some of the white women suffragists
in the 19th century as racist because of
the dispute over the 15th amendment uh
douglas being on the other side of that
but there's a very different sense also
when the suffragist statue was raised in
1997 to the capital rotunda actor fred
marcel as douglas spoke of the deep
respect he had for um
lucretia mod elizabeth kd stat and susan
b anthony
and i know the background of anthony
being a neighbor in rochester and
stanton especially
taught him the gospel of women's rights
as he said and he stayed in her home way
back in the 1840s
and she in fact was one of the few
people who supported
edna medford to talk about because we
promised an earlier caller we'd get to
it lincoln
to frederick douglass and women's
suffrage
let me say uh first of all that
women were a very strong element in the
reform movement for movements of the
1830s 40s and 50s especially in the
abolitionist movement
and as they became more involved in that
movement they came to recognize even
more fully if not they if they hadn't
even before that
that uh their rights were being abridged
as well
and they started demanding uh certain
rights especially the right to the
suffrage so in 1848 they had a
conference at seneca seneca falls and uh
sort of outlined some of the outrages
that had been perpetrated against them
by men
and douglas at that particular
conference uh stood up and spoke for the
rights of women to the vote the clash
comes in 1868 69 when congress is trying
to determine whether or not
black men are going to be on getting the
right to vote and women at that time
have no problem with black men being
given the right to vote but they want
the right to vote as well and douglas
feels and tells themselves that
black men absolutely have to have the
right to vote because they have no other
options if they don't that women do have
some other options and he's very much in
favor of them getting the right to vote
but if there is uh one or the other then
he would prefer that black men have that
vote that it is an absolute necessity
for survival standing by as promised is
nettie washington douglas she's seated
in the west parlor here at cedar hill
she is as we said the great great
granddaughter of frederick douglass and
the great granddaughter of booker t
washington good morning miss douglas
good morning how are you we're just fine
now just talk a little bit about your
heritage and and what it means to your
life today in the year 2001
oh my big question um
i cannot find the words to describe the
pride that i have in this heritage
that as my mother told me so often i had
absolutely nothing to do with
but
as i have
matured
and learned more about
whence i come
i can't find the words i am just being
in this room you know frederick douglass
is an amazing man
and
i have a hard time believing i'm really
related to him
um well exactly what is how does it work
your father was frederick douglass iii
my father was frederick douglass iii and
actually he was numbered out of order i
think you might say because if he truly
were well he was the third
one would assume there then that he was
the um
grandson
of frederick douglass but he actually
was the great grandson his father was
joseph the violinist and
he married the granddaughter of booker t
washington i happen to have a picture of
my mom and dad i'd love to share with
you if i may please do
this picture is actually their wedding
picture
um
am i doing that you can see without a
glare is that okay it looks very good
this was actually taken in the home
of booker t washington at tuskegee in
the den
my mother of course is in the middle her
name was nettie hancock washington
to her right is my father frederick
douglass iii
and to my mother's left is her brother
booker t washington iii
so this picture i love sharing with kids
when i go to school to the schools and
and share my heritage and tell them that
in this photo you have frederick
douglass iii shaking hands with booker t
washington the third we want to go back
to culture in a minute but it sounds
like you spend a fair amount of time
in some activity in some active way with
your heritage exactly what is that i do
well um it started actually it started
long before i remember
when i was in school
in elementary school and i went to
school in los angeles i was born in
tuskegee uh we had negro history week
and during that week i instead of being
in class learning about my my ancestors
i was off with friends who were giving
reports on either book of washington or
frederick douglass and the mother would
call my mom and say ken honey which is
my nickname um come to school with
marilyn she's giving a report and nobody
believes that we know a descendant of
frederick douglass and booker washington
so i'm off helping my friends get a's
and
not in class learning
even before then i've seen pictures of
me maybe about two two and a half doing
something doing black history excuse me
negro history week which of course
became black history month
when my kids were in school i started
doing more as favors to their teachers
to come to the classes since moving to
atlanta
and i don't have the responsibilities i
used to have my kids are all grown i
have been urged to to do this and i love
it i love it i go to schools as often as
i can
and
i don't lecture
uh i don't
even think of myself as giving a history
class so much as just sharing my family
maybe calling it the living
visit well we appreciate you doing it
here today and today won't you stand by
and we'll take some more calls uh for
now all three of us and our next call is
from apple valley california you're on
the air yes thank you thank you happy
memorial day to you all uh
thank you so much
in the early 90s
i had the opportunity to uh
do a paper which i entitled uh
the use of the black press in the uh
black abolitionist movement
and during my studies and research for
my paper i was introduced to so many
uh black publishers writers novelists
authors of all kind people whom i just
never even
dreamed of existed
in the united states there's so many of
these people who we just
overlook in our history lessons but two
in particular that i would like to know
if maybe uh frederick douglass was
influenced by one was a man named david
walker
who wrote a very powerful book and the
other person is henry h garnett who gave
tremendous speeches at something called
the black national conventions that were
held
okay sir thank you we've got those two
names and i see uh uh expressions of
recognition uh edna medford yes uh david
walker uh and henry hyland garnett uh
both uh men who were very impatient for
the end of slavery
and certainly were willing to uh use
force to effect that end of slavery if
need be david walker in 1829
wrote
a letter to enslaved people a pamphlet
indicating that they should rise up
and uh fight against with arms and and
uh challenge the institution of slavery
and henry hyland garnett in the 1840s
also suggested a similar kind of thing
douglas did mention them on numerous
occasions i remember in one speech he
says remember
nat turner remember david walker
so he certainly was aware
of the um
the agitation in their own ways of those
two men
uh the extent of which he was influenced
by them specifically i'm not sure i
think he was more influenced at least in
his earlier years by william lloyd
garrison uh he started reading the
liberator very early
and uh certainly
stayed with the garrison uh philosophy
for uh quite a long period of time
before breaking with him over the over
the issue of uh political agitation i
want to remind everybody that this is
this program on frederick douglass
focusing on his book the narrative life
of frederick douglass and american slave
is only the first in a series of four
american writers programs on slavery in
the civil war our next call is from
huntsville alabama go ahead please
uh good morning
i appreciate c-span also appreciate this
wonderful discussion uh by the two very
learning professors
uh i i wanted to uh ask a question miss
mr elder had made a very interesting
comment that uh in the douglas library
was a copy of the bible and also the
koran
as a
as an american muslim i'm just curious
if frederick douglass had done any uh
writings about
about islam
thank you david blight
now i know of nothing that douglas wrote
about islam
that he would have owned the koran is
not that surprising he collected books
widely as we have said but i don't
believe that douglas ever wrote
anything about the islamic world about
islamic culture
as a faith that doesn't mean he didn't
respect it
he wrote a great deal uh directly or
indirectly about the nature of
christianity and particularly of the
nature of the christian view of history
with which he was so deeply imbued if
you pick up any douglas speech almost
any douglas speech especially before the
civil war
and so many of his editorials you'll
find them laced
with passages quotations even just
single phrases
particularly out of the old testament
so there's no question that theology not
only fascinated him but deeply informed
his worldview
uh and that he may have read the quran
as some influence on that worldview
would not be surprising but i know
nothing that he actually wrote about it
escondido california is next oh yes
hello my name is vicky arcy i'm calling
you from escondido it's about 30 miles
north of san diego uh this is sort of a
follow-up to the question that mr blight
just started to answer it interested me
when he said that
frederick douglass had understood the
fiction of racial distinctions and some
years ago i had heard a man on a
religious radio program mention that
according to god there is no race but
the human race and any distinction
between human beings on the basis of
race has been made up by men and is just
a snare to cause dissension between us
uh because charles darwin has some real
pointed facts about
different races and how they related to
each other and did make statements
uh
about
negroes and that perhaps they were not
as human as caucasians i was interested
to know if frederick douglass read him
if he had an opinion about charles
darwin
uh
all right ma'am thank you very much
professor blight well yes doug was read
darwin but we can't really blame darwin
for what uh human societies and cultures
have done with his theory of natural
selection darwin intended that to be
applied to the species all species of
the world what flowed out of
out of the origin of species is of
course this
philosophy this uh this idea of social
darwinism which became
pervasive by late 19th century by the
late 19th century in america this notion
that that well that humans were like any
other species some groups of humans were
stronger than others and therefore it
must be race
which have become such a powerful and
defining fact of 19th century life
it must be that some races are stronger
than others and some that are weaker
than others douglas frankly hated social
darwinism
criticized it and condemned it at every
turn he was especially animated by this
theory that evolved after the civil war
that somehow with emancipation being
freed from slavery blacks were were
reverting back to barbarism as the
phrase went and didn't even use that
term in a speech that i hadn't read from
this notion that somehow blacks were
reverting to some kind of lesser and
animal behavior
outside of the protections of slavery
was a theory that douglas absolutely
abhorred and in that sense developed his
own critique
of social darwinism
or deposit alabama is next
yes i'm doing a dissertation on
the black women's movement and i'd like
you to expand on
douglas's role with the national
association of
colored women's clubs and secondly
i'd like also for you to speak to the
incident uh with
anthony and caddy where they
barred him from the women's uh movement
in atlanta meeting because they were
courting the southern white women
for suffrage and then excluded blacks
thank you
all right ma'am thank you are there any
takers does anybody know about this
incident
i don't remember the incident no no
he he well as edna said he divided over
the 15th amendment over women's suffrage
quite bitterly with the leaders of the
women's suffrage movement uh his
associations with the black women's club
movements
would have been somewhat limited because
those are really happening and evolving
in the 1890s and of course douglas died
by 1895 but he had many close friends
mary church tyrell ida wells barnett and
and several others who were the leaders
and creators of that club movement and
it certainly was also his social strata
of of women reformers among blacks that
he would have associated with every
chance he got well by my account we've
got two dissertation writers here this
morning and we're batting 500
so while we think about that next call
san francisco you're on the air
uh happy memorial day
um i wanted to ask you if the the panel
was familiar with the recent
book by gregory stevens
called on racial frontiers which
presents a
portrait of frederick douglass as being
not not just not only black but but
multiracial
and he um he he brings up that
that douglas was very proud of his
scottish scottish dissent as well as his
african descent and also his native
american descent and all
in fact when douglas was being
photographed he he said do you want me
to face to the left so you get the black
or to the right so you get the uh
so you get the white and he also all
right sir thank you
thank you very much uh any familiarity
with that comment of his it's a
physician
that douglas would have had no problem
with in terms of the multi-racial aspect
of him
it is something that he acknowledged
throughout his life
he had no problem with it he was who he
was he was not ashamed that he was of
mixed race he did not
promote
one element of himself over the other
the fact that he did
spend so much time with the issues of
african americans certainly was a
necessity because he had suffered as had
other african-americans
the disadvantages the horrors of slavery
and had suffered with other african
americans the injustices that came even
with freedom so it made perfect sense
that he spent a great deal of time
addressing those issues and his scottish
heritage of course if you can call it
that is reflected in his name he
actually chose his name from a character
in uh sir walter scott's our lady of the
lake uh douglas the protagonist to which
he added one s for his own distinction
um
he was he was proud of all of these
heritages if you want to call it that
but edna is exactly right
uh douglas
hoped and believed and wished that that
the fiction of race could somehow
be driven out of american culture
however he also knew that that was
impossible in the 19th century
it's good that some scholars are
beginning now to treat douglas in this
multiple way though
and it has taken i think some time
for us to do that this is the first of
four american writers series programs on
slavery in the civil war we'll continue
in a few moments with edna green medford
david blight and nettie washington
douglas and we'll also see more of cedar
hill the home of frederick douglass and
we'll be back after that
[Music]
is
on monday we continue our american
writers series a look at the nation's
history through some of our greatest
writers and their works
next week we're live from the harriet
beecher stowe house in cincinnati ohio
she was a writer and philanthropist best
remembered for her anti-slavery novel
uncle tom's cabin
we'll look at what spurred harriet
feature stowe to write the novel and
we'll also discuss her family and their
writings
you can see it here on c-span at nine
a.m eastern
in just a moment we'll return to our
american writers program on frederick
douglass
after that a panel discussion on
resistance efforts of slaves in the u.s
then we'll take a look at the library of
frederick douglass
and at midnight we'll again show you our
american writers program on the slave
order abolitionist and presidential
advisor
[Music]
saturday evening on c-span's special
profile of supreme court justice stephen
breyer you'll hear from cliff sloane who
headed up the clinton white house team
to confirm justice breyer
robin linhart his former law clerk
and barbara perry author of the supremes
essays on the supreme court of the
united states
a profile of justice stephen breyer on
america and the courts saturday at 7 p.m
eastern 4 pacific
for the mafia characters on hbo's
sopranos harmful stereotypes
prime time saturday cultural critic
camille paglia joins rolling stones bill
connelly and james walcott of vanity
fair to discuss the hit series on
c-span's american perspectives
then douglas wilder former governor of
virginia and descendant of slaves talks
about slavery as the human cost of
democracy
all on american perspectives this
saturday at 8 pm eastern and pacific on
c-span
next week british voters will elect a
new government and this sunday will show
you the two leading candidates for prime
minister including incumbent tony blair
as well as william hague head of
britain's conservative party
the british elections our special focus
this sunday at six and nine pm eastern
and pacific on c-span
this sunday on c-span's book notes
before the storm barry goldwater and the
unmaking of the american consensus
author rick perlstein's look at
goldwater's life including the aftermath
of his failed 1964 presidential bid
against lyndon johnson after the
election passed and it's the wednesday
after the election people were saying
conservatism was finished for good
that we now lived in a liberal republic
that uh if the republican party ever
veered from the center
and embraced conservatism as its
organizing principle there wouldn't be a
republican party and there might not
even exist a two-party system that's how
kind of discombobulating this whole
thing was in american history before the
storm barry goldwater and the unmaking
of the american consensus
this sunday at 8 eastern and pacific on
c-span's book notes
and visit booknotes.org for online
archives transcripts and first chapters
of many of the books seen on book notes
next monday we'll continue our look at
the june 7th british election when the
bbc's news night will profile british
prime minister tony blair
live coverage monday at 5 30 pm eastern
here on c-span
now the rest of this week's american
writers we continue to look at american
history through frederick douglass a
slave order and eventual presidential
advisor he wrote one of the most
important works on slavery in his first
autobiography the narrative of the life
of frederick douglass
this portion of the program's just over
one hour
harriet bailey gave birth to frederick
augustus washington bailey in february
of 1818
in a cabin on aunt betty's lot
aunt betty was his grandmother betsy
bailey
he married anna murray a free negro
daughter of slaves in 1838 and had five
children with her
after her death in 1882 he married his
former secretary helen pitts in january
of 1884.
james polk was the president and the u.s
population was 20 million 182 000 in
1845
when his first autobiography was
published
shortly after his attempted escape while
working as a field hand to william
freeland he was sent back to baltimore
where he learned the caulking trade and
planned his eventual escape
when hugh alt agreed to sell frederick
douglass's manumission
british admirers raised the fee of 150
pounds sterling
in a meeting at the white house
president lincoln assured frederick
douglass that his protests of
discrimination against black troops
would be given his every consideration
the southern states are those that
seceded and are commonly referred to as
the confederacy
the border states are those slave states
that did not secede
1860s census statistics also reflect
that in the southern states virginia had
the highest number of free-colored
persons numbering about 58 000
in the border states maryland's
population of free-colored persons was
nearly 84 000
on december 31st 1862 frederick douglass
and others gathered at boston's tremont
temple to celebrate the issuance of the
emancipation proclamation effective at
midnight
all of frederick douglass's books were
autobiographies
in a moment we'll return to cedar hill
frederick douglass's home in washington
d.c for part two of this week's american
writers program
[Music]
we are back at cedar hill the home of
frederick
douglass now a national historic site
managed by the national park service
to talk about
frederick douglass his life in
leading up to the civil war with our two
guests
professor david blight and professor
edna medford and
let me start with edna medford to talk
about harper's ferry john brown
what role those two names have in the
life of frederick douglass
john brown was totally committed to the
freedom
of enslaved people
and so proposed in 1859 to take over the
federal arsenal at harpers ferry in
virginia
and to then
arm the enslaved population in the
vicinity and facilitate
a war against slaveholders and that
eventually that would end slavery he
attempted to bring frederick douglass
into the planning and in fact douglas
met with brown at chambersburg uh
pennsylvania
and douglas decided
that it was not the smart thing to do
that it would never work and also
douglas was concerned that it was an
attack on the federal government and he
was not willing to do that an attack on
the slave holder or slave holder's
property to the extent that he was quite
willing to uh facilitate the
running away of enslaved people but not
willing to attack a federal arsenal
brown wanted desperately for douglas to
become involved and douglas utterly
refused to do so
this is the american writers series this
is the first of four programs on slavery
in the civil war focusing on frederick
douglass who was an author of a number
of works and we haven't really talked
much about his lectures
uh which have also appeared in print but
focusing on his slave narrative it was a
genre during the years leading up to the
civil war this one is widely known by
now he's also written
some other by autobiographies
and um we are trying to teach american
history by focusing on american writers
and let us continue that with
um david white we've been talking we've
been talking about
um
you've been talking about his
use of language but can you characterize
for us
what it was like to sit in a lecture
hall in the 1850s let's say and hear
frederick douglass what would the
experience be like
well this was the golden age of oratory
in in america something we're not
accustomed to today at all
most people today wouldn't sit through a
speech longer than 20 minutes probably
douglas was a great natural speaker he
had great natural grace on the platform
however he also studied the techniques
of oratory he was quite self-conscious
and reflective about the nature of
orator including even gestures
and the use of language and the use of
repetitiveness in speaking he read this
in the colombian orator he also read
other uh oratory manuals uh so this
isn't something he was simply
born with he studied it he practiced it
what did his voice we're told he had a
deep baritone voice that he could
modulate his voice that he had that
classic orator's technique of beginning
very slowly very calmly and working
toward a crescendo he was also a
performer
douglas saw oratory he actually wrote
about this quite self-consciously he saw
oratory as both
argument and performance
and one of the things he was such a good
performer at was mimicry
one of his favorite uh techniques in an
abolitionist speeches was to mimic uh
what he called the slaveholder's sermon
he would mimic a slave holding a
pro-slavery preacher at a
at a pulpit he also was fond of
mimicking southern slave-holding
politicians he had a routine that he did
particularly after 1850 in the fugitive
slave act about daniel webster john c
calhoun and henry clay and he would
mimic each of them
but but douglas ultimately also
uh was a speaker who had arguments
he believed that that oratory was a
total human experience that's what he
called it it was the speaker it was the
audience it was the hall it was the
environment it was the knowledge it was
the argument and he was also brilliant
at this notion of the refrain in many of
douglas's speeches you'll find a single
phrase as a refrain that he will repeat
15 and 20 times over would he encourage
audience response oh indeed he would in
fact in many of his uh
his recruiting speeches during the civil
war when he's out recruiting black
soldiers for the 54th massachusetts
regiment he would sometimes well he
would at the end of a speech invite men
to come forward and sometimes he would
do that by even singing he would often
sing john brown's body or he'd actually
lead the audience in a hymn
which would have made his speeches even
that much more irresistible we want to
take this next call but
how long would he speak at a given paid
appearance a typical douglas speech ran
from an hour and a half to two hours and
sometimes longer and there were even
cases where audiences didn't want him to
stop and he would announce a 10-minute
break for those who wanted to go home
and then he would continue for another
hour he also wrote out his speeches
these were not just extemporaneous talks
are they printed most of them are in
printed form very formal form which of
course he would break from at times but
he very carefully prepared most of his
uh prominent speeches let's continue
with frederick douglass his life and
times oak hills california go ahead
yes
uh first and foremost
to know the spirit to know the spirit of
abraham lincoln and frederick douglass
how else could one say amen
in regards to the constitution
the constitution
is not subject to inclusion but
interpretation
and therefore i hope the mysteries and
the wisdom of these great mans
continue to be found in the constitution
and indexed
to the legislature thank you very much
thank you comment well i think the
caller makes a very good point and in
relation to the earlier caller about
this the first principles of the
declaration of independence those four
great principles were to douglas and
other black abolitionists like precious
ore they didn't belong to anybody in
particular they belong to humanity that
was the essence of the natural rights
tradition and indeed as benjamin quarles
once wrote it was black abolitionist who
refused to allow america to
de-revolutionize its revolution as for
the constitution there's that phrase in
the preamble that says the united states
must guarantee a republican form of
government to all the states
many political abolitionists by the
1850s were tired of the argument that
the constitution was a covenant with
death
and pro-slavery as garrison said and
they began to find ways to convert it
into an anti-slavery document
they were always under duress with that
argument but it was the future
interpretation of the constitution over
time that they saw at stake not its
original intent next call is from denver
colorado
yes
can both commentators talk about
frederick douglass's affair with other
assing the german jewish journalist who
translated his biography autobiography
into german thank you are you say that
as if it were fact
um well i just recently read the book by
maria dietrich she was a fellow at the
w.e.b du bois institute at harvard and
uh i'm not sure if 100 sure that it's
true but uh there's some letters in
there that
that are confirmed let's see what
our guests think about that
well yes i know the book very well by
maria dietrich
there's no question that douglas had an
intimate relationship with a german
woman named marie named otilia aasing
beginning in the
late 18 mid to late 1850s when austin
came to america and running into the
1870s possibly as long as 18 years aseng
was a 48er a german radical influenced
by the german revolution
she read douglas's autobiographies she
came to america after reading my bondage
in my freedom fascinated with this man
and fascinated with the american
abolition movement
they had a close relationship probably
indeed an intimate relationship over
many years
and maria in her book makes the case
often persuasively
that
that assing may have had an intellectual
influence on douglas as well i know of
no references to german philosophers or
german writers in douglas's work
but there seems to be no question that
douglas looked to assing as a kind of
intellectual mentor as well as a close
personal companion
douglas's own marriage was a very
complicated one through those years and
of course he spent a great deal of time
on the road and it's no secret that he
sought
the the close friendships and
relationships particularly of
intellectual women
uh both in america and in in great
britain the one part of the assing story
that uh is still perhaps open to some
debate is exactly what her intellectual
influence on douglas was
there's no way ultimately to exactly
know that and the exact character of the
relationship is also not completely
known because all of the sources for
this at least 99 of the sources for this
are from assing's side they're her
letters to her sister and the articles
that austin wrote in german journals
maria diedrich did a tremendous job of
research to ferret all this material out
in germany
to show us how deep this relationship
was indeed one of the most important
things about it is the way that assing
actually
explained and revealed douglas as a
thinker and reformer to a german
audience through german journals in the
1850s and 1860s in preparation for this
program we asked each of our guests to
go through their
own libraries i guess and choose an
excerpt from the writings of frederick
douglass
that they wanted to comment that the
comment on that they thought was
particularly
uh compelling and i have edna medford
the one you selected this is from a
pre-civil war speech it goes exactly
like this
those who profess to favor freedom and
yet depreciate agitation
or is it deprecate agitation are those
who want crops without plowing up the
ground they want rain without thunder
and lightning why did you choose that uh
the the first part of that that is not
included there is that uh there is there
is no progress without struggle i
believe and so what he's saying is to
people who say you know you shouldn't
agitate uh you should sort of allow
things to progress you cannot
offend people because the abolitionists
offended a lot of people
they were seen as too militant they were
seen as folk who were tearing the
country apart and what douglas is saying
is there has to be struggle there has to
be agitation there has to be this this
kind of effort otherwise nothing is
going to occur cleveland ohio is next
good morning
good morning i have two questions uh i
want to know about
douglas's
parents specifically his father
and what kind of relationship if
anything he had with a man i want to
know about any brothers or sisters that
he had now hang up thank you
all right thank you edna medford yeah he
didn't know his father he assumed that
his father was white uh he had heard
whispers that his father was his owner
aaron anthony
uh so he had no relationship with him
and at least in terms of a father-son
relationship certainly
in terms of siblings he did have uh a
brother and two sisters i believe older
than he but he didn't feel any kind of
real connection to them uh any more than
he did with his mother and he talked
about the fact that slavery did that to
the african-american family that the
kinds of bonds that existed under uh
normal conditions uh in many instances
did not exist under slavery because they
were not allowed to ever bond with each
other next call is portland oregon
yes i'm doctor ernestgal
and uh i would like to ask a two-part
question one on
what is
what was uh
douglas's perspective on blacks getting
an education
as a priority for advancement before the
civil war and after the civil war
and
also what was his international
perspective and
connections
specifically uh his policies on thoughts
regarding the immigrations of blacks in
central america
or africa as exposed by martinor delaney
the first black graduate of harvard
medical school and also what was hey sir
i think we'll do that and we'll do that
with uh dr
professor blight before we go back into
cedar hill to talk to kim elder
well douglas was uh was a tremendous
supporter of education at all levels
particularly at the lower levels i
believe edna may have said this earlier
as early as 1852 douglas
helped to organize a campaign to try to
create what would have been the first
kind of national african-american
industrial school uh for for young
blacks he was a strong proponent of
black colleges black grade schools
wherever they could be created of course
before the civil war uh the black
convention movement and black
abolitionists were so strapped for funds
that anything of this kind virtually
never was created until after
emancipation in the south
during reconstruction
as for colonization and immigration
it was if anything perhaps the most
vexing question of all in the pre-civil
war decade should blacks stay in america
and still keep imagining their future
here or should they try to imagine their
future elsewhere in central america in
africa
perhaps in the west
uh immigration schemes among black
leaders and thinkers were at least as
old as the period immediately after the
american revolution paul cuffey a a ship
pilot
from martha's vineyard of massachusetts
actually tried to lead a campaign to
take blacks back to africa and he even
led a campaign to try to create a colony
in the west douglas almost universally
opposed the idea of black immigration
from the united states
although he was beginning
to soften to the idea in the wake of the
dred scott decision after 1857 and in
fact one of the ironies of the outbreak
of the civil war is that in the spring
of 1861 douglas actually had booked
passage to haiti
to uh to check it out there was at that
point a small campaign to try to
organize
people and funds for those blacks who
voluntarily wanted to to relocate in
haiti and douglas actually had booked
passage to go
see what it was all about
and then came the firing on fort sumter
and he writes that editorial uh passage
to haiti canceled
but he was most of the time a fierce
critic of black immigration and during
the civil war make no mistake nothing
animated douglas quite as much as the
lincoln administration's efforts
particularly during the first two years
of the war to try to create colonization
schemes in central america and in the
caribbean
for
the likelihood of when blacks would be
freed from slavery douglas opposed uh
colonization schemes during the civil
war like he opposed nothing else kim
elder is the park manager here at the
frederick douglass national historic
site she's standing by in uh the cedar
hill home which is really only about 60
or 70 feet from where we are outside in
the lawn kim elder what room are you in
now we're now standing in the kitchen
which was a pretty unusual area for a
19th century home
unusual in that most homes were built
with the kitchens as a separate out
building but again we're talking about a
gentleman who was well ahead of his time
and after purchasing this property in
1877 he saw it very fitting to add on to
the home to accommodate for a kitchen
where meals could be prepared and foods
could be
cooked and served and so we're now in
the kitchen of the douglas home and the
laundry room is
the laundry room is just off to our
right we're going to come on down and
take a look in the laundry room where of
course we know
chores were taken care of house or
chores were taken care of and douglas
again was a very wealthy gentleman who
had persons to take care of his home and
it was the laundry room where of course
most of the chores were taken care of i
want to point out to you again no
electricity in this house so the wooden
tubs and scrub boards and washers were
used to wash the clothes various types
of irons and i even like to point out to
you the cistern a sister knit was
basically added to the home again
after he added on to the section of the
home and the system simply collected
rain water from along the gutters which
ran the length of the home collected in
a nine foot tub underneath and of course
this rain water was used for cleaning
purposes made it very very convenient
for those persons who took care of the
home
elder thank you very much thank you and
let's take our next call this one from
stanley crossroads alabama go ahead
good morning and thank you c-span for
all these wonderful programs
including the american writers series
two brief questions
uh
what is the impact of the member of
parliament wilberforce in england who
successfully led the abolition of
slavery throughout the english empire
and
how did
frederick douglass make his great wealth
that has been alluded to so often this
morning thank you
all right thank you very much and let's
talk about the wealth first of all we
keep hearing about as well what does
that translate into in today's dollars
does anybody have any idea of his net
worth
would you call him wealthy for his time
or would you call him wealthy for a
black man which is it
i would certainly see him as very
wealthy for an african-american but not
necessarily so or a white american um
i think at by the 1880s early
1880s i believe he after he had
purchased cedar hill he um
had wealth valued at about 87 000
without including the house and property
and that certainly is substantial for an
african-american but it certainly is not
among the
the wealthiest of white americans
david wilberforce have you heard well
wilberforce was indeed uh one of the
geniuses of british abolitionism which
of course was first a movement to
destroy the slave trade in the british
empire woven force had enormous
influence
as did several other british
abolitionists on the evolution of the
early anti-slavery movement in the
united states and in fact that that
influence ultimately was
like jefferson's declaration of
independence ironically and ideological
influence what the british anti-slavery
movement from the late 18th century had
demonstrated is that in this age of the
enlightenment that there was this thing
called natural rights that all human
beings were born with certain
guaranteed liberties
and it took of course many many many
decades for there to be any kind of
consensus about that within britain but
it was it was the contradiction the
brutal bitter contradiction of slavery
of owning human beings as property now
to this age of reason this belief in in
human capacities this natural rights
idea that eventually makes an
anti-slavery movement possible in the
united states so it's not just
wilberforce it's the whole of the
british anti-slavery movement which of
course took many decades in great
britain before they outlawed first the
slave trade and then eventually slavery
throughout the british empire
by 1831. as we go to this next call i
want to show you some pictures we took
of baltimore
the harbor area fells point and we do
that because
frederick douglass spent time as a slave
as a city slave doing work
even on his own for wages
in that area and you take a look at what
it looks like today as we go to oakland
california go ahead please
oh yes you're on the air
yes my name is alex mclennan and i've
heard uh several conversations for
mostly professor dave about uh frederick
douglass relationship with uh lincoln's
like i said at the very beginning wasn't
that great i wanted to know if there
were
a personal relationship
between frederick douglass and alexa
abraham
i would like to hear from both of the
professors
thank you
ms medford
the two men grew to respect each other
lincoln understood that douglas's uh
admonished his admonishments during the
war his criticisms of the administration
were as a consequence of douglas being
very single-minded in terms of his
desire to see freedom for his people and
so
lincoln certainly understood that
eventually he certainly did
they did learn to respect each other
when lincoln died
as a token of lincoln's um fondness for
douglas mrs lincoln
actually made a gift of a walking stick
that lincoln had owned to frederick
douglass
and that walking stick is on display
behind us in the visitor center here at
the historic site next call philadelphia
pennsylvania yes good morning a question
for both professors blight and medford i
was wondering about the relationship
between mr douglas and the post lincoln
administrations uh johnson grant and
hayes in particular
was douglas well received by them did
douglas know them
did douglas have any particular
critical opinion of any of those
administrations
thank you professor blight well they
indeed knew him uh he did not have a
warm relationship with andrew johnson
rest assured no black leader did andrew
johnson
was in many ways
um
opposed to the very rights and liberties
that the civil war had created for
african americans douglas had a very
close relationship eventually with
ulysses grant
he campaigned openly and forcefully for
grant's election in 1868 indeed the
black boat had a lot to do with grant
being elected in 1860 the first time
first presidential election in american
history where blacks actually voted on
any scale
he had a reasonably warm relationship
with the hayes administration
after grant after the compromise of 1877
it was hayes who first appointed him to
a federal post here in washington d.c
grant had also appointed him to a post
as one of the as the secretary i believe
to the commission
that went to santo domingo to
investigate annexation
um
what this all reflects is that douglas
had become by this time by
reconstruction what was called a
stalwart republican
he believed that the republican party
was the vessel of black freedom
that it was that party that in spite of
its itself in some ways had brought
about emancipation and douglas in spite
of some events that might have turned
him against the republican party later
in life remained a republican to until
his his dying day
uh in the term in terms of grant he
actually was a personal advisor not much
so in the case of hayes and it was later
president garfield who actually
appointed him to yet another federal
post marshall here in the district of
columbia as we take this next call we
want to show you pictures of rochester
today where there's a statue that was
raised in honor of frederick douglass
and then some pictures of the building
where
he had his
publishing venture the north star which
let her become the frederick frederick
douglass monthly
it's not there now there's no particular
marker other than a few plaques
but that's all from rochester where he
spent a large part of his productive
years of agitation i guess would be a
good characterization of that time
concord california is next go ahead
uh my name is charles ross
and uh i have one question
i'm
sort of a
student of this man's history
and my question is why aren't there any
african-american male historians
included in this discussion
thank you
male african-american historians all
right thank you
well i guess we ought to start with
david blight
well there are plenty of
african-american males who have actually
we chose you didn't we so it's it's
actually it's man's fault no yeah there
are plenty of african-american scholars
who have studied frederick douglass
waldo martin who's a dear friend of mine
wrote a book called the mind of
frederick douglass the first modern
biography of douglas in the 20th century
was by benjamin quarles the late
benjamin coral still a very good book 45
year old book now but very readable
there have been many african-american
literary scholars who
have studied douglas in fact it became a
sort of rite of passage in the field of
african-american literature in the 1970s
and 80s to cut your teeth by writing
essays about douglas's narrative and
douglas's autobiographies uh there are
many african-americans who who are
scholars of douglas
i just happen to be
another american who's a scholar of
douglas and i should add that we had as
professor blight said a number of people
to choose from and we chose professor
bite he has a book out that's rather
recent and he's edited the narrative and
he has other credentials as do some
others and
edna medford
is here because she has done work on the
history of slavery and is conversant
with this area but that gives rise to
this question
would frederick douglass have asked us
that question
not at all why wouldn't he have asked
would not have he certainly would not
have been concerned about that
he would want the story to be told he
would want the story to be told well
and it wouldn't bother him
very much who was telling it as long as
it was told well well that gives me a
reason to ask this other question uh
before we go to baltimore maryland for
the next caller um
i referred to
um frederick douglass as a a black man
you responded by saying
for an african-american what was the
terminology then would he ever have
referred to himself as an
african-american for example
probably not and why not because
douglas believed that
people of color
black people colored people negro
whatever term you want to use were
americans he didn't feel a close
association with africa
uh one of the the comments about
colonization you know returning african
americans to africa his response was
we are american you know we were born
here we built this country we shed our
blood here we toiled in the fields here
uh we are americans and he expected to
be treated as such so he probably would
have had a concern about the term
african-american
given his
uh agitation mode how do you think he
would respond to the term use of the
term african-american today
i think that he would have understood
why some african-americans why many if
not most uh desire that term uh douglas
certainly changed with the times uh just
as du bois did he was not the same
douglas of
1838
of 1850 of 1870 of 1895.
and so i suspect that he would be right
here talking about african americans if
we were looking at it from this
perspective today baltimore merlin
you're on the air yes this is in
reference to the august 4th 1857 speech
if there was no struggle there was no
progress i'd like to know where can i
find the full text of that speech
thank you you can find it many places
the quickest way might be in the life
and writings of frederick douglass
edited by philip s foner f-o-n-e-r
uh it's in volume uh two the pre-civil
war decades
i don't know what page but if you just
look up they're all in chronological
order you can find the full text there
you can also find it in what's called
the frederick douglass papers which are
edited by john blassingame
but in at least those two places you can
find the the full text of that and would
any of that be in bookstores as opposed
to libraries um you're more likely to
find those in libraries um but probably
most even many public libraries would
have them but there is also a book that
uh is still on the shelves in terms of
in bookstores that uh is an abbreviated
version of phoner's work that's right
and uh it's a marvelous source because
it doesn't have the multi-volume effect
but it does have some of the most
critical speeches and writings that he
made
absolutely marvelous exactly we're going
to go back and visit with neddy
washington douglas in a few moments
after this call from woodlands texas go
ahead please
yes on the
history teacher for fifth graders and
we talk a lot about harriet tubman i
wondered if frederick douglass had any
relationship with harriet tubman and
also what happened to his sons
who fought in the civil war if i'm
correct uh that they did i believe i am
thanks so much for your program bye-bye
thank you miss medford uh he certainly
appreciated her strength um he always
appreciated the strength of certain
women
african-american as well as white
he had a real kinship with harriet
tubman to the extent that they were both
attempting to
facilitate the ending of slavery in
their own special way one of the things
douglas did other than speaking and
writing about the injustices of slavery
was that
he also was an agent on the underground
railroad used his office and his home in
rochester to help uh fugitives who were
running from uh slavery and i can't
remember
the sons
the children
neither rosetta nor the sons the
youngest daughter dies but uh the other
four children who survived are never
quite
measured up to their father's um
success certainly that would have been a
very tall order i don't know of any
children during this period who would
have measured up to the success of
douglas the two boys serve in the civil
war yes they did um lewis did and so did
charles and massachusetts 54th they were
both in the 54th mass
lewis was actually at the attack on fort
wagner um and survived it of course
uh but was wounded charles was at that
point uh sick and in hospital
but uh they were they were actually
douglas's two first recruits for the
54th massachusetts he recruited about a
hundred members of that regiment let's
go back to meet with uh neddy washington
douglas who is the great great
granddaughter of frederick douglass and
the great
great granddaughter of booker t
washington uh miss douglas you talked
about talking with students a lot about
frederick douglass what is it that they
know about him
well excuse me um when i speak to
or share with the children in elementary
school and and middle school
mostly that he
could not read and write did not know
how to read and write you know he had to
teach
reading like you have to teach that to
himself and they're just amazed to find
out that it was against the law
for slaves to uh even think about
learning to read and write
and of course you know one of the
questions i get which i think is so cute
they always want to know if i knew him
and uh
surprisingly enough i have adults asking
me that too but it what what apparently
happens uh
is that
prior to my coming to the schools of
course the teachers will give them a
little lesson on frederick douglass and
it is amazing how much they do know and
the questions that they ask me
i would like to say if i could just take
a moment that i'm so enjoying this
program myself
and my vcr is taping in atlanta and when
i go back i'm going to look at it
several times i'm learning an awful lot
and i'm happy to say that some of the
information i also do know
but also
i don't know and i'd like to thank
c-span for doing this series um i don't
know whether it was intentionally
scheduled to do
this program here today but i think it's
very fitting given that it is memorial
day
and the fact that frederick douglass's
role in the civil war and recruiting and
as you heard his his sons
and
i mentioned earlier i just envisioned
what it must have been like today back
in the about let's say 1880
here on the grounds with frederick
douglass and celebrating what i believe
it was referred to then as decoration
day
and um in memory of the civil war and to
think about the family because frederick
douglass while we know him as as the
outstanding american the historian that
he that he is the historical figure he
also was a family man and very much
enjoyed having his family with him here
at cedar hill and having picnics out on
the grounds and having the children and
the grandchildren running around well
we're pleased to be part of having his
family still here on the ground well i'm
very pleased to be here i just am well
invited and neddy washing douglas is
going to remain with us for the rest of
the program and be able to take some of
your calls as we move along and as we do
we're going to go to gary indiana next
but we want to show you some pictures of
the highland beach house
which was built by frederick douglass i
don't believe you spent any time there
but neddy uh washington douglas did and
maybe she can talk to us about that but
in the meantime gary indiana you're on
the air
uh yes thank you i had a
question similar to the lady in texas
about harriet tubman but i wanted to
change it
douglas made a statement uh during a
speech about
the fourth of july and how it is not a
holiday in which
should be celebrated at that time by
african americans
what was this thought process about that
thank you i think david blight you
addressed that well i did uh
at the time you made that famous speech
in 1852 douglas was was delivering a
fierce embittered critique of american
hypocrisy about the fourth of july a day
that celebrates liberty and the creation
of the republic but does not include
black people in it the interesting thing
that changes though
and this is in my book on douglas ten
years later to the day
at a place called him rod's corners new
york in upstate new york in 1862 on the
4th of july
once the civil war was underway and by
the summer of 1862 there was at least
the real hope that it was going to be an
abolition war as douglas called it
in that speech in 1862 the pronouns
change he doesn't say it's your fourth
of july you may rejoice
i must mourn he calls it my fourth of
july he calls the founding fathers my
founding fathers it was only the
prospect of black freedom and the
potential of racial equality black
equality that made him feel incorporated
into the 4th of july and all that
symbolically went with that you can rest
assured he desperately wanted to be part
of that but he wanted he needed the
history to happen to make his people
part of it neddy douglas we showed
pictures of highland beach what's the
story behind that building
oh it brought tears to my eyes um the
story behind the building
well as you may or may not know that
highland beach itself which is where
twin oaks
is
was founded by
charles frederick douglass's son
and the home that you're just seeing
twin oaks
was a home that was built by frederick
douglass now you're correct that he died
prior to the home being completed
but i spent
every summer at highland beach from the
time i believe i was two and a half with
my grandmother fanny
howard douglas joseph joseph's wife and
the view from that
the view from that is a chesapeake bay
and of course looking back to the
eastern shore which is where frederick
douglass was born and at the top of the
home
is a little was a screened-in area
called cupola i believe it was
pronounced
cupola and
i remember my grandmother telling me and
it was just large enough for a cot
really not even a full-size bed but a
cut and the idea of that area
was so that frederick douglass when the
home was complete
could go up there and look back across
the bay from whence he came
and so i spent many many many many many
a day in that area all right next call
washington d.c
uh yes hello
i'd like to thank the
c-span and all the guests today and i
have somewhat of a two-part question
concerning frederick douglass his family
and how
his family maintained his estates
and what and how he uh frederick
douglass
uh
organized and if any of the
organizations that he
uh headed
assisted anything into this current time
thank you
all right thank you um
and the medford do you know of any
organization that he started that still
exists today
i can't think of a single one no no i
can't did he ever create any
organizations um
supported quite a few well he created
his newspapers which he was a newspaper
man for 16 years
and
he ceases being an editor of a newspaper
in 1863 then he buys another newspaper
here in washington the new national era
in 1870 which he edited for three more
years
no i know no single organization
although after he dies there was a
douglas memorial association which i
think helen pitts and his daughter
rosetta well that might be created to
preserve this house so the second part
of the question which was about
the family and how it managed the estate
i assume he means cedar hall and maybe
the money do you know anything about
that it was primarily his second wife
ellen tits and his daughter who who did
that
um i can't recall though the length of
time that they were very actively
involved
in it
well we're going to show you some
pictures of the neighborhood here in
cedar uh
hill and it's called anacostia it's
across the anacostia river from the
capitol dome we understand that and we
haven't mentioned this yet frederick
douglass was hail and hearty for almost
all his life and he walked it's roughly
five to seven miles to his office every
day
and as we look at the neighborhood we'll
take this call from martinez california
go ahead please
uh yes my name is steve from marquis
california
and uh it's calling up a great show i've
been through the area and it's
absolutely beautiful
uh what i wanted to know is uh how did
we know from speeches and so forth and
maybe you covered this earlier
that uh mr douglas
attained such a really
large amount of wealth for that era in
time and if there was any person of
color that uh
did we have like a bill gates
that
was that we got it thank you uh edna
medford uh we know he had some
investments in buildings uh some income
from where
uh certainly from the the speech making
he started off with just uh he was
working for the american anti-slavery
society and was not getting very much at
all there were some very lean times
throughout douglas douglas's life as a
free man and it is annamarie douglas who
helped to supplement that income while
douglas was out on the lecture circuit
whether it was in the north uh or the
the near west or in europe it was anna
murray douglas who was out
supplementing the family income either
taking in sewing or in shoe bindery or
whatever so i think she does not get the
kind of credit that is due her
uh by the time he finished uh his his
lecture if he ever did if he ever
actually stopped lecturing i'm not so
sure that he did he would he would
occasionally go back to it even when he
got those other appointments um he would
go back to it uh i think at the end he
was
drawing a hundred and fifty dollars a
lecture yeah and he was doing a lot of
lecturing and it did wear on his body
eventually he'd go on the road for a
month of lectures and come back with
several thousand dollars that was his
main income late in his life after this
next call we're gonna have another brief
visit with kim elder who runs the
historic side here in the meantime
though flint michigan go ahead please
good morning
i uh i began to tune in i was watching
you were talking about harper's ferry
and i just before i asked my question i
want to comment that the last time i was
at harpers ferry i was
a high school student being guided by
david blight
i have a question uh has to do with
david this is dan kildee
hello dan how are you i had a question
about the uh
you're talking a little bit about the
wealth that
that he had accrued one of the questions
i had it seems to me i read that
that
douglas was involved in a bank
after uh some sometime in the 1870s and
it occurred to me that
you know all the discussion about uh
about creating wealth i wonder if he was
seeing far down the road
and uh trying to address some of the
shortfalls that the
the freed slaves later would would uh
would never be able to really fully
realize and that is the accumulation of
wealth
all right sir thank you we've got only a
quarter hour to go in this program david
blight well he did take over the
friedman's bank
freeman savings bank in 1873 as its
president
uh something he regretted later he lived
to regret indeed
it was an attempt at a bank for the
freed people particularly in the south
uh to put their meager savings in
uh and to get loans from what what
blacks in the south desperately most
needed was first land and second credit
and the idea here was to provide a
source of credit but it was never uh
capitalized enough or subsidized indeed
by the federal government in any way
that that it was needed and the bank
actually failed under douglas's
leadership i believe in 1876
he also lost himself some money on that
uh arrangement uh he'd never been a bank
president before uh he'd run a newspaper
but never a bank on this scale but he
believed in it wholeheartedly this was
the one thing more than anything else
other than their political rights that
the freed people so dearly needed credit
but the freedmen's bank really died
because of the way that reconstruction
politics unraveled in the middle of the
1870s kim elder we don't have a lot of
time but we can't leave without hearing
you tell us about these last two rooms
where are you now i'm now standing in
the gentleman's guest quarters and i
should mention to you that whenever he
had gassed all the male gets slept on
one side of the home while the female
guessed up on the other even mr and mrs
douglas slept in separate bedrooms when
they had guests and if they did not have
guests they slept together as husband
and wife in douglas's bedroom or what
we're going to go see just now but
before we leave i want to point out to
you this beautiful desk that was
allegedly given to douglas by harriet
beecher stowe the author of uncle tom's
cabin and it's even alleged that it was
from this desk that mrs doe wrote the
first manuscript of that famous book
entitled
uncle tom's cabin again come on and join
me as we take a look inside frederick
douglass's bedroom
where there are lots of his personal
effects and again i know we're rolling
short on time i want to point out to you
many of his personal items including his
night shirt shoes suspenders waistcoat
everything as we've mentioned
when we started this tour is original to
the home with the exception of the
wallpapers carpets drapes and curtains
we talked about him being a very hearty
man a few moments ago want to point out
to you that even in his older age he was
lifting weights he wanted to keep his
muscles and his arms and hands nice and
supple so not only walked back and forth
from the capitol but he also lifted
weights and i have to ask you to point
out anna's
bedroom before we leave i want to point
out to you that again the women slept on
one side of the home while the gentleman
slept on the other and i want to
specifically point out that after anna
died here in this home which was in 1882
frederick douglass and his family
decided to close off this room in fact
it was kept nice and clean but no one
ever slept in this room again
the room was not open again to the
public until 1972
when the national park service opened it
on february 14 1972 to the general
public and kim elder is the park manager
for the frederick douglass national
historic site managed by the national
park service thanks for all of your
hospitality today thank you for coming
and we enjoy and have look forward to
each of you all visiting cedar hill all
right let's go on back to the phones
waka arizona go ahead please
good morning
um really enjoy the show i was wondering
what doug was being such a high-profile
agitator uh if you would if you will was
did he ever live in fear of his life or
was there
in fact an assassination attempt ever
made on greater douglas thank you
thank you edna medford uh certainly
there was car cause for him to be afraid
he was attacked on numerous occasions uh
while he was on the lecture circuit uh
the abolitionists were not very popular
among most americans and so douglas did
have his uh run-ins with um
ruffians and bullies
it's interesting
he didn't spend a great deal of time in
the south although he did visit the
south after the civil war uh he stayed
uh
didn't usually
go any further than the washington area
in terms of of south he as i indicated
he did make some trips there after the
war but he understood that he was not a
very popular fellow in some areas but
that did not prevent him from speaking
out uh both in lectures and in
newspaper publications and in his
autobiography how sheer are we that his
house in rochester burned down due to
arsonists well he believed that that was
the case
i don't believe that anyone has ever
proven that that's what actually
happened but but it also gave him the
excuse or the opportunity to leave and
come to washington partially because he
understood that that's closer to
the people he wanted to help and also i
suspect he was moved by certain
ambitions he wanted certain um political
plums and he certainly felt that it was
easier to get those in washington
speaking of rochester we want to show
you some pictures of his gravesite he's
not buried here at cedar hill or in
washington he when he died in the foyer
over there he was taken up to rochester
we'll show you a picture of that as we
take this next call from hopkinsville
kentucky hello
you're on the air okay my name is
matthew
i'm not
i'm a new scholar i guess because i'm
just a boy
13 years old
i hope to see miss elder i'm going on
the national boy scout jamboree in the
washington area so maybe i'll have the
fortune of
running into miss elder and getting the
tour
but
my question is i've noticed that you've
spoken a lot of
mr douglas's relationship with mr
washington
and i was
in my studies i had done a lot of
done a paper or two about
washington's belief as far as to help
the advancement of the black people as
compared of a webb dubois
or du bois and i was wondering um if mr
douglas had had any
opinions or if he'd even
knew about mr dubois
all right thank you professor blight
uh yeah douglas was at least aware of du
bois although they never met
douglas dies in 1895.
du bois came of age as a public man in
the early 1890s
although his public profile was not very
wide
douglas and booker t washington whom
you've studied
differed largely on the question of
whether blacks should agitate for
political rights or whether they should
simply
avoid agitation for political rights and
avoid the problem of social equality in
favor of economic advancement that's the
real difference between douglas and
washington that you should pursue
du bois however grew up with a
tremendous sense of the significance of
frederick douglass in fact wanted to
write
a biography of douglas
in 1903 but a publisher asked booker t
washington to to do it first
we're getting close on time and we want
to make sure to get a lot of more things
in so next call mountain view california
go ahead please
hi uh great show um in view of the fact
that there are a lot of white
southerners today who yearn for uh their
southern heritage the south as it was
before the civil war um one of the
panelists said that frederick douglass
was given over to a slave breaker and
i'd like to know with some detail what
slave breaking
involved
to know what these white folks yearn for
thank you sir
any takers
this was when douglas was 16 years old
and he was an unruly teenage slave to
his owner thomas ald in eastern maryland
ald hired him out for a year to a man
who wasn't really a professional slave
breaker but he was known to take on
unruly slaves and try to bring them in
line and douglas lived a full year with
a man named edward covey who beat him
mercilessly at least during the first
six months of that residence
and we don't know for sure exactly how
this fight or this encounter really
occurred because douglas is our only
source in the autobiographies but it
becomes the crucial turning point in in
his narrative and in his autobiographies
it's when douglas flees covey's
plantation after so many whippings and
beatings
and he comes back a tail between his
legs and covey comes after him again and
douglas stands his ground and fights
covey
physically and douglas uses that as his
sort of resurrection he makes it into a
kind of resurrection metaphor in the
autobiography
through physical violence recreating
himself as somewhat more free because
from that day on the last six months he
lived with covey
we're told covey never laid a hand on
him so there's no question that
experience however that fight actually
may have occurred was very pivotal in
douglas's own developing sense of
himself
and the necessity of self-defense uh for
a slave if he could survive it if we
have the time to do it i want to tell
our two professors that after this next
call i want each of you to be thinking
of some kind of a summary
comment about frederick douglass and
today and and to nettie douglas too um
i'll be coming back to you to see what
you think about what uh you've heard
today and if you have any other final
comments but the next call is from
memphis tennessee go ahead please
how y'all doing i i know this program is
very educational my question is for miss
medford uh okay uh after slavery or
the white plantation owners were
given a reparation or whatever you
called it they were paid for the loss of
their slaves and the blacks were
promised four acres of the meal they
never got it how did they defend the
douglas ever give a speech about this
how did he feel about this
thank you
okay um actually uh former slave holders
did not receive compensation for the
loss of their slave property
at the end of the civil war
in the district of columbia there is
compensation because slavery ends in the
district in
april of 1862 by an act of congress and
uh slave holders get an average of 300
per enslaved person as a consequence of
their loss of property
but
others don't
when the 13th amendment officially in
slavery slave holders are not
compensated i can't recall what douglas
says about this
he was concerned however
that there was no economic base
independent uh economic base for african
americans and he understood that the
shipping of the system of sharecropping
sort of um
prevented them from um acquiring true
freedom that as long as there was
economic dependency then african
americans would not be totally free and
certainly the 40 acres
mule or otherwise would have facilitated
that springfield illinois is our last
call this morning go ahead
thank you for taking the call
i have two questions
one rather trivial i suppose the other a
little bit more
substantial first as a teacher of speech
i was wondering how it was that
frederick douglass's lectures and
speeches were recorded did he write them
all out or did he
in fact have someone who was
transcribing them as he spoke
the second question a little bit more
trivial but i'm curious about
uh something that
happened
during his lifetime i'm going to have to
ask you to be brief please
uh the little giant of from
illinois changed his name
and dropped the s off of his name
because of frederick douglass is that
true all right sir thank you is that
true david knight i know no evidence
that stephen douglas ever changed the
spelling of his name if he did i doubt
it had anything to do with douglas and
how was his speeches recorded douglas
did indeed
type out in most cases
his lectures and speeches some of them
in longhand but it is also true that
newspaper recorders reporters would take
down douglas's speeches and you would
get
versions not always verbatim
particularly on his tour of britain for
example in the 1840s the british
newspapers would record his speeches as
best they could let me go to nettie
douglas are you there neddy i am and
what are you taking away from this
morning
an awful lot of information and i want
to thank the callers for calling and the
questions have been great and also thank
you for having an interest in my great
great grandfather it just
overwhelms me and i thank your two
guests and thank you again for
what you do and continue to do what you
do and educating our our young people
and if i may just say to kim's mother
i am delighted kim is back when she
called me and told me she was back here
i feel like a family member is taking
care of the home again
and hi to my kids
and to the new friends i met yesterday
outside of the visitors center the bush
thompson family all right thank you
thank you so much
neddy washington douglas
edna medford final word
i think what we should take from
douglas's life is the understanding that
uh what what he actually said that you
have to ensure
liberty
freedom equality for all people and when
you abridge the rights of any one person
or any group of people you're in danger
of abridging your own rights david blind
well these are the beautiful trappings
here of a successful man but i think we
will know douglas best in his language
in his speeches and in his writing we
understand freedom perhaps best when we
understand its denials and what we also
have in douglas is is a man who
contributed as much as anyone to shaping
the nation's historical memory
particularly after the civil war
and he laid down indeed for all time a
kind of
emancipationist vision a black
abolitionist vision of what emancipate
what slavery emancipation in the civil
war had meant in the middle of the 19th
century we really have no better
spokesman than that we know him best i
think
in his use of words in his use of
language thank you both for being here
also thanks to frank ferragasso kim
elder
kathy ingram and the entire staff at the
frederick douglass national historic
site and to lewis fields at bbh tours in
baltimore comcast cable here in
washington dc
of course to our viewers and to the
entire c-span staff that put up with a
lot of uh
put up a lot of tents and things to
anticipate the rain that did not come
this program will show again on c-span
at 8 p.m east coast time on this coming
friday
thank you all
have a good day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
on monday we continue our american
writers series a look at the nation's
history through some of our greatest
writers and their works
next week we're live from the harriet
beecher stowe house in addition visit
bobwoodward.com
angela davis presents a critical edition
of frederick douglass's memoir narrative
of the life of frederick douglass an
american slave written by himself
miss davis explores the abolitionist's
intellectual life and recalls the
several other editions of douglas's
memoir
angela davis is joined in conversation
by nobel and pulitzer prize-winning
author tony morrison at the new york
public library in new york city the
program is just under two hours
good evening
good evening
hi tony
hi angela
i'm sorry about that entrance
i wondered i wasn't doing it for
theatrics
but i do have a brand new spanking new
hip
ah
i love it i love it i love it
but the rest of the body hasn't caught
up yet
so we go slow
so nobody's moderating us no we're just
talking just talking we're just talking
we're talking about um
douglas
libraries literacy literacy and
liberation
yes yes absolutely let me start
uh with literacy
because i have this document here which
i want
you know other people to uh know about
we'll read it
i'm interested obviously in literacy
i am impressed
with
what i've only recently discovered which
was that this country
is unique in the world
in terms of the distribution of
libraries
throughout the country
uh you cannot go in rural areas
in europe
or in africa or in asia rural areas and
find libraries the way you can here
every little town
not to speak of the huge
university libraries that just jump up
out of nowhere in indiana or someplace
in pennsylvania you go for 100 miles and
there it is you know this enormous
university with more books actually than
cambridge or the libraries in rome
so it's really an extraordinary thing
uh the other thing is about literacy
which
i'm sort of interested in
is uh
on the one hand the power
of reading
and of course
understanding the meaning
of what one reads
and what i like to think of as visual
literacy
visual literacy
which in addition to print or maybe
without print what do people who are
literally
illiterate do
to negotiate around the world
minus people
who
they depend on and i don't mean just
uneducated people i mean people
like myself say in beijing and i don't
read the language
i don't understand it how do you
negotiate
and what are the visual signs that you
need to travel the colors
the shapes
the sounds
smells all the other senses
and it makes for if you have that plus
the ability to read you have this third
dimension an artist's true dimension
of how to read your world
as well as how to read text
and i wanted to begin because i wanted
to describe
the i don't know explosive
the the perception
of reading
particularly certain kinds of novels
as not just
explosive in a dangerous sense but
explosive in a way that could be lethal
and my documentation for this
angela
is this
thing that paul made me bring for my
house
in my guest bathroom
you know downstairs by the front door
oh
that one
over the sink
is a letter from stuart lean
and asking me would i be
willing to come
and receive the nobel prize for
literature
and
write a speech
on the opposite end over the toilet
is this
i know i said
i've seen this many times
in your bathroom tonight
well what it is it was sent to me by uh
an editor
from kanap
it's the
the title is the publication denial
notification
the title of the publication
is paradise
by me
the above publication has been reviewed
and denied in accordance with section
3.9
of the
tdc rules and regulations for the
reasons checked below
now there are five reasons
why
a book would be banned from the
texas department of criminal justice
the first reason is the publication
contains contraband
the second one is publication contains
information regarding the manufacture of
explosives
weapons or drugs
the
fourth one is a specific factual
determination has been made
that the publication is detrimental to
prisoners rehabilitation
because it would encourage deviate
criminal
sexual behavior
and the last one
publication contains material on the
setting up and operation of criminal
schemes or how to avoid detection or
of criminal schemes by lawful
authorities charged with the
responsibility for detecting such
illegal activity and i skipped the third
one because that's the one that paradise
is accused of
a publication contains material
that a reasonable person
would construe as written solely
for the purpose of communicating
information designed to achieve a
breakdown
[Laughter]
not just your average breakdown but
a breakdown of prisons
through
inmate disruption
such as strikes or riots
this is um
[Music]
february 20th right after my birthday
1998 i was amused to get this but i was
also thrilled it seemed like an
extraordinary compliment
that paradise could actually
blow up into a riot in a prison so i
thought in addition to my inquiry about
expanding literacy to visual literacy as
well as print
i wanted to make some connection between
prisons uh
their organization
uh
and the prohibition
and what they understand to be
lethal and dangerous like
reading
like literacy
like understanding it
and i actually wanted to begin
on that theme
by talking a bit about the
inaccessibility of libraries
and i i'm thinking about my own
childhood
when
i saw this incredible
building in birmingham alabama made out
of indiana limestone it was
it was the
birmingham public library but of course
it was only for white people
the one black library that existed was
run down very few books and i tell the
story
because
i first entered
the doors of this library in 1959
and i can remember how it felt to
actually
walk into
a real library because although i had
used the library in birmingham
it was
very lacking
it was broken down finally they built a
new one um
years later yeah many many years later
so
i think
that as we talk about the democratic
impulse of libraries and
and the accessibility of libraries it's
also
important to
talk about those places where books have
a hard
time penetrating and your example of the
texas state
correctional system is one
just before the event
i had an opportunity to look at some of
the items from the archival collections
here
and i saw
i saw
a wonderful collection
of
a periodical that was actually published
by prisoners at rikers island
from i think
1939 to 1940 something
and i was thinking about
you know what
was required in order to um
be able to do that this is for those of
you who don't remember
a period when we didn't have xeroxing
or
you know i looked at it and i said this
was
mimeograph
well i think that's the way that was
that the word mimeograph
uh and
the prisoners who put this together and
the books that they had to read in order
to put
this literary publication together
uh was was was quite astounding so i'd
really like to thank the
librarians for allowing me to see these
documents and i also had a brief
conversation
with
um
what is his name the head of the
correctional
what's his name
what's his name him
nicholas nicholas okay that's right you
were there too yeah
with nicholas
who
coordinates relations between the new
york public library and
the and rikers island
and the women's and the men's detention
facility there interesting so i was
actually telling him about
my experience
in the women's house with detention here
in new york i'm having all of these new
york memories uh you know this
[Laughter]
and um
i um
you know i was in jail in new york i
don't know did you mention that i was in
jail
okay okay some people don't know
and
one of the first places i went
i was able to go in the jail was the
library
and i didn't see very many interesting
books
there
right
i mean i
had just finished my studies in
philosophy and i went to the library
expecting something very different
and so what i did was i had people send
books to me while i was there and i
wanted to share those books with all of
the other women there was something like
a thousand women there
and i was not allowed to do that as a
matter of fact in the library there was
a big cardboard box you could receive
the books i could receive the books and
i could read the books myself it was
okay
yeah for me to read them but don't share
them with them but don't share them
and one of them was george jackson's
book oh yeah soledad brothers that was
not allowed at all although
we did
you know one of the things i learned um
when i was in jail there was you know
how to uh secrete
certain kinds of things
and so we were able to
so we had these clandestine reading
groups with books that were smuggled out
of that box in the library yeah
and it kind of reminded me of frederick
douglass and frederick douglass's effort
to
get an education to learn how to read
and
and his idea that
education really was liberation
absolutely yeah that scene that i'm sure
people who read the autobiography
of his of the master saying don't
teach him in the mistress
wanting to but being afraid to he uses
an ir
interesting phrase in describing
her
which was
irresponsible power right right
and i thought that's just not just
having the power
it's the irresponsibility of how you
manage it
and his hunger
was overwhelming because he knew as we
all know that that was freedom
and the people who did not want blacks
to read
knew that i mean that's why
you know if it had been
you know simple fairy stories it would
have been quite different or not even
that
there is power if you can't read in your
in a place like that they can
cheat you and beat you yeah and the
other root is extraordinary
the things people suffered in order
to read i remember in
in trying to figure this out with in a
novel i wrote a mercy
how would that child learn to read well
she was in
maryland
which was a state charles bought king
charles as a haven for catholics
who were being beaten up
and killed and persecuted in during the
restoration in england
um
the catholics had a different idea about
the soul
of black people than protestants some
protestants did and
not that the consequences were terribly
thrilling but they just sort of reshaped
the definition of
what is a human being or who is the
other
and so that priests would frequently
defy the virginians for example who were
church of england people
and teach
people to read slaves to read children
to read
not that they wanted them to read the
bible but just so that they could do the
catechism and perhaps read
some religious tracts
so there was
that kind of priest
in addition to other kinds which would
not teach you to read but there were
exceptions in the way in which they
interpreted
enslaved people
and i also wanted to emphasize in in
that book
i wanted to separate
race
from slavery
it wasn't really the same thing
we assumed all slaves were black and
that just not was not true
they called white slaves indentured
servants in order to give them
uh legitimate uh they weren't cattle
slavery although they functioned that
way if you had an indentured servant you
could extend their contract forever
any little infraction you could add
another seven years and if they drop
dead and happen to have children
uh you could
use the child to pay off the debt
uh and there were many instances in
white indentured
europeans
work right alongside
black slaves on plantations
and i always remark on this one incident
in that book and what i learned was this
thing called bacon's rebellion
where a group was called the people's
army some landed gentry
some indentured servants and some black
slaves and some native americans
indigenous people all you know
got together
and
deposed the governor of virginia
and they ran things for a month they
weren't so nice themselves but still
i don't want you to think there was this
noble group
going forth they were just another group
anyway when the governor returned from
england they killed them all but the
interesting thing is
that
they established these laws
and the laws were very very interesting
they said things like
any no black shall be allowed to carry a
weapon
ever for any circumstances
second
any white
can maim or kill any black
for any reason
without
being charged
now you see what that did to the
indentured servants who were white
now they're better
freer
more powerful they're the same situation
they're still enslaved but they're not
but they can carry weapons and they can
beat up
black slaves without punishment so they
have this little margin
of status
nothing else nothing else
but that little margin and that little
margin has worked its way through this
country since then
that was in the 17th century
and you know
the southern strategy you know all these
things
in which you
you know flag race and racism
as a cause or even a goal
you know racism is not a goal
it's a path
it's just a route
to power
and money
that's what it is that's what it's for
whether it's via war or segregation or
what have you
the thing itself is just a manipulation
and a tool
and its
purpose
is
um what i just described that went on
after the bacon rebellion
so how did i get there
well you know i was thinking as you as
you were describing um as you were
were describing the conditions then that
um when you were talking about a mercy
[Laughter]
i was thinking about
um
you know frederick douglass's uh that
another passage in the narrative
where he kept hearing this word
abolition
and he didn't know what it meant
and he heard about the abolitionists but
he had no idea what it meant and he said
that at some point he realized
that um
it was connected to something that he
really ought to be interested in
and then eventually i mean he describes
this painstaking process of learning
you know learning how to write and you
know learning how to read when learning
how to write by
looking at the markings
that
were placed on the boards
to be used to build ships
so one would say something
forward starboard f
s
and then he learned those letters f s as
a result right it's amazing and and then
of course he talks about uh bribing
um the white boys to teach him
how
to read and write he says at one point
he dares the a a a a white boy who was
around uh
uh to prove that he could write better
than
frederick douglass himself could now
frederick douglass really didn't know
how to write that much
so the white boy could write a lot more
and in the process he learns what the
white boy was writing uh
so um but the point that i was making
about hearing this word and knowing
there was something about this word
that was so important yeah but he had no
idea what it meant
but he was attracted to it yeah it was
like abolition
abolitionist sounds right
and then of course he becomes uh the
most powerful evolutionists
but that kind of curiosity that really
is only possible um
through a process of education
you know where
which isn't to say that people who don't
know how to read and write don't have
that curiosity but learning how to read
and write opens up a whole new universe
opens up a whole new dimension and this
is why these texas people did not want
the president
yes exactly exactly yeah
why paradise i mean really
and then you know when you consider that
there are now 2.5 million people behind
bars
and what can they really do
what can they do that significant uh
you know reading and and writing really
allows
for the possibility of inhabiting a very
different
world but the control of those 2.5
million people
i don't know about all but
it's such a profit-making
thing now yeah i mean you you have whole
cities i know in upstate new york
that are living off of the benefits of a
brand new prison employment of the
guards the cooks this you know all the
paraphernalia that goes with
imprisonment and i don't know how they
oh i read about somebody one of those
prisons in texas privately prisons with
the business get out no money
when the prisons get out they get no
they owe they owe money oh because
yeah because they have to pay they have
to pay for their own room and board
right yeah they're in college
yes yeah
yeah it's just like the students right
[Laughter]
room and fort you get out and you have
this bill if your family can't pay you
none of you paid your in time for
whatever and then of course the kinds of
laws
that are you know
heavily weighted in certain communities
for minor
offenses and so on not to speak of
um
but i was interested in your in your
book because
i'm not sure i understand fully that
separation
well that's not well the implication is
that there's a difference
well there is a difference between
vengeance and justice
[Music]
but justice itself has some
unpleasant
um
consequences
we have to assume
that if we want justice for some bad
activity by a bad person
we want punishment we want restraint
we don't want rehabilitation
and that assumes that
there is something called the other
there's a stranger
that your neighbor or the criminal the
so-called criminal
is some other thing
is an
other
now i was thinking
along those lines
when i was trying to figure out
another area that is of great interest
to me and has always been but i've never
had the patience or maybe the
intelligence or maybe the research kind
of follow it through
which is what the impact
of
torture
and slavery enslaved meant
and
violence has on the perpetrator
i don't therapists don't seem to be
terribly interested in that
but my feet when i mention the other
possibility it seems to me
that when you destroy
somebody
through
vengeance and or
severe forms of justice
that the real
object
of the pain
really is the self
don't have to go there with me but
that's
you really you know that's why it's so
the menace
is so mundane in a way
um so i'm thinking about these slave
owners
i'm thinking about say women enslaved
women who were pregnant
lying on the ground they make a hole for
her stomach so they and then they beat
her or any other you know sort of savage
response
uh that even the one that frederick
douglass speaks of
it's very clear in his case when he
finally confronts that uh
covey covey
who is kavi i mean
he's he's destroying something that is
in himself
it's not that that person is animal or
soulless or
inferior
if you're strong enough
you know it's it's the fragile
personality
the fragile personality not strong
but the fragile almost erasable
personality that can do that
because there's already the self
contempt
and the self-loathing
and it's in that area that i
well i don't know i couldn't say i'm
working
but
i'm just looking at these various forms
it's so easy
racism obviously is the easiest thing
you can do it's very easy to uh block
off these so-called criminals and
they're away from us they're not with us
we don't even have to be tolerant
because they're over there
but if they're us
if we're doing that in order to corral a
certain kind of behavior
whether it's
scale is high or low in order to
redeem something in ourselves that's a
whole different operation
entirely different
so i want i've read a lot a couple too
diaries or appended diaries
not these sort of little let me tell my
grandchildren what to think of me but
some interesting uh diaries um
of slave owners when they're not showing
off they're just marking how many
barrels and how many this and you know
riding up and down and sleeping with
this and so on it's really interesting
because they're not cruel i mean they do
cruel things
but they're not cruel people
but what they obviously are doing is
working out some relationship
that is so
damaging
to them
really damaging
it's really a form of self-destruction
it's a powerful form of self-destruction
that
i don't care how big the spectacle
you know whether it's germany in the 30s
and 40s it's still a spectacle and it is
about one's own self-loathing and
fragility
that you need that spectacle
well that's my lecture for today okay
well you know i would okay i i've had a
number of thoughts uh oh you have good
one of them i want to put in parentheses
because i want us to come back to it
and and that relates to something that
you said earlier about um
the profitability of punishment
but i want us to think about the
privatization of libraries
regular party
well you know just as we have
experienced over the last
several decades of privatization of
health care
we are witnessing the privatization of
education
and you know i won't talk about looking
for superman and waiting for superman
whatever it's called
uh the privatization of prisons yes but
there is now a company called
libraries
services
library systems and services
that is taking over libraries in some
communities california for example
who pays for that i mean who would how
do well
they make money they make money because
they hire
non-union staff
okay they they either
don't allow the employees to continue to
be members of the union or else they
hire entire entirely uh a new staff and
they probably also cut back on services
because the only reason for such a
company existing is its profitability
well what about the person who wants to
go and borrow a book do i get drafts pay
a fee for
joining the library yet well you know
that up yeah maybe not yet but who knows
what will happen
in the future and it's it's it's very
dangerous uh
the privatization of everything is what
we're in the process of witnessing but
that's what i said i wanted to put in
parentheses uh
the um
oh the other comment i wanted to make
was um
the fact that i
i've been looking at the work of this
woman
from new york's new york her name is
faye honey knopf
she was a quaker
and
helped to publish a book
in 1976 which was called
instead of prisons that abolitionist
handbook
so she was one of the key figures in the
prison abolitionist movement in the 70s
she
she was a quaker who had also been
involved in the anti-war movement and
i just saw
well there's a film with yuri koshiyama
called mountains that take wings some of
my students are here from
syracuse they saw it
and apparently and yuri koshiyama of
course was the
uh
is a an amazing activist a
japanese american activist who was in an
in
tournament camp and
she lived in harlem for many years and
met malcolm x and was responsible for
introducing the survivors of hiroshima
to malcolm and as a matter of fact she
was in the audubon ballroom when malcolm
was assassinated and there's this
incredible photograph of her
leaning over malcolm's body
that's yuri koshiyama the woman i'm
talking about is faye honey um knop
whose daughter told me the other day
that
her mother
feihaniknap worked with the same group
of survivors of hiroshima
that
yuri koshiyama introduced to malcolm x
so i mean it's really interesting you
know all of these
uh k-n-o-p-p
oh i cannot yes yeah
not like alfred
well the point that i want to make is
that um
she came to the conclusion after doing
all of this work on prison abolition
that um
the only way she would and the whole
movement would be able to
move in a progressive direction would be
to demonstrate
that it was possible to address some of
the horrendous problems that
imprisonment presumes to address so she
started to work with child sex abusers
child sex
abusers and she spent the rest of her
life
you know working with
these
mostly men
who had sexually
abused children
because she felt that she had to answer
the hardest question
and she also felt that if we continue to
be
incapable of confronting
those
horrendous
acts of violence that human beings
inflict on each other
that it would never be possible to get
rid of the prison because what we do now
is we say
that
when someone commits such a horrible act
put them in prison where we don't have
to think about them anymore and we don't
have to think about the perpetrators
and we also don't have to think about
the problem or the problem no no and it
continues to replicate itself so in a
sense addressing it in that way
has guaranteed
that there would be this
reproduction
of of the problem from one generation to
the next
and
you were talking about uh the
diaries of of of slave holders and
people who committed horrendous acts and
who weren't necessarily
somebody has a cell phone let's uh ring
a
okay we'll wait
good is that you
[Laughter]
hi
and um
and so yeah
um
and you were saying that uh they they
weren't necessarily evil people they
committed evil acts
and
i think this is something we have a hard
time recognizing today
somebody calls it a case of
mistaken identity
who says that suicide was a case of
mistaken identity
i thought that suicide that suicide
suicide is the case okay i see i see
because you really meant to kill
somebody else yeah
you don't recognize yourself
[Laughter]
so it may be the same
[Laughter]
it may be the same thing you know in a
nutshell theatrical way
when we think
we've put that aside we don't have to
address the problem anymore and that it
does not
that that the activity whatever the
behavior is is somehow
beyond the pale it's not us you know
because
you know i'm getting a little
uh weary with that notion of the
foreigner
you know i did a whole thing at the
louvre called the foreigner's home
the foreigner is home
yeah at the louvre in paris oh the
foreigner
is all this is his home
uh he owns his home because a lot of
foreigners i mean in africa they were
treated like foreigners right
absolutely i mean that's what
colonization is you become a foreigner
and you're in your own home yeah and
certainly it's true with
african-americans you know who have
preceded many many of the people who
came here and native americans and they
don't know really
have been demonized
or the foreigners own home of the
foreigner is home but the the the notion
of the foreigners not just linguistic or
geographical or
community it really is a kind of
severance
deliberate
maybe for status maybe just because
of
of
another group
that is
not doesn't have the advantages you do
one of the reasons
back to this last completed work of mine
about a mercy was that i
know as everyone does that no one in the
world is born
with those attitudes
and prejudices no one
you can
learn them early so long as you're
taught you're in an environment in which
such ideas
can flower
but it's not in your dna
it's not natural it can become
environmentally
you know necessary or you know you live
in a certain world in which there is
none or there is
okay that inner innocence
uh of the
of a human being
i wanted to compare with the
you know this romantic notion of the
innocent american americans are always
anxious you haven't noticed that
uh there are hundreds of books innocent
americans and abroad
so i want to go back before the
institutionalization to see whether
you know these were people coming from
europe for either money or resources or
they were scared to death
i mean you have to have a lot of
something horrible going on to risk two
to three months
in some raggedy ship i mean most of
those things sank
coming aboard you were down there you
know with the animals that's where they
were really chipping they were cows and
pigs and things and a few human beings
next to them and then you come to this
country
with
probably nothing
and it was bountiful certainly that but
what were they running from
usually religion or poverty
but the point was that they did not come
over here i mean italians who came to
this country
were not italians after a while
they were white
but it took a long time it took a long
time long process of becoming white yes
it is a process
i mean
you can't just
then become this you see but the same
but i wanted to get back to that notion
this country
particularly with the political
flavor
and poison
now
uh to to look at what it was like then
when every country wanted a piece of
this this place i mean we could be
speaking dutch now or spanish
or
swedish did you know there was a swedish
empire i didn't
i mean they were all in here doing what
they did you know obviously in africa
taking little bits to claiming this
town's names changed every five years
somebody else would say no no no it's
not
new york it's
this
uh it's not this it's that they change
names constantly but that was the big
thing but the people who were settling
here who were really refugees
came here with some other ideas
so what made this outrageous
the necessity
uh for the level of enslavement and
racism in this country was what i said
money and profit i mean
we this country entered the industrial
revolution like in i don't know three
decades
other countries took
a century
this country in three decades why
because they had slave labor
instantly you don't have to pay them you
have to do anything just feed them and
corral them
and then you look at some place where
they were making sugar in cuba and the
people were dropping they kept bringing
slaves over bringing slaves over it was
a little island
why did they need so many
you get you know i don't know a thousand
slaves to cut
sugar or two thousand or two what why
were they key
then i learned that they were dropping
dead
they died so when guys get another
that's right you just replenish them
they come over here and live a year
yeah
or two they try to get younger and
younger ones right there four years so
you're replenishing them
like putting coal into a furnace um
so that all of this is
my trying to figure out
uh not just the consequences of race
which i did in the first book i wrote
the blue stein but other things around
it
since it seems to
uh you know have a hole these have to be
ferociously
uh
against it or
apologetic about it or you are the
victim of it or the perpetrator of it
and i just want to get rid of that
discourse which doesn't go anywhere and
find out what the origins are
uh what its purpose is
not just a scapegoat purpose but it has
a real function
which is
power and control
and money which is pretty much the same
thing
that's what it's for
it's not something that oh yeah
i
this group of people are like this and i
mean you know we all know that's
ridiculous
and that's why the phrase but one of my
best friends is because we all know one
who's not quite like that
uh and that's part of the staple you
know i'm not really you know but there's
something
in the in the diet
yeah the intellectual diet
and the ignorance you know
of uh
well-meaning people and even their own
work
and i was serious when i said i don't
understand why therapists ignore it or
ignore it the way they do
that's a powerful thing you know
in the mind angela's experience in the
library and somebody else was talking
about having difficulty going into life
it was like alice um alice walker yes
yeah and then she just could not because
she said that she finds it difficult to
enter into libraries today i was um
so hungry for the experience of the
library that i never experienced that
difficulty and i haunted libraries all
over the world for a very long time but
uh tony if they were my home my my first
decent job other than scrubbing
somebody's floors at 12 was to be a page
in the library which i got because my
sister was secretary to the head
librarian
so she brought me in and they quickly
they didn't fire me because i was very
slow
i mean you read the books
so they just moved me to another
department
[Music]
okay tony before you move on there's i
have a response
that i want to share
because
liz i always loved listening to you talk
and i could and i realized that i'm also
here to participate in the conversation
so i can't just sit back like i usually
do
and i'm sorry
you know all of your brilliance
but i you know this this summer i was in
um
colombia as a matter of fact in
september columbia columbia colombia
and
visited a community of people
outside of kali
who live
in this mountainous area
afro-descended people
people whose ancestors were enslaved 400
years ago
who were brought to colombia to engage
in gold mining
and
they still live in the place where their
ancestors settled
when they
escaped slavery so it was initially a
fugitive slave settlement like a maroon
settlement and this the people who live
there now
um
live on the same land and do the same
work
that their ancestors did 400 years ago
they still
mine gold in this
very
different way the women are minors
and the children are minors and the
women talk about mining in this
incredibly passionate way
the guy's mind too
they all mine
they oh my no but i mean it's
interesting that the women say i've been
a miner since i was in my mother's womb
so the point that i'm making is that now
um even though they actually own the
land they have the
they were able to get the title to the
land but not too what's
in the land the subsoil the minerals
and there are a number of big mining
concerns that are trying to evict them
so that they can institute these new
industrialized modes of mining strip
mining
and
one of the mining companies this kind of
complicates our notion of what counts as
racism in this day and age and its
relationship to power
one of one of the mining companies is
called
anglo
gold ashanti
and it is headquartered in south africa
the ceo of the mining company is a black
south african
so
there you go
yeah there we go there we go
and it's it's it's it's also about uh
the way in which racism um has a
has its own um dynamic and its own
momentum
regardless of what who the people are or
what the people think
i mean here's a black south african who
just
how long ago experienced
freedom
from apartheid in south africa and who
is now about to kick these people off
their land people who've lived on the
same land for 400 years
so what kind of a story is that
everybody should write the new president
of colombia we will yes that's one thing
we can all do uh this evening what is
his name um
he just got elected um
we'll find it what's his name not you
uru uribe was was the last president and
a new president was elected just uh a
month or so ago
what's his name
santos
yes that's right santos santos i'll
remember that but you can google it you
can get it you know really right and
write a letter write a letter of protest
that's right
ah what time is it
so
do we want to take any questions from
the audience yes
a few okay well it's about uh wow it's
it's a little after eight now how long
have we been talking about about five
minutes a little less than about 55
minutes so yeah
okay so we'll take a few questions
[Music]
thank you
i want to apologize for that phone it
was from
death row in pennsylvania
oh wow
[Music]
if we're talking about prisons and
talking about inhumanities
and how we are being deprived of so many
brilliant minds that are in prison that
should be
helping to lead the country can we talk
about
mumia
and
the all the political prisoners that are
in prison who should be amongst us
please
well first
uh i would say
um
[Music]
that
you know speaking of literacy
and libraries and liberation uh mumia
abu jamal has made such an amazing
contribution
to all all three of those those
categories
and
yeah this is something that we we have
we have to
save mumia's life we have to save
mumia's life
and this is it's also about the
relationship between
learning
and freedom
it's about the uses to which we put our
literacy
and because of the fact that there's
been this mobilization against mumia by
law enforcement all over the country it
has not been possible to build the kind
of campaign
that we see in other parts of
of the world as a matter of fact mumia
is an honorary citizen of paris
and there's streets named after him in
all over europe in germany
everyone knows his name
and that's why
if he were like stupid and sort of un
right
right but what can we do here yeah where
can we that's that's a question a good
question what can we do
where in philadelphia
[Laughter]
what
[Music]
big demonstration on november 9th okay
okay
and also i think we have to do the work
that needs to be done to build movements
that is to
use all of your contacts to
encourage people to think about this
case
tell people about
mumia
if you have kids who are in school
you know ask
the teachers to talk to the children
about the meaning of living in a
democrat
so-called democratic society
and using
capital punishment as a routine
mode of addressing um a whole range of
issues this is the only industrialized
democracy in the entire world
that puts people to death in this way
and mamia more than anyone has been the
face of the campaign
to expand democracy in this country to
abolish capital punishment and the death
penalty so thank you thank you very much
uh good evening my name is kazimbe um
and uh first thing i want to say is that
um
the women's house of detention is now
the jefferson market library uh which i
think is really ground like
great yeah on 10th avenue
10th street and 6th avenue so that's
awesome um
my question is um you um professor
morrison you mentioned the self and i'm
wondering if that can also translate
into the current
um anger that we see in terms of
immigrants and also but specifically
around uh the gay youth suicides and
bullying as well um and i'm wondering if
there's any thought in terms of the
connection between gender expression and
the race in terms of the hatred of the
self in terms of your research in terms
of mercy but also i know professor mo
davis you've also done a ton of research
on that as well if you can comment on
that
that's clear to me
the answer homophobia
it's so obviously
the violence connected with that it's so
obviously a destruction of the self i
mean it's just blatant you know
to me these others are maybe people
don't realize it so much
but
calling people names and beating them up
hanging people off of fences
and what
i mean it's just so
self-destruct
you know the more vicious it is toward
the so-called homosexual
uh person
the more violence there is toward
oneself and that and i think that you
know distributes itself in other kinds
of scapegoats and
i don't know how do mexicans i mean
police
or board somebody said i read somewhere
that when the berlin wall came down
my prognostication was
uh oh the end of end theoretical not
really but the end of communism is also
the end of raw capitalism
i mean if one goes
the other goes also
and i have been proven right but the
other thing is he said you've been
proven correct
i mean capitalism is not dead
obviously
but it's crumbling well but
it i mean i totally it is it is it is i
told them i know it but most people
don't know it they're terrified by the
notion of not having it and and and i
think that capitalism capitalism
penetrates into that's true our very
emotions in ways that it was never able
to do
that's true and when we look at the
privatization of libraries because
everybody's mad
he's not gonna laugh you can i'm telling
you okay it's tell me uh it's decaying
okay how do you describe it how do you
scramble how do we speed up the demise
of capitalism that's what i want to know
the first thing you have to do is keep
those republicans out of office
yeah cause they're hanging on
tooth and nail
yeah
to
you know capitalism in its rawest form
not even its sort of civilized form but
the raw er the better so that's one way
but
you know
i may not live to see it i'd be 80 next
year but you will
my dear
i'm not that far behind
so that's one thing oh the berlin wall
is interesting is when the berlin wall
fell this is how we talk all the time
all sorts of other walls went up
the one between israel and the west bank
and then the wall in
south
mexico
is a border
i mean all these other walls jumped up
and then they're not physical walls but
there are other kinds of imprisonment
walls i mean we're just constantly
separating in some instances the berlin
wall was so people couldn't get out
now we're building walls so they can't
get in
so you know it's a
constant this shift looks to me long
range
like part and parcel of what i am
certain is
you know this it's the disconnect you
know it's really crumbling when these
people say
i want my
get out of i want the government out of
my
social security
i know i know yeah
it doesn't matter it's all incoherent
well since you're talking about since
you're talking about
since you're talking about capitalism
and communism i want to acknowledge
charlene mitchell he's sitting over
there
[Applause]
charlene was the first black woman to
run for the office of the president of
the united states of america
she was on the communist party
[Applause]
dear hi good evening hi um you know i
was actually my first job was also a
page in the library on 96th street and
i'm also a writer so you've made me feel
really good tonight about my prospects
for accomplishment
um my question is i actually have two
questions and one is um it's about your
ideas around
visual literacy i immediately thought
about movies particularly in the context
of how movies now
are being adapted from books and the
type of literacy that we get from movies
versus what we get from the book it's
always
i would hope the director is walking a
fine line although even with something
like epray love
the general masses were outraged i think
that becomes even more complicated when
you talk about black black movies about
black women in black movies particularly
like
alice walker's the color purple waiting
to exhale and now we have for color
girls coming up and i just wanted to
know your thoughts on
on adaptation um and and film and also
the and just if you could flush out some
more of your ideas in terms of visual
literacy in the realm of um film adapted
from books my second question is a lot
easier how did you two meet um and how
did you end up
writing her uh editing her autobiography
was the opposite way around
exactly thanks does it work i don't know
what she was doing
i had a job at random house
and she was an acquisition that they
were very proud of
and so we got to know each other at that
point i think i had published one book
or two you had published blue science
yes already other times and you were
working on um
no you had already published so you were
working on sound songs solomon i had
published because i can remember you
would like write three or four lines uh
we would we would be driving from your
house to the city across the george
washington bridge there would be traffic
you'd pull out a little note tag
and write or you'd fix breakfast for a
slave and
dino and then you'd write a little bit
here
and then when the book finally came out
i said
i cannot believe it
you know it was so it was like magical
it was wonderful
but also i really i should say that i
really appreciate
what i learned about writing from
tony when i read when i wrote my
autobiography you know i was somebody
who was used to writing
philosophy
and so i didn't think about writing in
the same way
and you know rather than like writing it
for me tony would say
well
you know what was that room like
you know what did it look like what was
in there what were the colors and so she
made me
understand writing in such a a different
way and i'm forever grateful
for that we also had fun you remember
when we went to
the virgin islands
i made you and i made you walk from one
end of the island to the other
there was nowhere
there was nowhere in the united states
where angela could feel safe and right
so
so we went to the virgin islands
for a long time it's like a month or
something yeah we stay yeah well we work
because i remember we were going to stay
at the holiday inn hotel but it wasn't
finished yet
it was incomplete
yeah and we also went to uh
remember we went to finland and
um sweden and denmark helsinki
yeah yeah yeah
the photographers came out and these
women
was that in helsinki where
these women
uh formed a circle
huge circle they held hands with angela
in the middle and i was sort of there
but
looking around to keep the
photographers and the journalists all
right right right cops or whoever yeah
they just formed this tights it was
amazing yeah yeah i should have had a
camera you know what i mean
but see this is this was really really
wonderful
well how we met each other the question
was visual literacy too so well i think
uh
what
movies and adaptations yes and what do i
think i think that most of them are
pretty
awful
[Laughter]
there's some
i don't know if it's fear
of doing something you know how creative
say african-americans have been with
music
i mean
nobody told them how to do it
i was just reading about bob coming out
right after the atom bomb
it was so chaotic i mean everybody's
building shelters and saying oh my god
what is this the music changed right
away
into something that where you know odd
notes screeches new language you know
they just took off anyway back to the
movie thing it's this very
it's as though they're fearful of
powerful and different creativity
how to do something wildly different
or
they follow a certain pattern
you know
i mean you know from the first scene
everything
now i understand that the business
requires certain kinds of formulas
in order for to get the money
and to get them out i understand that
it's a it's such an expensive project
i'm surprised anybody does anything i
was stunned looking at
this doesn't have to to do with
african-american films
but i saw
what's that
no country for old men
my god there was a movie with no score
none
i didn't have to they didn't tell me
dante dante
i mean i just blew his head off you know
or something like that with no sound
there was just some mexicans
you know on the guitar that's all you
heard
it was thrilling it's like they trusted
me you know it was frightening it was
different but i wasn't
urged by the music
pushed this is going to be scary this is
going to be happy this is going to be
you know
and i thought isn't that interesting
so that's a little bit i know about the
movies but what i'm saying is that
i wish it were possible
to do more
inventive creative
non-formulaic hollywood things
uh
it's possible in the movies
hey think about passing strange
wasn't that something
i have never seen anything on broadway
that literate
and that musically inventive and staged
that way that was really a leap for me
i thought it was fantastic so it is
possible and i just want to say that
you know i've been unhappy
oh who cares not unhappy but
you know not
wholly excited by and not satisfied by
a lot of the films and musicals are
going on although they're well
intentioned
for me well-intentioned and good enough
it's like happiness
that ain't good enough
don't rest on happiness
it's okay i hope you all are happy but
we got to do more than that
more than that
yes
hello first of all let me just say this
is an incredible honor
and just to be in front of two
of my literary and life heroes i'm about
to have my own breakdown without even
reading
paradise but i have two questions as
well
uh the first being um you've talked
about you know writing a letter to
colombia and talking about
in protest to what's going on with
minors there what do you think in this
time where it seems like lethargy and
cynicism has
risen so high it's almost you know
choking us
how do you feel what do you think
the role of written protest is i mean is
it still does it still have an effect
the written letter of protest
the other question i have is also in
these times
what do you think the role or the
importance of the storyteller is
well andrea i want you to answer both of
those questions
[Laughter]
but i have to say preface my obviously
you know we live in this fast food
nation yeah
americans just want it now
and a lot
yeah and they sort of like deserve it
you know politically
everything
and with all the problems
if you don't hand it to him right this
minute
like at mcdonald's you know you just
drive by
tell the little machine what you want
pay them in the money
get your mood and going home
and it seems like that is you know this
sort of constant thing so that actually
sitting down and writing a letter
mailing it
telling three other people to do the
same thing
and organize like actually get on the
phone call some people you know it takes
too long
who's gonna i mean you know it's like it
may take a while
it may take a while that's my version
okay well
i totally agree with you
um because we've forgotten how to write
letters you know i mean i was going to
say for those of you who
will have problems actually sitting down
and doing a letter and putting it in
the mail you know finding out how much
it costs to mail a letter to you
yeah right and all of that
uh
you could perhaps
figure out how to email him
but
let me see if i if i can answer that
question in um
a slightly more complicated way
and it has to do with the previous
discussion we were having about
capitalism
and the extent to which we
assume
that as individuals we are powerless
which is in part
a consequence of
neoliberal
individualistic ideology that we only
think of ourselves
as individuals and that we don't think
about possible connections uh broader
connections with communities that are uh
not only in the us but that are that are
in other parts of the world as well
and it seems to me that this is the real
challenge of of this period
even for people who consider themselves
progressive in a country like the united
states of america
because we also
are
we also imagine ourselves as somewhat
different from the rest of the people in
the world
you know american exceptionalism has its
impact even on those who
pretend to be most radical exactly
um
and so what would it take what would it
take to create
a connection
with
that community
i was speaking about there are about
seven thousand people
afro-descended colombians
many of whom still have african names
because they have created a history and
a culture that goes back to um
that goes back to resistance against
slavery and they're still resisting as a
matter of fact they received an eviction
order for august 18th and they refused
to leave
so yeah you've and writing to answer
your question is
written protests
is a process that can perhaps help us
feel as if we are making community
we are reaching out beyond ourselves and
and that we have emotional connections
with people who live on this mountain
and this is in in in this
village called latoma
well i have this mantra
in connection with what you said angela
when i was young
they called us citizens
we were american citizens or we were
fighting for citizenship we were first
class or second class that's our first
second we were second class yeah but the
word was citizen now citizens suggest
some relationship with your neighbors
with the block with town with the
village
after world war ii
they stopped using that word
and we were consumers
that's all you could hear american
consumer this the american consumer that
and we bought things for status and that
what we were supposed to do
now
what are we we are taxpayers
all of a sudden it's about my little tax
my little money i don't want to give it
to the i don't want those people who
should not have it you know the people
you know we've and that you talk about
capitalism sort of seeping into the
blood they just change the language and
redefine us and we go for it yes my
driver was fussing about his taxes i
said so what
you pay taxes so what
and
um but you know so all of a sudden we
lose who we are
or we we're redefined and when you when
the language changes we change
the labels change so all of a sudden
it's about taxes if i have something
else about taxes
but if we were still
citizens
that's a different thing
we feel some obligation
we don't pass by citizenship not
narrowly defined no largely and there
are no losers i remember when hobos were
romantic
they were hemmingway stories
and they were on these trains and they
did stuff
now they're the homeless losers
who by the way don't pay taxes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he's taking his head
hi there
actually there was some great blues
players that are out there on the
railroad track playing some fantastic
fantastic music
uh ladies this is honor um
i could see your hand up with a fro
and on a book that i have um that i was
looking for and you bought um
um
ida b wells alive for me
i did yes you did yeah
um
apollo giddings it was a um
it was a program did you oh yeah yeah me
and paula she wrote the book
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're right
correct
it's my memory well you know can i just
say something
many people
don't acknowledge
um how important
toni morrison
was to the emergence of what we now call
a black feminist literature that's true
yeah
[Applause]
and
and i just
i mean i say this to my students i don't
know what i've ever said it to you but
uh i i i remember when she was
publishing tony kate bambara
right
and
and um gail jones
lucille clifford yeah all of them so you
know what we know as that as that black
women's writing that took shape in the
70s and the 80s would not have been
possible had not toni morrison insisted
as an editor at random house
on publishing these works
so let's
and you published paula gettings was it
paula getting and she published paula
giddings first book too yeah paula
getting's first book yeah you know
angela's first book my first book yeah
oh man
[Laughter]
she didn't realize that she was uh doing
she didn't i was just really historic
in case there was a hiatus i sort of was
writing in between myself you know
they didn't like that at all
they didn't hire me to write books they
hired me to edit them but what can i say
okay sorry i interrupted you no
you got
you're exactly where i wanted you
speculative
literature fiction
sci-fi
um
how does it relate to the um third world
women
and the movement through literature
as a student of anthropology i'm always
rooted into
what's real
but um i look for fiction for ideas to
make what's real
illicit you know uh illuminating
um show me the reverse where's where
where are we in the third world writing
back speculative
soft sci-fi
about what's going on socially
well there's not much as sci-fi as
octavia butler listen you've got
somebody coming here
this is a good story i don't hope i'm
stealing her thunder edwards dentica
right
and she's just published this book
called creative dangerously create
dangerously or something like that
anyway she gave a speech
at princeton
and she was
describing something that happened in
haiti
i was overwhelmed by this and i hope it
answers your
part of your
question she said that during the really
tough times in haiti when the tooth
hormone crew was running around chopping
everybody up
um
they established a rule that if somebody
died your son your neighbor a stranger
on the street
if you know they killed him you could
not pick them up
you could not go and get the body
just even if it was yours i mean you're
a relative
at some point a few days later
a uh
garbage truck
would come along and pick it up and put
it in the garbage and do whatever they
did so if you went out to pick up a body
uh
to bury it or to whatever you would get
shot
so everybody was afraid
she i hope i'm not miss i know this is
part of what she said at some point in a
neighborhood
and somebody organized a little theater
in a garage
and the local people came to participate
in this play some to be in it and some
to watch it and they did it every night
and the two terminal crew would come by
and check you know to see what they were
doing and walk on by
but what they were doing
get this
the play
was antigone
i mean that to me was the most
extraordinary thing
it provided the solace
it was about the subject
the conflict between the government and
the burial of the honor of you know and
so on and so i was thinking
not only about your
inquiry but also about the the visual
literacy thing the many many ways
there's no one way the letter is a
beautiful thing
and important and permanent i mean it's
there
uh it can't be erased it can be burnt
but not you know erased off your thing
the same thing is with theater
the same thing is with portraits
i mean the same thing is just
as we were saying try to think what it's
like in the world if you can't read
what other kinds of things jump out at
you you know use
everything everything
you know to become
you know the best human being you can be
you know i also just uh noticed the
lights are on now
and i noticed that um amir
baraka is in the house
there he is right there look look he's
behind us
thank you
[Laughter]
yes good evening i'm very honored to to
be standing in front of you you you are
my idols
i represent the resistance in new york
city the black and latina
mothers who
believe in public education who
use the libraries who are so opposed to
mayoral control into
the privatization
of
our schools
and
i want to give a shout out to the
parents in chicago who have just sat in
for a month in order to get a library
for their children
that there was a field house that was
going to be torn down and they
they sat in because they wanted a
library
i'm speaking to you because as i said
you're my idols and i was greatly
influenced in the 70s and 80s in
the the literature and being able to use
now
the internet to be able to hear
you give speeches and to speak in front
of like the new york women's agenda or
the ms foundation or the new york
women's foundation where
mothers like me
women in the community
don't have access
and so i'm asking now if you can give
the women the the many the mothers
agenda new york the the women that i
represent can you please give us some
words of encouragement and inspiration
so that we take that back to the
community
and we continue our fight our our
struggle for proper quality human
rights-based education public education
for our children
[Applause]
yeah give me your email and let me say
let me say that um
what you said in that
minute that took you
that it took you to explain who you were
i'm sure inspired so many of the people
here
and the work that you're doing
to resist privatization um
[Music]
so
the message that that i would give to
you to take back was the continued doing
what you're doing and
you know we all need we need to follow
your leadership
we need to all be involved in this
campaign to
prevent private the juggernaut of
private privatization from taking over
our lives
and especially from
taking over the
public educational system
so thank you thank you very much
thank you you're welcome don't forget
hi hi this is a question for angela
before we saw the shepherd fairy image
of obama um
even you know
in the context of all these che guevara
shirts you have this iconic image of
angela davis i'm wondering how does it
feel when you see people
you know using it in posters putting it
on t-shirts does it feel like it's you
does it feel like it's co-opting your
image or does it feel like it's
spreading sort of what you were trying
to say
well okay i'll you know i'll i'll i'll
tell you a story uh
um
because it it did
begin to bother me somewhat now the it's
so easy to
um
create the possibilities of
proliferating image you know anybody can
do a t-shirt and
and then it goes on the internet and so
i was i was i was a bit disturbed by
that and i asked a young woman
um who was a high school student who had
on one of those t-shirts i said you know
what's the whole point why are you
wearing that i mean i thought that went
out in the 70s when
because then there was a reason the
reason was to help to create this
campaign to free me exactly
so i said but this is the 21st century
right
and she says well i wear this t-shirt
because it makes me feel powerful
it makes me feel like i can do anything
i want to do
and i don't know what she knew about
whether she knew anything about me
really
but uh that made me recognize that
people bring their own interpretations
and that that image is an image not so
much of me as an individual as it is of
an era during which
millions of people came together you
know all over the world and demanded my
freedom as a matter of fact charlene
mitchell was the um
was the executive
director of the national united
committee to free angela davis
so
so yeah
i mean i can't stop it
so you know why not see
what is uh what what might be a possible
a productive and positive in
interpretation
of it so you know who knows i i i do get
kind of upset when people uh
think that i'm the only
only black woman who ever wore a natural
i mean
you know i can remember when i was a
high school student in new york and and
i saw miriam akiva and i saw i saw um
odetta yeah
and then later of course
tony had a natural a beautiful
natural so why do they keep picking on
me
that i don't understand
but thank you for the question
hi it's a pleasure i'm here representing
my concordia classmates and professors
and i want to ask you what classmates
concordia oh
college
um i would like to ask you if you think
um which is worth being internally
imprisoned or being imprisoned by
society and do you think it is possible
to be internally free while being
imprisoned by society i'm referring to
slavery and
just being in prisons
recently and things like that
thank you
you're really asking about
freedom yeah
internal external
i
have a very small short answer about
internal
freedom
i'm from
ohio
near um
no kidding
they always
uh
they always tend they come to new york
and make good make good
uh
near on lake erie right it's a
working
class town that had
steel mills shipyards and so on so a lot
of people came there
african-americans from the south and
mexicans and europeans and so on
i mean a real
diverse as they say in the rural
community and the only common thread we
had was poverty
but again we were citizens in some cases
um
uh and you know
the polish lady next door would bring us
those little cabbage things with meat in
them you know okay
if she if we didn't have any and if we
had something you know we'd bring her
and everybody had gardens i'm not trying
to make it sound like it was thrilling
because but although we were too young
to know we were miserable so
at any rate um
my experiences about race
are very different from
many other black people
one is because i grew up in a mixed
neighborhood
it didn't mean people didn't call me
names but you know they were calling
each other names so what i remember
coming home with somebody some little
boy called me a bad a wicked name and
said
he said you ethiopian you
she said well ethiopia is a continent in
africa and this
and i think the original human beings
were born there or something and we all
came
and so i thought what is he talking
about you know
so that so but here's the thing um
there were little minor
things like that and some sometimes from
adults
but i never felt and this is
curious i
i think i know why but i never felt
it
the way it was meant
and i think the reason is
because i always thought that those
people were deficient in some way
always even as a little one i thought
they were deficient
i had a big sort of racial
moment when i was working
as for some white family just before i
got my job as a page
i was working after school just doing
housework
and two dollars a week
one of which went to my mother
and the other i could keep but
she had
some complicated
for me complicated equipment like vacuum
cleaners
never saw one
and the stove that had the other thing
and i didn't know how to work it so she
would curse me out every now and then
doesn't matter you
know you told my mother mom when i got
to quit she's too mean my mother said
quit
now but that one dollar right
cause i told my father and he said
i said daddy she's so mean
and he said go to work
get your money
and come on home
you don't live there
so i didn't have an
employment problem
sense it was not my life was not
there and also i didn't have to disdain
or be afraid of or neglect any person
who had an advantage skin advantage over
me whoever they were
i never felt that
and when i wrote the first book i wrote
the bluest eye i really wanted to know
why that girl felt so bad the one who a
real life girl
who said
she wanted blue eyes we were talking
about
whether god existed
i of course was persuaded that he did
and she was persuaded that he did not in
her proof
was that she had
prayed for blue eyes
for two years
two years
and she didn't get him so obviously he
wasn't up there
but when i looked at her and thought
about how
awful she would look
[Music]
if she got them
and then i thought the second thing was
how beautiful she was at that moment you
know
she was just incredi but i didn't even
know whether she was beautiful or not
until i thought about what she might
think then the third thing of course is
why does she want that
you know what
what makes her think
that's an improvement and that kind of
self-loathing which is real
you know in when you don't have any
support made me
you know think of
that as a as a real subject for a book
not some old victim but really how it
works
how you can actually hear someone lost
the training the question but
it was about freedom too so all right so
i
that internal thing
i had trouble
when i first went travel south
not with white people i mean yeah maybe
but my
inability to perceive
how
southern blacks who work
you know their whole lives were
oppressed like not feeling comfort not
being able to go into the library i mean
just anything like that no not knowing
you know is this place safe or is that
place safe or knowing what the safe
places are
and what that might do how to escape
from that how does one internalize that
or does one you see
and if you do
how does it you know how do you get rid
of it
so all those and i that i never i always
thought
that the
those people whether they were adults or
children it's like they call me
ethiopian that was like
so stupid
he had sort of complimented me in a way
that i could not you know feel the
degradation that i was supposed to feel
all the self-loathing and i always felt
that inside
which i suppose is called
arrogance or
happily but i think it was the way in
which
uh
my family responded to that and they
were both from the south
deep south alabama and georgia
but they instilled in us some other
thing
okay
and maybe i could just add um
a couple of things
is this the last question no no please
add some please i'll add something well
and it's actually on a different kind of
register
about freedom
um
internal freedom external freedom
what do we mean by freedom and we've
been talking about frederick douglass
and
freedom had a certain
historical meeting then it was about
abolishing
slavery and
as
as i thought about
this new addition of
the narrative of the life of frederick
douglass i thought it would be
important to point out that
in a sense
as incredible and as brilliant as
frederick douglass was his
imagination of freedom was historically
constricted
so that in a lot of ways it was about
manhood
and and and that fight with kavi
proves his manhood and in the process
it provides a path towards freedom so
the question is well you know what about
what about women
yeah what about little girls how how
could they imagine freedom
and so i want to say i i want to say
this and in response to one of the
earlier questions that i didn't um get
to answer about um
um homophobia and uh
the
su the suicides of of young uh gay
people today uh
and it's about how we think about
freedom and the historical
um the deeply historical character of
our own imaginings of what it means to
be free
and what you know what did it mean to be
free in frederick douglass's time what
did it mean to struggle for freedom
during the civil rights
era
you know what does it mean
to
expand our notion of freedom today and
we've talked a lot about immigrants uh
you know tony you were talking about the
wall
the uh in mexico you talked about
pal you know the palestinians so how do
we bring
palestinian freedom into our frame
how do we bring the you know freedom of
immigrants into our um
into the way we imagine freedom today
how do we think about um
transgendered people how do we think
about gays lesbians bisexuals within the
frame of freedom and what does that tell
us
about the extent to which our own
framework
of freedom is
quite
restrictive
so i ask myself sometimes
a hundred years from now
how are people going to be
talking about the struggle
for freedom because i don't think we're
ever going to get there i don't think we
will ever reach a point where we can say
we are free
right we can rest
we can stop now
uh we've won
and so it seems that in the very process
of of struggling for freedom of
reflecting on freedom of writing about
freedom
we
constantly challenge the framework
within which we
develop uh that uh imaginary of freedom
so
i think it is it's it it's powerfully
imaginative in a certain period it's
this and another period it's something
else
i think of freedom as
well a major part of it for me is
knowledge
maybe wisdom if you get there
but certainly knowledge
and then i'm reminded that the first sin
genesis the sin
is knowledge
the acquisition of knowledge
that's why they get thrown out of that
little kindergarten they were in
that little playpen where they could
just sort of you know
and they said uh uh uh
you know something and the literal words
at least in one of the translations the
king james is they may become wise
so stop that
they knew
and in many other
religious forms
that's why faith and belief is so
important not knowledge faith belief
just instinct which is you know i'm not
complaining i'm just suggesting that
there's something so powerful
so attractive
so liberating
about what we call you know scheme
science knowledge
that it's you know you can't have it
which is the same sort of thing that we
were talking about with this document
from the texas correction bureau and
what angela is talking about when she
talks about the necessity of reading
literacy of all kinds under
constrained circumstances
and what frederick douglass did
uh having an intellect like uh maria in
prison you know death
you know all of this works into the same
thing the big horror
they have led us to believe
is knowledge because that will set you
free
on this note of knowledge
i would like
to thank angela davis and tony morrison
thank you very much
this event was hosted by the new york
public library in new york city for more
information visit nypl.org
joining us is jonathan the union army by
president lincoln and his generals
the new york historical society hosted
this hour-long event
welcome everyone
um it's a pleasure to be here tonight
with three
outstanding scholars elizabeth leonard
mia bay and david blight
really
wonderful choices as you'll hear to
tackle
the wide-ranging issue of lincoln
douglas and their roles in establishing
the u.s colored troops during the war
and of course the usct's own
considerable role in the successful
fight to save the union and destroy
slavery
it's a big topic it's really more than
one topic and we have a limited amount
of time but let me start in the middle
because
steven spielberg's lincoln movie is
surely on everyone's mind at the moment
and all through this year and in the
opening scenes of the film
we see soldiers from the second colored
kansas infantry
engage in a do or die death struggle
with the confederates
knee-deep in mud and water on a rainy
day
and it's the battle of little known
battle of jenkins ferry arkansas in
april 1864
black men and white men are fighting
with fists and bayonets and swords
really
in a way anachronistically it's not the
modern war that we hear about of
artillery and many balls and technology
it's almost a medieval
certainly a primal fight
what viewers aren't told is that
confederate forces that they were
fighting under the so-called black flag
which meant
that if african-american soldiers were
captured they would not be imprisoned
they would be killed or even as the
threat went
um sold back quote unquote into slavery
or sold into slavery
so i want to start by asking whether
this was a real threat this black flag
treatment
of
african-american soldiers during the war
how serious was it and how effective was
the threat
in inhibiting
enlistment
elizabeth
well um i think it was a very real
threat i think that what happened at
fort pillow is an example of uh in 1864
of how seriously um confederates took
their
intentions to destroy black soldiers if
they had any possibility of doing so so
i think it was a very real threat and it
wasn't just a threat for the black
soldiers it was also for their white
officers but i'd say it was very real
oh it's absolutely real
um
douglas since he's part of this panel
announced it that way
uh warned
well he warned recruits about that
that's after he
[Laughter]
with his own kind of rhetoric
uh
it was not only real threat it was done
i mean in effect it was done
but it also inspired a sort of no
quarter
policy among black soldiers from what
i've heard that they you know would
rather do anything than be taken
so they would become quite terrifying in
their own right
do you think it had an inhibiting effect
on enlistment and we're talking
200 000 successful enlistments and a
casualty rate greater than among white
troops but
was it a cautionary tale that was
frightening enough
i don't think it was as
troublesome in recruiting as the
discriminations that unequal pay was
that's what actually
caused many many blacks to to not sign
up
actual recruiting in the summer of 1863
all that came to a halt
because of the awareness
of discrimination brutal discriminations
unequal pay for black soldiers no
commissions as officers yeah
inferior equipment etc etc we'll get to
that segway right into scene two of the
movie remarkable
but
you're good at this
let's go back to the beginning
how soon
did african-americans yearn
to get into the civil war what were the
opportunities
before
january and february 1863 what were the
tell us some stories about efforts like
those of douglas and others to
to
promote the idea of black recruitment
early
i think it's pretty clear that black men
were very eager to become involved in
the army
on behalf of the union before
fort sumter and certainly as soon as
fort sumter was fired upon i think their
eagerness and their willingness to serve
was a very real uh a great reality but
uh they were certainly turned away in
large numbers at that point it's a
constant theme in the black newspapers
from that period i mean arguments
editorials eagerness and then you also
have slaves who are running away to join
the union army and offering to
participate on whatever terms
they're allowed to
and douglas writes to cameron doesn't he
asking for some boston recruits douglas
writes an editorial right after fort
sumter in april of 61
saying we must drink as deeply of the
martial spirit as possible and on and on
and on he went there were black militia
groups all over the north uh just as
there had always been militia groups
organized at the county level city level
state level
um
they were they were never legally or
technically allowed to be official
militia because there was a federal
militia act
of 1792
that explicitly denied the right of
black men to serve in the militia but it
didn't stop them from organizing and
they had all sorts of wonderful names
local names even some uniforms offering
themselves to the union army all through
the summer of 1861 and of course were
denied
any access yeah
mia you've done some
extraordinary research into the primary
sources of this period
you you spoke briefly about the
newspapers and the drum beat of
enlistment and volunteering what about
letters and and other evidence that
you've uncovered or tell us more about
the editorials and what they said
um the editorials mostly expressed the
eagerness to fight i mean there's
editorials about the unequal pay but
there is a strong sense and this is
something that african americans express
have expressed in virtually every war
that if african americans fought they
would sort of be able to prove their
equality manhood and then get taken more
seriously as citizens so there was a
sense that it was just very important
that african americans participate in
the fight
and there were
white officers early in the war who also
agreed that this was a logical direction
for the army to go and tried to push
the establishment to accept
these black soldiers or these wannabe
black soldiers black newspapers also
stressed the presence of black troops in
previous wars right they constantly
mentioned the revolution the war of 1812
the mexican war uh they they kept
reminding the country of a black
military tradition every chance they got
so a year goes by
and we're now in the
summer of 1862
with the war going badly for
the union
lincoln is reacting to all sorts of
pressures
notably by denying uh military
initiatives to uh to confiscate property
in slaves where do you where is he in 62
on the whole issue of freedom and the
potential
of what he later calls the sable arm
where is he privately or where is he
publicly i think i think there are two
different questions
right i think privately he's come a long
way
and is really thinking in terms of we
know that he had already planned his
preliminary emancipation proclamation by
july of 1862 so we know that he's done
that privately but it's going to take
him a little while longer to bring that
public
for a variety of reasons having to do
with the way the war is going and i
think he must have been thinking about
enlisting black soldiers at that point
well and importantly he signed the
second confiscation act july of 62 which
did authorize the recruitment of
uh people of african descent i think is
the language it actually used so that's
actually the first
it's not the first black troops but it's
the first official sanctioning of the
possible recruiting of black regiments
doesn't do much right at the time well
it does lead to the first regiment in
south carolina it leads to the secretary
of war appointing general
saxon i think
eventually by the fall of 62 you get
thomas wentworth higginson the
abolitionist from massachusetts who goes
to south carolina and puts together this
full regiment of black troops called the
first south carolina volunteers this is
before the emancipation proclamation
it's this it's congress that actually
authorized this first it wasn't lincoln
sorry harold
okay you said at the beginning he signed
it that was good enough
almost didn't but he did yeah he was
ambivalent on that one well he he
delayed i've been on a lot of things
exactly
so new york city um here we are at the
new york historical society new york
city was um something of a divided city
we should acknowledge and um
i have just finished doing um this
project for the historical society that
will be appearing in a book called
the history of the civil war in 50
objects from the collections of the new
york historical society one of the most
astonishing things
is a petition
prepared for abraham lincoln which
doesn't seem to have been sent but he
got a truncated version of it with 800
signatures it's a giant scroll
um
irish laborers jewish doctors
vander you know
blue bloods of the city someone who
signs his name john brown by the way
hey german tailors
maybe it wasn't gone after all right
um
what was the what was the sense
in the military i mean you've got
george mcclellan who was from new jersey
even though his son became mayor of new
york city um just in time for the
lincoln centennial which is poetic
justice in a way what
what was the feeling in the military
about freedom and recruitment of
african-american soldiers
well since benjamin butler was a colby
graduate i guess i can start
in fact we just refurbished a fantastic
portrait of benjamin butler that he had
delivered to the college many years
after graduating
uh but i think that there were a number
of white officers as i said who
at least
believed that the war was an occasion
right from the start like benjamin
butler believed that the war was an
occasion to start to
shift the balance of where black's
strength and and might was being used
and and certainly we know that he was
one of the first to say i'm not
returning these slaves when they come
you know under my protection whether he
went so far as to already plan to put
arms in their hands and send them off to
fight is another question but he
he was moving in that direction
there's a great deal of popular talk in
the press and various other places
about whether black men would fight
could they be trained soldiers would
would they
master arms uh as well as white men
would they fight was this very public
question
and it's one of the reasons that the
famous 54th massachusetts regiment was
so important the regiment formed in
massachusetts after emancipation
because it became this test regiment
there'd been there's already been
another regiment but the country didn't
know much about first south carolina
volunteers
uh they will know about the 54th but
there was this you know would they fight
question could they be disciplined and
the other thing i've seen in the press
is will they
once they mastered the very difficult
art of firing a weapon which is not i
suppose not that difficult they would
would they turn the weapons on whites
would there be a quote
race war or servile insurrection you
read that a great deal i just find it
interesting and ironic that the two the
two schools of thought are
people of color can't possibly use these
weapons and but what if they do what if
they do
or that they're savages savage killers
you know basically being held in control
but they actually don't know how to
would you have another sound yeah
sound domingo all over you know right
but
i think the mcclellan question is
important because
even after antietam which is the trigger
for the emancipation he is reluctant to
see the the um rationale for the war
transform to embrace freedom
he could never have been the presiding
general in a period of african-american
recruitment don't you think i think
you're right yeah he was more than
reluctant
yeah he was sherman-esque
well we'll get to mr sherman okay sir
definitely no no no he sherman esque has
has several meetings but you're
absolutely right he was mcclellan asked
in in that moment so the preliminary
proclamation civil war buffs are loving
this half of you probably wonder what
the devil were talking about well
sherman was not a very great fan of
black recruitment but
we will definitely
will definitely deal with that and
butler i should mention is
yet the the subject of yet another
chapter in this 50
objects book which i'll mention seven or
eight times during the event
commissioned this extraordinary silver
medal
for african-american troops who fought
in virginia
very badly commanded by him
but the historical society has one of
those
silver medals which is which is quite
beautiful so the preliminary
proclamation makes no
mention
of black recruitment and then
the final proclamation has what our
friend mark neely has called the most
schizophrenic
two paragraphs in the entire lincoln
canon because in one pack one sentence
he says i hereby enjoin the people
so declared to be free to abstain from
all violence
and then he says i further declared that
such persons of suitable condition will
be received into the armed service of
the united states where presumably
violence will be their job unless you
just give them shovels well that's why i
think
is the expectation that that the first
recruits are going to be laborers and
not fighters
i think so
i think so i don't know how far ahead
again lincoln would have been looking at
that point but i think
he would have he understood clearly how
methodically he had to approach this
topic with the public and i think to
suggest immediately that arms would be
put into the hands of the freed slaves
would have he would have considered that
rather treacherous ground to be walking
on
so everyone should answer this was
lincoln
leading from behind or was he behind
where the people were on this issue i
won't take it personally i promise
on black troops yeah
uh well he's leaning from behind to a
degree herald because we have this
year-long history
of
black troops going back again to
the first south carolina volunteers
however
it's still you know you know you know my
answer to this it's yes and no however
one of the things that makes the final
proclamation emancipation proclamation
so important and so different from the
preliminary is the sanction of the
recruiting of black troops
and
that it abandoned finally his schemes of
colonizing blacks out of the country and
i believe compensation as well yes he
dropped compensation he dropped
colonization which was the removal of
blacks if freed
outside the united states
and that line about recruiting black
soldiers i mean it is it's i don't think
it's schizophrenic i mean he's obviously
implying in one case the masses of the
freed people
you know please be good workers for
wages now if you can get them
and don't resort to violence however
those of you in the army
yeah step it up we'll give you a rifle
there's a it is but i don't want to be
the only one to weigh in on that no
please
i think it would be hard to say anything
but leading from behind i mean he's
under tremendous pressure of
circumstance the confederates are
already using slaves for all the kind of
scut work that
that people are imagining that these
blacks would do um you know there's all
sorts of reasons why he has to do this
um but then it's also like leading from
behind who because people were very
divided in the north as you guys say
there's abolitionists who really want to
see the war lead to the end of slavery
there's others who are more ambivalent
he's worried about the border states
yeah i was just going to mention the
police i think we tend to assume that
once the border states remained in the
union in 1861 they were never a problem
again and that's certainly not true and
kentucky of course is a very important
concern for him and kentuckians um were
very angry about the emancipation white
kentucky slave holders i should say were
very angry about the the nature of the
emancipation proclamation and not
particularly happy about arming black
soldiers and a huge percentage of the
black soldiers came from
the largest
number per capita of any state
kentucky had a real civil war i mean the
whole country had a real civil war but
and some would argue became a
confederate state after appomattox
absolutely dude
careful where you say that in kentucky
well since i write about the kentucky
and i i know where where i can say these
things
when when recruitment is finally part of
federal policy
embraced in the proclamation then there
is a recruitment act
that congress passes and lincoln signs
it isn't an easy proposition i guess
recruitment is never an easy proposition
so
tell us
how what measures were taken
to promote
to advertise to travel to speak
particularly douglas i guess we want to
hear
what he did in that in that realm
well uh elizabeth named her book for
broadside that well i think you're drunk
oh yeah i thought you were going to say
so let's have her answer that question
no no you go because i'm really about
i'll hand it to you in 30 seconds
men of color to arms is a broadside it's
actually a nearly three-page document
but it was put on a broadside famously
that douglas wrote published in his
newspaper
beginning of april of 63 so he's writing
it in march
uh he begins to recruit uh but he was
recruiting under now and this was
terribly important too
the government the war department hired
john luther stearns
that got the first name right is it john
stern i think so yeah
who had been one of the secret six uh
behind john brown et cetera et cetera an
abolitionist
to organize a whole series of agents who
would travel the north recruiting black
soldiers
exactly how they were going to do this
was to be determined and douglas was
merely one among many but he visits
douglas doesn't oh yeah yeah no he gets
douglas first right enlists him
and douglas
went on the road between march and april
and right on up until july of 1863 and
recruited approximately 100 members of
the 54th massachusetts the first two of
which were his two sons
his 19 year old son charles and his 20
year old son louis
and that to me as a douglas biographer
is is a puzzle
because
he never tells us anything about exactly
what that meant to him as a father
the sons never really left us anything
in a letter that reveals
you
know
i'd love to find that smoking gun letter
where one of the sons says you know the
old man had us go what the screw is
doing his reasons not ours because i
think that actually is the case but i
can't prove it what does a son say what
does a father say excuse me to a 19 year
old son
go to war you you could be reins well
they never were enslaved these guys were
born in the north free they never knew
enslavement they never knew the south
you could be enslaved you could be
executed but my son please go
go for this reason this reason that
reason and that reason but we're sure
that it was he who urged them as opposed
to the yearning that
robert lincoln had conveniently at the
end of the war too i don't know i don't
know i'm willing to hang this one on
douglas himself
douglas made very
eloquent moving aggressive arguments in
his recruiting speeches that would blow
you away you might enlist if you hurt
him
he would even end some recruiting
speeches by singing john brown's body
and his baritone well though but that
didn't work by the some middle of the
summer of 63 because of all these the
broadside discrimination
and he would use words like retribution
he would use the language
you know he would say the government has
now sanctioned you to put a musket on
your shoulder the u.s on your sleeve and
has sanctioned you to go kill every
slave holder in the south
go kill them that's what he's advocating
so he received citizenship in return and
received
yeah that was the aim that was my goal
you were going to add your well i was
just thinking about that being this at
the very least i mean he says if you can
if you put on this uniform you will go
forward and nobody can deny you
citizenship again and it's a
certainly a great promise that must have
held a lot of value
and and and
aside from douglas what were the other
means of recruitment that you've come
across both you and mia well a lot of
prominent african-americans were
involved martin delaney
garnet garnett the whole you know the
sort of black leadership rallied around
recruitment um and i'm wondering i mean
douglas i mean his message was that
anyone of an appropriate age had to sign
up so he his sons had to go uh well
no they didn't his third son frederick
did not sign up
but douglas got him
to become a recruiter
[Laughter]
and sent him to mississippi
where he got very sick and ended up
convalescing in a hospital and came home
so two went and two didn't there's
another story there that he doesn't tell
us about we should know by the way this
is a very historic day i don't know i
hate to make this a date specific
announcement but
you know mississippi
was good enough to
pass the 13th amendment in 1995.
but they didn't turn the document they
forgot to turn the document in and in
honor of president's day we can actually
say that the state of mississippi has
this week acknowledged that the end of
slavery in america
[Applause]
i thought kentucky was late kentucky was
1975. oh mississippi broke all records
it was 1995. is it true the lincoln
movie didn't play very many places in
mississippi though i'm sorry no i don't
know i heard that
maybe that's apocryphal maybe someone
can confirm that for us i imagine it
would be
not a big
bonanza
right
right but we don't know
um
as you pointed out 180 of the 180 let's
say the low number 180 000 troops
something like 135 000 come from the
border states or south
that's we're slaves former slaves that's
extraordinary right so are the are
people recruited off
directly out of
slavery
tell us how that works i mean we know
that
free african americans are being
recruited through the
things like the the great broadside and
did i mention that that's in the book as
well i guess not but the broadside is in
the book but how what is the recruitment
process as
as white troops are marching into
southern territory
isn't it partly in contraband camps
isn't that one of the places i mean it
would have been very hard to go on to a
farmer plantation and ask the slave
owner to step aside while you spoke to
the slaves and encouraged them to yeah
no it's in contraband camps but it's
also when the armies are marching
through i mean if you read the um wpa
narratives of former slaves they'll say
that you know they met these soldiers
and these soldiers said
you should join us you should go here
you should do that
so it says the army comes through and
encounters slaves on their own and makes
that pitch that could recruit in areas
occupied by union armies but not in
areas they were not it's why they did
send a lot of recruiters down to the
lower mississippi valley because a lot
of that region
was occupied by union troops
lower louisiana
up the mississippi river memphis down to
vicksburg
densely populated slave regions
where union armies occupied territory
they set up recruiting stations and many
times the recruiters were simply union
officers
but you see in those instances there
must have been the the true
manifestation of lincoln's argument
that
emancipation
brought with it a double benefit to the
white north which was one of his
arguments one you're denying home front
labor to southern slaveholders and b
you're adding a body to
to the federal army trying to restore
the union
me you brought something up and i don't
want to let it pass it actually hadn't
occurred to me but let's address
and dispose of
the persistent myth
of
confederate african-american service i
mean henry lewis gates
himself believes that there's a
substantial number of african-americans
from the south who have who volunteer
for
the rebel army
let's let's deal with it
you don't have to deal with skip gates
you can just deal with the issue what
has your research shown well so far as i
know there's just absolutely no evidence
for it i mean
white southerners
in entering the civil war brought along
slaves to work for them
as they normally did when they did
almost anything but
they were very nervous about letting
african-americans fight and
contemplated it only towards the very
end of the war and never pulled the
trigger
yeah well
it's it's one of those deep great
anthropological myths once it's
announced and launched it has a it has
attraction you can you can't kill it
it's like the spring flowers they will
come
uh look at look at black confederates no
don't don't even bother
but there are hundreds of websites about
it um in fact there was a textbook
written for the lower graders
saying that they were african-american
volunteers in one of stonewall jackson's
armies and when the author was called on
it she said i got it off the web got it
off the internet
yeah but the state board of education
approved that textbook
well but where the myth where the myth
keeps its traction is in part because
there are lots and lots of union
soldiers who write back in letters and
lots of these you know they're looking
out across the line and they see lots of
blacks working on confederate battle
works
they see blacks in the union and in the
confederate armies
working at this and working at that
lots of examples of that and the even
douglas himself
in the fall of 1862 writes in one of his
editorials which today's
neo-confederate sons of confederate
veterans websites use they use douglas
as an epigraph for one of their major
websites it's where douglas says if the
confederates can use the strong hands of
the black man to serve in their army or
serve their armies why can't we
so they say well even forever douglas
believed there were black confederates
because what he was saying is they were
laborers they were slaves now the
confederates did
finally have a roiling
embittered debate over arming blacks
which is the beginning of 65 or late 64.
well actually starts even early started
with an irish immigrant general named
claiborne who who launched the id in
december 63. it didn't get any
attraction getting to 64. but by the
last two three months of the war
jefferson davis robert e lee and most of
lee's general staff came out in favor of
it in exchange for freedom yes but in
utter desperation and they actually did
have a couple units put together in
richmond just as the war ended
and slaves have been armed by the way in
almost
every war you could think of throughout
pre-modern and modern history
so it's not a totally unthinkable notion
i think there was also photographic
you know imagery that people would have
been able to see that showed blacks
in
traveling with you white confederate
soldiers or in what looked like uniforms
of sorts and people would say see that
shows that and
uh when in fact they were forced into
that as i understand there's even a
doctored uh photograph on some
neo-confederate websites that shows a
photograph of black union soldiers
they've just recolored their uniforms
yeah
it's where to god i hope we're not going
to spike traffic on these websites but
but it's
as you say each spring
this dandelion myth rises again and i
don't think we've heard the end of it if
you read the
it means we won't get asked about it
tonight though i hope
i know i hate to inhibit questions by
the way that's a reminder that in five
minutes we will be setting up
microphones in both aisles so
if you have questions that you'd like to
ask us do get ready or even come to the
front as the microphones are are being
set up but we'll go on we talk briefly
about
butler but what about grant and sherman
and people like that tell us about their
attitudes early and later about black
recruitment
well sherman we know wasn't very fond of
of the idea of recruiting blacks or
really dealing with them at all from
what i understand he really would just
have liked to make this a war between
white men and and not deal with the
slaves at all
the sherman uh did not want those
thousands of
uh freed slaves refugees
uh behind his arm and him yeah and
there's the
infamous terrible case of him pulling up
the pontoon bridges along i forget the
name of the river in georgia during the
march to the sea he just wanted to be
rid of them partly because he did not
feed them take care of them but he had
he had as many as 20 000 black refugees
following
he wanted no black troops in his army
and he had no black troops in his army
grant's a different story uh most of the
black soldiers who served
in the war not all of them
in effect served ultimately in grant's
army in virginia although he wasn't
crazy about the idea no he wasn't crazy
about it except he followed orders and
instructions to recruit yeah what about
the army that goes into charleston in 65
is that technically sherman's army the
55th
i think that's technically sherman's we
have to give him some credit actually i
guess it is technically sherman's army
and didn't germans policies ironically
result in giving these blacks that he
didn't want these former slaves or these
runaway slaves giving them land or
setting aside land for them because they
just didn't want them following his army
so it had this
that famous order of 13 or whatever it
is field order that's one of the most
amazing moments of the war yeah
sherman has these thousands of black
refugees
behind his army
they reach savannah
or they reach liberty county you know
liberty county is the county south of
savannah and if you go to liberty county
today you can meet people who will
readily tell you this is where sherman
turned left yeah
but when he got into savannah he didn't
know what to do with all these people so
he he let his generals
put out the word and they invited black
ministers to come in and talk with him
like 20 of them
and they chose a leader he was an old
guy in his 60s who was free he had
bought his own freedom named garrison
fraser
and garrison frazier as their
spokesman
sat face to face with william tecumseh
sherman and edwin stanton secretary of
war
and they asked him
about 12 questions this is all
easily accessible in the documentary
history of emancipation the exchange
they had was recorded by journalists
there it's an amazing exchange
and out of it came this field order
where sherman
decides called field voter 15 i think
set aside
200 miles along the coast of georgia
south carolina down to jacksonville
florida actually 250 miles 20 miles
inland for the exclusive settlement of
freed people
with promissory notes
on a piece of land
which was the dream all of them had
it won't last because andrew johnson
successor to lincoln
will uh
remain
back
in the fall of 1865
and almost all of those
20 000 black folk were removed from the
land
many at the force abandoned
but even sherman said okay i'll meet
with some black ministers because i
don't know what to do
and they told him what to do
give us land so his awakening
so
going back for a moment to the uh
to the
common bond all of us almost all of us
in this room i'm sure have and that's
having seen
the spielberg movie once or twice or
thrice whatever the case may be there is
this wonderful moment when two veterans
of
jenkins ferry
private harold greene and corporal ira
clarke i got that from the screenplay i
didn't memorize him come and come into
lincoln's presence and talk
excitedly about their experience um
and then clark can't help adding to the
horror of his friend
they were very brave and making three
dollars less each month in white
soldiers another three dollars
subtracted from our pay for our uniforms
that's actually less than was subtracted
but we'll let it go in three dollars so
the screenplay correctly
acknowledges this imbalance um
tell us about the dialogues that douglas
and lincoln had on this subject how
important they were and also how the
press is weighing in on this issue
particularly the african-american press
elizabeth i was gonna say i think we
have to bring stanton into the picture
too because i think stanton the
secretary of war was very aware of this
injustice and very uncomfortable
uh with it and and did see fit to try to
write that so that all of that
pay and and uh
those benefits could be given back to
those soldiers after the fact
and it was retroactive it was and there
were some white officers i remember
correctly that that drummed up some very
fancy ways to ask their black soldiers
whether or not
they had owed their white
masters
any of their labor prior to such and
such a date and if they gave so that
they could say no i didn't and that way
they could get the correct pay this is
all enforced in battle it was a way that
because there was some stipulation still
in 64 about whether or not you were a
slave at a certain time and whether you
still could get all of that back pay or
not
is the press involved in this as well
but
correct me if i'm wrong david but
they're they're so intent on getting
people
to be recruited that they're not making
maybe as much of a fuss as they might
have yeah well although
the reason frederick douglass quit
recruiting
in july of 1863 is because no one was
coming forward to enlist anymore was he
promised
as some of the dramatizations
suggest was he offered a commission that
he never yes he was his first meeting
with lincoln
was prompted precisely by this
discriminations issue douglas goes to
washington august
10th
1863
met with stanton first he actually had
an appointment with stanton he had no
appointment with lincoln he just got in
line famously and said please let me in
and they actually let him in stanton met
with him for a half hour stanton he said
afterward agreed with him that these
discriminations are ridiculous they're
brutal we have to do something about
this and stanton offered him he thought
a commission to go to the lower
mississippi valley
and be sort of chief of recruiting
that's one story
when he meets with lincoln though link
stood his ground
they had a you know how they say after a
diplomatic meeting we had a frank
unserious discussion they had a frank
and serious discussion and lincoln said
we're not ready lincoln said i'm sorry
this is the only way this can be done
right now
your people wouldn't even be in the army
if we weren't doing it this way which
douglas walked out very displeased by
that answer but they're also very
impressed
by how lincoln treated him as an equal
and kept people
scheduled appointments waiting people
waiting but douglas went home to
rochester new york
stopped editing his newspaper which he'd
edited for 16 years wrote a final
editorial called my valedictory and
announced that he was going to
mississippi to recruit black troops as
an officer as an officer but the
commission the offer to go came there's
correspondence
but the commission as an officer never
came
and
and with his pride up
he decided he wouldn't go without that
commission i think there are other
complicated reasons why he didn't go
um but he never went to the deep south
to recruit
he had friends writing to him at that
time saying frederick don't go the
target on your back
you will be killed right do not go into
lower mississippi valley whatever you do
and he never did
now but the microphones are here so if
anyone has a question
we need you to line up and and we'll and
we'll recognize you
just want to point out one more
thing have i mentioned this book about
the objects the 500 no
because you're only on the 38th one oh
good
there's a wonderful reminder in the
collection
of how
embarrassingly slow
new york state was in this business of
recruitment
not until september 1864
was new york's first usct
regiment recruited because our governor
resisted it
and just here know you're including this
one
yes okay
and
when it finally occurred
the recruitment
no one in new york city would rent a
recruitment office
in lower manhattan to the uh to anyone
who was recruiting people of color they
had to piggyback onto it this is all
just discovered for the purpose of this
book but i didn't know the story this is
after the draft ride well
absolutely it's a year what's a year
after so they have to piggyback
with an office that's been established
to provide some reparations for people
who were burned out
that's the office they share and yet
there are stories that some of the
recruits are shanghaied
or their 75 bounty is stolen wow and so
they finally have this big event at the
union league club downtown
and in a wonderful postscript perfectly
ironic and logical postscript there are
lots of speeches lots of people 100 000
people on the street and at the end of
it all the white officers are invited
into the union league club for a
splendid coalition and the black troops
outside get a cup of coffee
and then they march right down broadway
to the seed of war
just
one of our
proud moments yes sir you have the first
question tell us your name and your
question my name is uh judah krauser
terrific panel thank you
could you talk about the role of black
soldiers in the reconstruction period in
terms of serving in the south and in
particular um the viewpoint of andrew
johnson and
and grant as president towards having
soldiers serve there thank you good
question
well
one of the interesting things that uh i
found and it what i'm not the first
person to find this but that was very
interesting to me when i was writing
about black soldiers after the war was
that the colored troops as they were
called were disproportionately
numerous in the south because of the
time of their recruitment they ended up
still being in service
and so they were disproportionate to
their numbers in the overall
army in the south but that was very
tough on uh white former slaveholders
and this created a very uncomfortable
situation for everybody and i think
johnson
uh of whom i am not very fond
as
many people already know if they've read
anything i've written uh he would have
been not very
supportive of really defending those
black soldiers grant uh
quite interestingly
did say
in more than one order you know it's
it's very important to keep the peace as
best we can maybe we should get these
black soldiers out of the south and move
them to the west there's trouble brewing
in the west and and so on but he also
said
that uh as long as black soldiers were
in the south they needed to be treated
well they needed to be protected their
white officers needed to take good care
of them and so on so he had quite a
different view from johnson i think
johnson would have really been happy
with colonization and just get them out
of the united states however you can
soldiers are not
most of the occupation troops as long as
there were occupation troops in the
south were actually black right and then
they go west right yeah
like
two three dozen when they missed the
parade that's one of them right right
and there's some dispute about whether
that was intentional or not i've i
suggest in my book that i think it was
quite intentional and others have said
no editor agrees with you uh gallagher
actually doesn't agree with me takes me
quite to task but i think it's a
difference in the way we interpret
things
your turn this side my name is peter
goodman of the blacks
in the north
who volunteered
were they slaves were they free and were
they better educated did they come from
the uh are the group of blacks who would
are regular job holes and things like
that
well if they were northern soldiers
yeah they were free um and there
certainly were a fair number of educated
ones
who have supplied us with some of the
you know diaries and stuff that we we
can use
treasured
the treasured few right
most northern recruited black soldiers
were free
some were although some were former
fugitive slaves living in the north i
mean the regiment we know the most about
is the 54th massachusetts ed redke did
an amazing kind of close social history
before he
recently died
of the 54th they came from every state
in the north
there were three or four from the island
of bermuda
the largest number were from
pennsylvania it was called the 54th
massachusetts but the largest number
were from pennsylvania
huge numbers from ohio
they were almost all free which made
that an unusual
regiment
um
whereas the usct this you know the
united states colored troops which were
the vast majority are recruited in the
south
and they were very different kinds of
units too and then there's the louisiana
native guard which is a whole different
sort of situation right well the the
louisiana
soldiers the black soldiers who began
actually as soldiers to defend
louisiana but then when
butler and his troops came and occupied
new orleans turned around and
named themselves as union soldiers and
uh but were very interesting in terms of
their makeup because many of them had
been free creole
blacks in louisiana and so there were
interesting hierarchies within the unit
and so on
but even among i must say this
where you even among black troops where
you might not have found them with much
education
that first south carolina volunteers
that i mentioned early on
commanded by thomas thomas wentworth
higginson higginson wrote a classic book
called army life in the black regiment
which i'd highly recommend beautifully
written for one thing
and he had a non-commissioned officer
an illiterate
slave former slave named prince rivers
and the way he writes about
the name alone prince rivers he says
prince rivers was born to be a soldier
if in another world he would be the
greatest general on earth and i feel
embarrassed to be his commander
i mean so so now and then there were
there were men without education who
took to soldiering not all of them but
some took the soldiering as though they
were born for it
and it turns out some of them have been
leaders on plantations they've been
leaders in slavery apparently this was
the case of prince rivers who loved to
drill his fellow men
and bark at him and yell at him
we really should before we do the next
question just talk a little bit about
the 54th and the famous action we're
assuming everyone knows about battery
wagner but someone should really tell
the story
you're looking at me and i'm thinking
well haven't you all seen glory
that movie that movie actually a civil
war movie i actually really like
really
i do like it among civil war movies i
like it i don't like many so i i like
that one
um
okay before we become cis what is it
siskel and ebert let's do but let's tell
the 50 who's going to
take the challenge plunge here and do
the 54th
yeah uh fort wagner was a battle fought
for a fortress on the beach
sullivan's island
part of the beach around the harbor of
charleston that part of solomon's island
isn't there anymore it's under the sea
um
it was
a test battle
it wasn't their first battle
but it was the test battle it was
actually covered by new york herald
tribune correspondents who witnessed it
uh
robert gould shaw their commander
volunteered them to go first in what was
what was a suicidal mission they were
trying to take this huge fortress on a
beach
at dusk
and that part of the movie is absolutely
accurate except they're marching the
wrong way oh sorry yeah
yeah i don't even know there are other
things i don't like about the film but i
didn't know that one and it was july 63
yeah yeah
july 18 1863
about 40 of the regiment ended up dead
wounded or captured
shaw himself of course was killed with
his troops they were buried in a trench
in the sand on sullivan's island uh it
became a celebrated event
in this now developing and this was
still early in the use of black troops
it became a celebrated event painters
painted it poets wrote poems about it
sculptors sculpted it
eventually the greatest single public
sculpture about the civil war by augusta
saint gardens the shaw memorial in
boston at least that's my favorite
uh is all about the 54th mass
uh what the 54th mass story represents
whether you see it in saint garden's
magnificent masterpiece or you see it in
the movie glory or you read about it and
there are a lot of letters from that
regiment because you had a lot of
literate young men by the way
douglas's son lewis survived battery
wagoner
his other son charles wasn't there
because he was too sick with diarrhea
and he was in a field hospital
he wasn't in the battle
but what it came to represent is how
which is what this whole story
represents
of how and why black men had to
go die very publicly
in order to be recognized as men
as human beings with real rights well
citizenship and i think it was really
transformative and for many many white
americans and certainly for people who
were on the fence about what all this
emancipation business meant i know the
person i've spent the most time recently
studying is is joseph holt of kentucky
who had been who was raised a
slaveholder and
but was a devout unionist but
and stayed with the lincoln
administration when the rest of his
family remained with the confederacy and
i've been puzzling and puzzling and i
still am puzzling over what led this
former slaveholder to become the staunch
supporter of emancipation and black
rights that he became as the war
progressed and as i've gone back over
the literature that i have the documents
that i have there's no question to me
that the black soldiers
valor was a key component of his
transformation that it led him from
being someone who didn't just care about
union but really cared and didn't just
care about emancipation but cared about
making emancipation mean something in
the long run because these men had
proven themselves to be men
and if you'd seen grant's army in
[Music]
the winter of 64-65 you'd have seen a
lot of black soldiers by then
petersburg you've been very patient so
ask away my name uh question did
douglas's sons survive the war and you
touched on that they survived the battle
at the fort wagner and did any african
americans reach the rank of a
commissioned officer during the war
uh yes and yes
i don't know about it wasn't delaney and
martin delaney yeah yeah there were
commissions there were a few very few
but they couldn't rise very and for all
to all intents and purposes they
couldn't i mean but it but there were a
few who had somehow managed
the physician
lawyer
the editor right but it was hard to say
tiny tiny number tiny yeah
uh douglas's sons did survive lewis
charles and frederick
uh it's it's an interesting and
difficult story
none of them managed careers or
professions effectively the rest of
their lives it's not easy to determine
how much the war had to do with that
lewis the oldest was very proud of his
service
always went to gir reunions proud having
his photograph taken in his old uniform
whether it fit or not
and
was very fond of reminiscing about it in
letters
i do think that experience
they were so young had to be formative
for them
in both positive and
negative ways
and
let's
just to make certain we understand that
this was not
just a constantly upward uh
momentum
uh there's also fort pillow which is
worth talking about and the whole
notion of inequal treatment in if there
are really laws of war that function in
in times of combat
what happens at fort pillow
how do lincoln and douglas respond
well what happens at fort pillow as i
understand it is that a large number of
black soldiers who are confronting
confederate soldiers
realize that they are going to be
defeated and they throw their hands up
in surrender and are massacred as
opposed to being taken prisoners and uh
it's a clear indication and this is
april 64 if i'm not mistaken and western
tennessee on the right on the
mississippi river right clear indication
that um
you know the the white confederates will
the confederates will take no prisoners
and lincoln responds quite forcibly by
saying well if that's how you're going
to behave
then we'll start shooting your prison
you know
putting our prisoners
to work at hard labor right never quite
does it but no he certainly threatens it
for a while right and then there i don't
think there is a similar massacre of
black soldiers again even you know one
thing i learned about fort pillow
inadvertently doing research on
something else is that that was an
internal tennessee war
those black soldiers were tennesseans
in a tennessee union regiment
and there were white tennessee union
regiments and of course lots of white
confederate but that battle was like i
didn't know this until i don't know a
while ago
it was a battle among tennesseans i mean
civil wars are bad enough
but when they get local they're usually
worse and that may have had something to
do i was just going to say that
exacerbated 300 men yes it was murdered
and
basically left
into the mississippi river i was going
to ask you though and i'm sorry no i
just was going to ask you that my
understanding i know i read this
somewhere is that one of douglas's sons
was actually in the gallery at the
capitol
when charles the 13th amendment was you
remember the scene in the movie where
one of the congressman this is your
house and all that yeah
yeah
welcome it doesn't appear he does not
appear in the movie but they don't tell
you who those people are one of those
people listen
charles who writes a note to his father
back in rochester and says father you
should have been here you should have
seen the rejoicing this was your day
and i came
there's no answer from douglas but i
imagine doug was saying damn i should
have been
i should have taken the train and i
think it's got something to do harold
with why douglas went to the inaugural
he wasn't going to miss that
he didn't miss it and
that's where lincoln famously said as
douglas forced his way into the white
house for the reception
said there is my friend douglas there is
no one whose opinion i value more than
yours and then he said enough about you
let's talk about me
he didn't say that but that was the
implication
what did you think of my speech
douglas
two names out into this discussion that
i just i i think that we just need to at
least recognize harriet tubman in this
discussion and her involvement in
if not direct recruiting nevertheless
moving uh
helping to liberate black men who would
then ultimately become uh soldiers on
the union side and i also wanted to
mention susie king taylor who was with
the first
south carolina and one of the great
black women nurses how about harriet up
on the front of gun boats right yeah and
spying and getting
spying
and then working the rest of her life to
get a pension so black
for 35 years she could not have a
pension finally
her husband applied
as a veteran he got the pension
she couldn't get one retroactive yeah
i'm asking i don't know i don't know no
i don't think so
and you can tell by seeing
her
homestead today the difference between
her homestead down the road from
seward's homestead there in auburn uh
new york it's interesting to see it's a
very she actually applied for a pension
yeah as a warrior well she had been
hired she was paid yeah she was
heartbroken but she got no pension
well this has been great i want to end
by by quoting
one of my favorite speeches of the war
by
you won't be surprised by lincoln
in 1863 he was invited back to his
hometown uh to attend and address a
union rally
which he was told was actually going to
be composed of people who weren't crazy
about the emancipation proclamation and
certainly didn't like the idea of
african-american recruitment in the end
he didn't go
and what he sent to be read aloud has
often been called a letter but in fact
it's a speech and this is what he said
to his old neighbors
you say you will not
fight to free negroes
some of them seem willing to fight for
you
and then he mentioned that he believed
the outcome of the war was pretty much
decided it would take time but the union
would prevail
and then he said there will be some
black men who can remember that with
silent tongue
and clenched teeth
and steady eye
and well-poised bayonet they have helped
mankind on to this great consummation
while i fear there will be some white
ones unable to forget
that with malignant heart and deceitful
speech they have strove
to hinder it
those are powerful words
history has finally caught up
with the vital role that
african-american soldiers
played in keeping the union together and
and removing
from it the stain of of african-american
slavery and we thank
elizabeth leonard mia bay and david
blight for helping to bring that to our
attention and illustrate it
[Applause]
the civil war airs here every saturday
at six and ten pm and
up next on american history tv
pastors historians church choirs and an
actor portraying abolitionist frederick
douglass reflect on the passage of the
13th amendment which abolished slavery
the event is held at the new york avenue
presbyterian church where president
lincoln frequently worshipped
this lincoln group of dc event marking
the 150th anniversary of the passage of
the 13th amendment is about two hours
first a word about the church you're in
as roger started to elude this is
lincoln's home church
we try to keep not only our current
ministry but the legacy of lincoln's
participation here alive
he would sit in this pew which was kept
from the original church this by the way
is not the original lincoln church his
church was torn down and replaced with
this church in the exact spot very
similar to the original church in
nineteen fifty the pew was preserved
that's where the president and his
family would sit in about that position
he would be listening to pastor phineas
d gurley who will be speaking from this
pulpit this was the pulpit from the
original church and was used up through
the time of peter marshall in this
church
we preserved his memory through the
lincoln window these marvelous stained
glass windows which we have installed in
this church were dedicated in 1968 but
maybe uh at the end you can look to the
one the second from the last
is the lincoln standing in prayer which
was his custom when sitting in this pew
during the
services here
you probably passed coming in the
hitching post out in front there was a
sign historical marker already there
that would have been used by the
president when he attended that has not
been moved
you may have heard the bells of this
church the lincoln chimes were a gift
of the robert lincoln family lincoln's
son
after
robert died his wife and daughter
presented the church in 1927 with the
chimes which were brought forward to
this new church
it is the only memorial
to the president given
by the president's family and we're
proud to have that here
the pastor's furniture pastor gurley's
furniture downstairs lincoln would have
sat in that we have those items
preserved
along with numerous personal items of
the president and first lady letters
from mary
lincoln's desk set on display downstairs
we also have the real gem of the
collection which would be a document
written by lincoln and signed by him
on april 16
1862 right after he would have signed dc
emancipation
he created the next generation
emancipation document which is on view
downstairs
that document describes a compensated
emancipation plan which would have been
his last effort
in trying to get the border states the
slave holding border states to sell
their slaves to the federal government
so that they could be out of that that
business when they rejected that he
immediately moved on to beginning to
discuss the process of the emancipation
proclamation
that all happened based on
the president's experience politically
but also we believe as ron white points
out in his wonderful book
the second inaugural address lincoln's
greatest speech
that the the pastor gurley's
relationship with
mr lincoln uh helped mr lincoln develop
a uh a higher understanding of his
relationship with uh with his god and
allowed him to think through more
clearly
from a religious uh perspective
how the emancipation proclamation
eventually the 13th amendment can best
be described and encompassed
so with that
we are ready to begin the the program
i'd like to introduce dr medford edna
green medford is a history and chair
history professor and chairperson at
howard university
she holds degrees from hampton hampton
institute in the university of illinois
urbana and her phd is in history from
the university of maryland at college
park
dr medford specializes in 19th century
united states history and teaches
courses on the jacksonian era slavery
and the civil war and reconstruction she
lectures widely around the country she
frequently does c-span productions and
that's what the cameras are here for
today by the way we are being filmed by
c-span for later broadcast
she is featured in several smithsonian
documentaries one currently on view from
emancipation and proclamation to civil
rights
and she is a member of many advisory
boards dedicated to the study and
promotion of civil war history
including the lincoln bicentennial
foundation the lincoln study center at
knox college
president lincoln's cottage scholars
advisory group she's a member of the
executive committee of the lincoln forum
her many honors include the 2013
professor of the year award at howard
university from the undergraduate
student association
and the 2012 lincoln award from the
lincoln group of the district of
columbia
and a special bicentennial edition of
the order of lincoln granted to 30
international recipients by the state of
illinois
with all the demands on her time she's
never hesitated to help here with the
lincoln group projects and it is with
great pleasure that i introduce her to
you today dr edna green medford
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon
is it on can you hear me
okay
can you hear me now ah you can okay
i would like to thank john o'brien and
karen needles and the members of the
lincoln group of the district of
columbia for the opportunity
to uh participate in this very special
program commemorating the 13th amendment
shortly before abraham lincoln took his
first oath of office as president
congress passed a resolution that sought
to guarantee that the federal government
could never impose its will on the
states in regards to slavery
this action had resulted from concerns
over the growing secession crisis
seven states had already left the union
and it was feared that more would follow
in attempt to stay the southern
withdrawal a peace conference was
convened under the leadership of former
president john tyler of virginia
i should
stop to indicate that john tyler was
from my home county in virginia charles
city county so i don't ever let that
pass without pointing that out he may
not have been the most popular president
but he was president so that's important
the 131 delegates from 21 states settled
on resolutions that were recommended to
congress and adopted as the corwin
amendment amendment so named after
thomas corwin of ohio
the measure prohibited congress from
entering from an acting excuse me any
law that would allow it to abolish or
interfere with the domestic institutions
of any state including that of persons
held to labor or service by the laws of
that state
within three weeks of the president
taking office he performed his official
duty by sending the resolution to the
states for ratification
only ohio and maryland approved the
measure before war ended the
ratification process
but just four years later on january
31st
1865 congress approved another
resolution which was later ratified as
the 13th amendment
rather than protecting slavery and
perpetuity however it prohibited the
institution throughout the nation except
as punishment for crime
this reversal of sentiment within a few
short years reflected the changes
brought about by war
the election of a republican president
who enthusiastically supported his
party's platform to challenge the
extension of slavery stoked
long-standing concerns on the part of
the slave-holding states
try as he might the new president could
not convince southerners that their
property in slaves was safe under his
administration
having failed to re to quell the
rebellion
now of 11 states
by the end of the first year of war
lincoln had encouraged the slave holding
union states to implement a plan of
abolition
his hope was that the
seated states would realize their
numbers would never increase to beyond
where it currently stood
and hence would give up their bid for
independence
when none made an effort to rid itself
of slavery he issued a proclamation of
emancipation based on military necessity
lincoln and supporters of emancipation
recognized that his decree might not be
sustainable once the war had ended
moreover they understood that its
provisions were limited by his authority
as commander-in-chief
affecting only those enslaved in states
still in rebellion its provisions were
withheld from upwards of eight hundred
and thirty thousand people but we should
keep in mind that more than three
million people were promised freedom
through the proclamation
how to eliminate slavery throughout the
country and for all time became the
subject of intense debate
the adoption and ratification of a
constitutional amendment however obvious
it may appear to us today was not a
foregone conclusion
with the exception of the bill of rights
the constitution had been amended only
twice
no new amendment had been ratified since
1804
and many believed no further revision
was indicated
nevertheless the political climate and
public sentiment encouraged support for
an amendment as casualties mounted
northerners became convinced that the
divisiveness caused by slavery's
continued presence anywhere in the
country was too great a cost to bear
swayed by the argument that irrevocable
universal emancipation was the only
solution to preserving the union and
reading the nation of the potential for
such future disagreements
northern residents sent petitions to
congress calling for action
indicative of this effort was the
women's national loyal league which
under the leadership of elizabeth katie
stanton and susan b anthony collected
100 000 signatures and in the winter of
1864
presented them to republican to radical
republican senator charles sumner for
delivery to the senate
by summer the number of signatures had
reached 400 000
simultaneously and the border states
growth in the ranks of anti-slavery
democrats pressed the cause of perpetual
freedom for all
in the meantime in december 1863
republican congressman james ashley of
ohio proposed a bill that would quote
amend the national constitution
prohibiting slavery or involuntary
servitude in all of the states and
territories now owned or which may be
hereafter acquired by the united states
the ashley proposal was followed by
another from iowa republican congressman
james wilson
when the blended bill reached the floor
it encountered considerable opposition
primarily and predictably from peace
democrats and representatives from
kentucky and as you know kentucky always
had problems with any issues are
regarding
the removal of slavery from the nation
so it was not only a thorn in lincoln's
side but it was a thorn in the side of
the rest of the north as well in terms
of how it protected slavery the
subsequent vote 93 in favor to 65
against failed to meet the necessary
two-thirds majority needed to have it
passed
in the senate john brooks henderson of
missouri introduced a joint resolution
that sought the same end
as a senator from a border state
henderson represented the kind of
leadership on the destruction of slavery
that lincoln had sought in the first
year of the war
henderson's bill had been sent to the
senate judiciary committee for
consideration
and on february 10 senator lyman
trumbull chairman of the committee
reported the revised measure to the
entire senate
the bill incorporated features of the
several proposals that had been
submitted for correct for consideration
in both houses of congress
absent from the revised measure was a
proposal by senator sumner that had been
more radical than his fellows in
congress could abide
its stipulation that quote all persons
are equal before the law so that no
person can hold another as a slave
aim to guarantee equality as well as
abolish slavery
the senate opened debate on the proposed
amendment in late march with senator
trumbull offering a plea for passage
if the amendment was adopted he argued
we are forever freed of this troublesome
question
we accomplished then what the statesmen
of this country have been struggling to
accomplish for years
we take this question entirely away from
the politics of the country
we relieve congress of sectional stripes
and what is better than all
we restore to a whole race that freedom
which is theirs by the gift of god but
which we for generations have wickedly
denied them
the largely republican argument in favor
of an amendment was strengthened by the
support of democrats such as remedy
johnson of maryland who gave an
impassioned speech during the debates in
which he argued his fellow legislators
which he urged his fellow legislators to
outlaw slavery in order to ensure
a prosperous and permanent peace
when the senate voted on april 8 it
approved the amendment 38 to 6.
support for a constitutional amendment
from border state senators and
representatives such as henderson and
johnson did not imply that there was a
lessening of objections to extending
rights to african americans
in response to suggestions that
abolition would lead to political rights
for the newly emancipated henderson had
argued
we give the slave no right except his
freedom
and leave the rest to the states
of course few are naive enough to
believe that any of the states in the
confederacy or in the union slave
holding states for that matter would
extend any political or social rights to
the freed people
and in fact we can go even further than
that there are many states in the north
would that were denying uh black men uh
certain rights as well black women of
course
were not
women know where were given the right to
vote of course so it was about mostly
the issue was about
voting rights for black men
as the debates had unfolded in the house
and senate in early
1864 the president refrained from
publicly expressing any opinion on the
merits of a constitutional amendment
while illinois when illinois congressman
isaac arnold pressed him to use the
occasion of his annual message to
congress in december 1863 to recommend
such an amendment lincoln declined
apparently because he continued to favor
state-controlled abolition
two months later republican congressman
john deffreys of indiana suggested that
he send a message to congress endorsing
an amendment that would prohibit slavery
forever
it would be your measure to freeze
stressed
if not done very soon the proposition
will be
presented by the democracy and claimed
by them as their proposition
lincoln offered a terse reply
our own friends have this under
consideration now and will do
do as much without a message as with it
he would not offer public support for
such an amendment until june after the
senate had approved the measure but
before it fell to defeat in the house
aware of the growing northern opposition
to slavery and eager to maintain their
preeminence as the anti-slavery party
the republicans used the occasion of
their national convention to remind the
electorate that their policies had the
best chance for success
while meeting in baltimore on june 7th
and 8th and now calling themselves the
national union party they adopted a
platform that blamed slavery for the
current state of affairs
argued that justice and national safety
demanded its destruction
and called for a constitutional
amendment that would quote
terminate and forever prohibit the
existence of slavery within the limits
of the jurisdiction of the united states
despite concern on the part of certain
leaders that the president might not be
able to win re-election
he was nominated on the first ballot
when notified of his victory he
expressed gratitude for the party's
continuing confidence in him and
anticipated that he would accept
renomination officially after he had
read the platform
but for now he wanted them to know that
he approved the party's declaration
favoring a constitutional amendment
he recalled that the seceded states had
been given 100 days to return to the
union and had been promised that no that
no harm would come to slavery when the
states had ignored the notice
quote such an amendment of the
constitution as is now proposed became a
fitting and necessary conclusion to the
final success of the union cause he
urged unconditional union men everywhere
to give it legal form and practical
effect
so he was on board by this time and uh
there are suggestions there is some
indication that even uh before this he
was on board he was encouraging um the
convention attendees to actually
say more about this issue of a
constitutional amendment he was
encouraging it from afar
when the democrats met in convention in
chicago nearly three months later
they ignored the shift in public opinion
rather than endorse a constitutional
amendment they reverted to con
condemnation of the lincoln
administration the platform declared
that the party's aim was to preserve the
federal union and the rights of the
states unimpaired
it demanded immediate effects excuse me
efforts to be made for cessation of
hostilities and called for the
restoration of peace at the earliest
practical moment on the basis of the
federal union and the state of the
states
the presidential election was far from
one in the summer of 1864.
although opposition from john c fremont
nominee of the newly formed democracy
party had fizzled the traditional
democratic party candidate former union
general george b mcclellan you know the
guy who never wanted to advance because
he never felt he had the advantage
remained a serious threat mcclellan was
supported by peace democrats although he
was not himself a peace democrat and by
those who apparently believe state
rights should triumph over human rights
at least in regard to african americans
mcclellan's willingness to negotiate a
less restrictive peace agreement with
the confederacy in contrast to lincoln's
insistence that peace could be had only
if slavery were destroyed made the
president's re-election
less likely and convinced even his most
ardent supporters that republican defeat
was imminent
despite pessimistic forecast
lincoln prevailed winning with a
stunning electoral college victory of
212-21
he garnered 55 percent of the popular
vote
aided by the support of union soldiers
and sailors who were allowed to cast
absentee ballots or were furloughed home
sometimes at lincoln's request to vote
in key states so anyone who does not
understand what what a great politician
this man was they just don't know
abraham lincoln okay he could play the
game as good as any of them could
um when the election uh with the
election behind him lincoln return uh
returned his attention to the house of
representatives where this with the
debate over the 13th amendment was again
underway the struggle in the house the
second time differed significantly from
what had transpired in the senate the
previous year
while the republicans dominated the
senate the party's numerical strength
was not as great in the house where a
hundred and 102 republicans sat among 75
democrats nevertheless lincoln proposed
that the current members who had already
voted the bill down in june reconsider
before the new congress convened in his
annual message to congress on december 6
1864 he suggested that the recent
election had signaled public support for
the constitutional amendment and that
almost certainly the newly elected
congress would approve the bill if the
current body failed to do so
there is only a question of time as to
when the proposed amendment will go to
the states for their action he declared
and as it is to so go
at all events
may we not agree that the sooner the
better
of course talks in the confederacy
surrounding the issue of freeing and
enlisting black men could not have but
had an impact on northerners who had
already been treated to the great
advantage the secessionist had in the
form of an enslaved labor force
black men served in every conceivable
capacity as involuntary military
laborers as blacksmiths teamsters
throwing up breast works etc freeing
white men to fight
what good would it do then to continue
to support an institution that even even
southerners were now having to
reconsider at least until their cause
had been won
in addition the border states of
maryland and missouri had decided to end
slavery in their jurisdiction
slowly but most assuredly the
institution was coming to an end in the
union slave holding states
either by legislative action or by the
frictions of war lincoln had warned
about earlier
once the emancipation proclamation had
been issued black residents of border
states although excluded from its
provisions used whatever means to secure
their freedom as well
including joining the union army
in the debates that ensued however
opponents to the amendment offered a
variety of reasons why it should not be
pursued from arguments that it
challenged states rights to concerns
over what would be done with the freed
men and women and some people were
arguing you needed to colonize every
single one of those who were freed
by the 13th amendment
prominent among the concerns was the
fear that such an amendment would confer
equality on the freed people or at the
least encourage them to seek the same
rights as white men and women
when the war is done for freeing the
negroes one opponent offered the war is
to go on to give them the vote a seat in
the jury box etc
that fear was not unwarranted
african americans had taken the
opportunity throughout the war to press
for those rights enjoyed by other
americans once black men had been
enlisted in the union army black leaders
such as frederick douglass argued that
their citizenship rights could not be
denied
given the support they rendered to the
union cause
throughout the north and in certain
areas of the south as well
african americans sought voting rights
or the abolition of black laws or as
here in the district of columbia
protested segregated streetcars
freedom would indeed be defined as full
citizenship
not simply the absence of slavery
meanwhile in the house
congressman ashley maneuvered his fellow
representatives toward a favorable vote
among the representatives to speak in
favor of passage was thaddeus stevens of
pennsylvania
the ardent abolitionist delivered an
impassioned speech that reflected many
years of service to the cause of freedom
we have suffered from slavery more than
all the plagues of egypt he declared
we shall we still harden our hearts and
refuse to let the people go
stevens warned that until pro-slavery
men yielded to god's command
and the demands of humanity and voted
for abolition the scourge of slavery
would remain
while ashley used his considerable
political skills to win over the faint
of heart lincoln used his own powers of
persuasion to reserve to reverse the
votes of a half dozen or more democrats
and to convince to convince others to
show up this time having declined to
participate at all in the first time
around
on the floor of the house chamber and
privately
critical votes were secured in exchange
for political favors and possibly other
considerations
whether these were offered with the
knowledge and approval of the president
we're still debating uh the extent to
which lincoln was actually involved in
some shenanigans um
i kind of hope he was because it makes
him a little bit more human so i like
that that lincoln was there
with his sleeves rolled up negotiating
with the best of them
at the final tally the vote taken on
january 31st 1865 stood at 119 for and
56 against thus barely securing the
necessary two-thirds majority
although not required to do so lincoln
signed the measure on february 1st and
sent it on to the state's ratification
the first to do so was his own illinois
and at the end of the year on december 6
on 1865
georgia supplied the required number to
make the amendment a part of the
constitution
several states ratified after the
requisite number had been reached three
of them
delaware kentucky and mississippi are
notorious for how late it took them to
do that
with delaware ratifying in 1901
kentucky in 1976
and mississippi in 1995.
okay
the passage of the 13th amendment by the
house of representatives did not elicit
the emotional response evidenced by the
emancipation proclamation
perhaps it was because americans found
celebration somewhat premature
since the required number of states
would have to ratify it before it became
an amendment but neither was it ignored
within days of its passage by congress
henry hylan garnett was invited to
deliver a sermon celebrating the event
in the house chamber now the house was
not in session but he was allowed to
speak from there garnett then the pastor
of the 15th street presbyterian church
here in the district thus became the
first african-american to speak in the
capitol building
titled let the monster perish his sermon
outlined the destructiveness of slavery
on the nation
and enumerated its sins against the bond
men and bond women
while he was pleased that congress had
quote saved succeeding generations from
the guilt of oppression and from the
wrath of god
he suggested the struggle was not yet
over
the champion of freedom must rest only
when all unjust and heavy burdens shall
be removed from every man in the land
when all invidious and prescriptive
distinctions shall be blotted out from
our laws when emancipation shall be
followed by enfranchisement
and all men holding allegiance to the
government should enjoy every right of
american citizenship
garnett reminded his audience that black
soldiers while sacrificing themselves on
the field of battle
were denied the right to a political
voice and could not
expect promotion to the higher ranks
frederick douglass responded similarly a
few months later on the occasion of the
32nd annual meeting of the american
anti-slavery society
in response to the argument of some that
the society should disband because its
work had been done
douglas suggested
whether this constitutional amendment is
law or not
i hold that the work of the abolitionist
is not done
the south by unfriendly legislation
could make our liberty under that
provision a delusion a mockery and a
snare
douglas argued that until the black man
had secured the vote could testify in a
court of law and had received the right
to bear arms slavery is not abolished on
march 4th the president
delivered his second inaugural address
he began his remarks with reference to
the previous inaugural address when the
nation had verged on a civil war
although both sides sought to avert it
he declared the war came
lincoln then turned his attention to the
central theme he suggested that the
cause of the war was the peculiar and
powerful interest in the southern states
in the form of enslaved people and the
desire of those states to strengthen
perpetuate and extend the slave-holding
interest
but he declined to vilify the south or
to hold it seemingly responsible for the
war
instead he chose to emphasize the common
bonds between the two sections both read
the same bible and pray to the same god
and each invokes his aid against the
other
and if some thought it's strange that
anyone should ask god's assistance in
exploiting the labor of another lincoln
cautioned them to judge not that we be
not judged
he saw the war as a burden shared
equally by north and south as atonement
for black bondage finally do we hope
fervently do we pray he continued that
the war would end soon but if it was
god's will that it continued until quote
all the wealth piled by the bondsman's
250 years of unrequited toil shall be
sunk and until every drop of blood drawn
with the lash shall be paid by another
drawn with the sword the american people
would have to endure it
lincoln ended his brief but arguably the
most powerful of his addresses with a
charge to all to move forward without
hatred and recrimination
and to honor the debt they owed to those
who had sacrificed themselves on the
battlefield
he called for an america of unity and
brotherhood with malice toward none and
charity for all for old antagonisms
would be resolved and a just and a
lasting peace would prevail while it was
a call for national reconciliation
between brothers who had waged war
against each other african-americans
encouraged by the pending constitutional
amendment
saw in the president's address
opportunities for which they had so long
struggled
later that evening frederick douglass
made his way to the white house where
the inaugural reception was underway
fully aware that his presence would
likely be received with disdain by
celebrants he nonetheless approached the
door and sought admission
when two policemen refused to admit him
on the grounds that they were ordered to
keep people of color away douglas
protested that the newly re-elected
president would never have sanctioned
such behavior
as providence would have it a passerby
observed the incident and accepted
douglas's request to inform lincoln of
what was transpiring
upon lincoln's intervention douglas was
admitted the president greeted his guest
cordially and asked him what he thought
of the inaugural address
mr lincoln that was a sacred effort
douglas assured him
gone were the years of criticism because
douglas was one of lincoln's biggest
critics
uh gone was that criticism and doubt in
their place was a hope-filled
anticipation of better times to come the
former bondsman left the reception
doubtless believing that the second term
of the lincoln administration would
bring to his people the freedom they had
envisioned
lincoln had once declared that he hated
slavery because of its monstrous
injustice because it deprives our
deprives our republican example of its
just influence in the world
enables the enemies of free institutions
with plausibility to taunt us as
hypocrites
causes the real friends of freedom to
doubt our sincerity
the 13th amendment would eradicate the
stain of slavery and bestow upon america
the honorable name lincoln sought for it
unfortunately he would not live to see
it ratified
after hearing an address the president
made in which he mentioned voting rights
for a segment of the african-american
population john wilkes booth changed his
plans that caused lincoln's kidnapping
and instead decided to assassinate him
the measure that the president
championed in his final in its final
journey through the house of
representatives became the first of
three reconstruction amendments the
other two which secured citizenship and
due process and voting rights for black
men
gave meaning to the freedom that had
been declared by the first
a century and a half later as recent
events have tragically demonstrated
we find ourselves in need of a renewed
commitment to freedom
one that shields american citizens of
color from the continuing disabilities
imposed by persistent racial views that
unfairly target and malign them
may the generations to come enjoy a
lasting freedom
secured by the commitment of all
americans to that justice and equality
evoked by the 13th amendment
[Applause]
dr medford thank you very much for those
wonderful words
a perfect observation of the importance
of the event of the day and what it led
up to
our next segment we'll talk about
activities here in the district of
columbia
which occurred up to and before and then
after
the 13th amendment as
typified by some of our key church
communities
william lord garrison
published his first issue with the
liberator the abolitionist journal in
1831.
in there he said i am no moderate
the constitution is a slaveholder
document and the north will be better
off seceding from the slave states it
was the abolitionist movement that
prompted as much a secession movement as
as the south would do later on
the white man's support for abolition is
based on the belief that no man can own
another and that negroes will want to
escape slavery when given the
opportunity
the pre-civil war narrative of abolution
has largely been one of fearless wealthy
white activists providing resources and
guidance to help daring runaway escaped
refugees
escape oppression culminating in the
heroic figure of abraham lincoln as the
great emancipator
without diminishing these important
roles more recent scholarship has
discovered a much more complex
relationship built on robust cast of
intrepid free blacks who opened their
homes and businesses to refugees
provided the boots on the ground
guidance and the local knowledge to
provide credible intelligence to both
refugees and their white partners
the organization of african-american
communities to support the work followed
the one vehicle most commonly available
to them in a very oppressive white
dominated southern society as washington
dc was
and that was the churches
in the city of washington the power of
the african-american church communities
was particularly potent because of the
interest of members of congress who
lived among us
and who tended to participate in many of
the african-american church celebrations
those key members helped to drive many
of the legislative movements in congress
and they were here in our community
among the most prominent the early
african-american churches in washington
were the african-american methodist
churches
israel bethel and union bethel 19th
street baptist church
asbury now united methodist church and
the 15th street presbyterian
it is
good to have two of those churches with
us today with their pastoral leadership
and uh and support to talk about some of
the important activities of those
churches prior to enduring the civil war
leading up to the 13th amendment we have
on my far left the pastor of
metropolitan ame church
william lamar
and with him is
thelma dean jacobs who is the church
historian for metropolitan welcome to
both of you thank you
and sitting next to me is reverend
robert bell who was the pastor of 15th
street presbyterian
let's begin with miss
jacobs would you like that if you
whatever you like sure
good afternoon
it's an honor to be here for and a part
of this 100 commemoration
thank you thank you thank you
head and shoulders above everyone else
again good afternoon and thank you for
this honor of
making me a part of your 150th
anniversary commemoration
for the next few minutes i will share
with you some information about
the history of the african methodist or
ame church
the history of amy church in the
district of columbia
and the store and the history of two
civil war era ame churches israel bethel
union bethel and the presiding prelate
of the those churches the bishop daniel
a payne
and i will show at the end with two
post-civil war events
the apparent african methodist episcopal
or amy church grew out of an
anti-segregation protest
at the predominantly white saint
george's
methodist epistle church in philadelphia
in 11 late 1780s
one sunday
the black members of saint george were
told
they could no longer occupy their pews
on the main floor of the sanctuary they
henceforth they would have to sit in the
balcony
upon hearing this directive
a
a group of the blacks from saint
george's under the leadership of
reverend richard allen walked out and
formed their own church which they
called bethel
methodist episcopal church
by
1994 reverend allen and his group of
followers had purchased property and had
constructed a church in philadelphia
it was the first black methodist church
in the city
in 1816 reverend allen called the
conference of black methodists who were
interested in forming an autonomous
methodist episcopal denomination
delegates came
from delaware new jersey pennsylvania
and maryland to philadelphia
when the conference concluded the
african methodist episcopal or ame
church had been organized
and bishop richard allen was elected and
consecrated the denomination's first
prelate
in the district of columbia because of
racial segregation black members of
ebenezer
methodist episcopal withdrew from their
church that church in 1820.
in 1822 these black members petitioned
to become a part of the ame connection
thus the first amy church in this city
named israel bethel amv
was created in 1822.
a few years later
israel bethel was worshiping an edifice
at the foot of capitol hill
the ray bernal house office building now
sits on that site
in 1838
members of israel bethel residing west
of the 14th street northwest and in
georgetown
organized an amy church in their
neighborhood
these members felt it was a hardship for
them to walk on unpaid
muddy
snowy cold streets
from their homes the one or two miles
for services at israel bethel on capitol
hill
the new church located on m street
between 15th and 16th street
was named union bethel ame church
during the civil war years the presiding
prelate of ame churches in maryland and
the district of columbia was the right
reverend daniel a payne
of the four churches in the city under
his charge
israel bethel and union bethel were the
largest
israel bethel adjacent to the u.s
capitol was an especially politically
active church
bishop payne and the church pastor
reverend henry mcneal turner were
involved in local and national politics
in the spring of 1862
the legislation to emancipate the
enslaved in the district of columbia
was working his way through congress and
on to president abraham lincoln for his
signature
reverend turner preached sermons and
made israel bethel a me church available
for meetings by supporters of the
legislation
further bishop payne went to the white
house in mid-april
met with the president and spoke in
support of the legislation
the sunday after president lincoln
signed the manumission bill
there was a city-wide worship service to
celebrate the liberation
at the service bishop payne preached a
celebratory sermon
welcome to the ransom
in this sermon he stressed that
liberation
also brings with it the responsibility
of good citizenship
the following year
reverend turner was a lead in the
campaign that enabled blacks to serve in
the union army
reverend turned his first army recruit
where young men from israel bethel and
me
congregate from the israel bethlehem
congregation
he also held recruiting drives at union
battle amy
in the fall of 1863
reverend turner joined his recruits when
he became the first black union army
chaplain
union bethel and b church was the scene
of several historic events in 1862 63
and 64.
in august 1862
a white clergyman the reverend james
mitchell
described as quote the commissioner of
immigration
convened a meeting of prominent black
men at union bethel church
the meeting topic was a proposal to
transport free blacks and the formerly
enslaved out of the united states
at the meeting
five men were selected to meet with the
president at the white house
although none of the men were union
bethel members
the group of five and reverend mitchell
returned to union bethel on the day of
the meeting and walked four blocks from
the church to the white house
you can find details of the meeting in
the digitized lincoln papers at the
university of michigan
after slavery was abolished in the
district of columbia
thousands of blacks came into the city
mainly from virginia and maryland
most of them were destitute and in dire
need of food clothing and shelter
therefore in october 1862
reverend james handy pastor of union
bethel amy church
helped form the union relief association
the association was one of many
organizations created to alleviate a
crisis in the community
the union relief association gathered
contributions of money
food and clothing from its members and
held many fundraising events at the
church
after a denomination-wide appeal went
out in the church newspaper the
christian recorder
donations came to the association from
ame members across the northern part of
the united states
mrs elizabeth keckley well known as
dressmaker for mrs mary lincoln
was a member of union bethel and me
during the early years of the civil war
in late 1862 she was president of the
contraband relief association
mrs keckley obtained donations of money
and clothing from the lincoln family for
the association
reports of mrs keckley's fundraising
speaking tours to philadelphia new york
and boston made front page news
in 1863 union bethel held a meeting held
meetings to recruit men for the first
colored regiment
the church followed up with meetings
about
the uh with meetings about caring for
those who entered military service and
their family
families one unusual meeting in
september of 1864
discuss raising funds for procuring
substitute for colored draftees
the 13th amendment passed the united
states senate in april 1864.
one provision to set aside texas for
african
territorialization was not part of the
final legislation
the 13th amendment passed the house of
representatives on january 31st 1865.
i conclude with with a few post-civil
war events
most methodist denominations meet as a
delegated group every four years in a
convention called a general conference
the 1868 ame general conference was held
in washington at israel bethel near the
capitol
when the ame general conference convened
that may
representative thaddeus stevens
republican pennsylvania was ill
he had been in january 1865
the last member of the u.s house to
speak on behalf of the 13th amendment
to show the appreciation of the
nomination for that speech and for all
representative stevens had done on
behalf of black americans an amy
delegation visited him in his home
he died a few months later
thank you
thank
you
robert bell of 15th street presbyterian
[Applause]
thank you and again we appreciate the
opportunity to say a few words about
15th street
roll and appreciate john's invitation
and by the way some of his
research which has been diligent very
wonderful as john said at the beginning
i think a couple of things helped here
in the district of columbia certainly
the number of freed blacks at that time
period which was about a two to one as
some of you may know
for the enslaved folks in the district
of columbia and so i think it wasn't
only the
the racism and the slavery issue but
from the prominent black leadership side
really made quite a difference in moving
us towards this legislation
a couple of things about and a couple of
names about 15th street and how they
helped
in october of 1841
john cook who was at that time the
minister of the african-american
episcopal church
petitioned the district of columbia
presbytery within the presbyterian
church sort of the levels of heaven the
presbytery is sort of one level up
it's it's the next judicatory uh to
become a minister of the presbyterian
church and he came under the care
of a minister uh from the fourth
presbyterian church at that time john
smith
following his approval to get licensed
as a presbyterian pastor
the first black pastor here in the
district of columbia
there was a
notice issued
inviting all black members
and persons an open notice to join a new
church
this meeting
to form the church was held at the home
of david carroll in november of 1841
and they were formally recognized by our
presbytery in may of not of 1842
again i assure you our presbytery
doesn't act that fast in today's world
so gathered were prominent black and
other black citizens from a series of
churches first church second
here a fifth church even down from new
york city
reverend cook as you may know uh was a
great educator here in the district of
columbia had to take a little leave of
absence during the snow riots
until that calm down returned to the
city
they met in his schoolhouse as the first
presbyterian church here in the district
of columbia and eventually built a
church in 1852
on mcpherson square
so reverend cook john cook who is very
well known perhaps another name from
15th street that's not quite as well
known william slade
mr slade was president lincoln's
valet
he was also a ruling elder at 15th
street presbyterian church and really at
the white house i believe much more than
a valet he would take dispatches for the
president's president and deliver them
his children
played with the lincoln children on off
hours as well so he was a
force in the movement as well
one of the things and i attribute this
to john o'brien's good
research here
that i was unaware of is that william
slade and reverend cook helped formed
what was known as the social
civic and statistical association
so
scsa an organization in the district of
columbia bringing together black
businesses and church leaders so they
could coordinate
and improve the opportunities for the
district citizens black
african-americans
advocating emancipation suffrage of
course for male blacks they met monthly
at the 15th street church
they did their homework very well and as
one example of this reverend cook
compiled
statistical data on the taxes paid by
black businesses
to refute the district of columbia city
council's position
that a public fund should not be used
for to educate black children in the
district so they work through these
organizations and and you might say an
institutional mentality
reverend cook was one of the prominent
black leaders that was mentioned that
went to the white house uh to meet with
president lincoln in august of
1862.
they didn't get all they asked for the
full enfranchisement of
and black citizenship
but in a in a way 15 one writer put it
this way
the colored people who worked at the
white house during the civil war were
considered the cream of washington
society and were recognized leaders and
many were members of the 15th street
presbyterian church
now among just let me mention a couple
of other names
that
15th street hosted
and helped pursue the cause one was john
rock of boston
delivered a speech at our church in may
of 1862
a plea for my race it was entitled to a
biracial audience in the church
uh rock was a friend of senator senator
charles sumner
uh would be who would be the the first
black man to argue a case before the
supreme court in 1865.
frederick douglass gave a speech at the
15th street church on thanksgiving day
in 1864
after john cook ended his tenure in 1855
succeeding ministers had helped with the
cause william cato john martin
and as was mentioned henry hyland
garnett
following him francis grimke
anecdotally reverend grimke performed
the second
wedding of frederick douglass not at the
church but
very close to the church on on our
street
reverend grimke was actually pastor of
15th street for some 50 years
from 1877 to 1937 there were a couple
years off for good behavior
in between there but basically almost
for 50 years and this of course is a
little bit later
but reverend grimke was a charter member
of the niagara's movement which was the
forerunner of course of the
naacp
now not all members of 15th street
church were committed to strictly legal
and non-violent methods to obtain their
freedom
a highly educated writer and print maker
by the name of osborne perry anderson
was one of five blacks who participated
in john brown's raid on harper's ferry
he was one to escape with a white
colleague
he later wrote an account of that
called a voice from harper ferry i think
it was published
originally in canada to set the record
straight
about the amount of support that this
raid had in the black community which
i understand would mean diminished
obviously being careful not to identify
anyone
and now i'll conclude
very humbly by mentioning a couple words
about henry hyland garnett dr medford if
you'll bear with me and and correct any
of my mistakes here but uh this is
certainly a a very prominent player from
15th street that that helped with the
cause
he was a great abolitionist
and uh
educator uh decide he become a preacher
as that was the most effective way to to
carry the cause
also kind of anecdotally about his life
he walked with a limp he had a
prosthetic leg
that
was
taken off due to a
sporting industry when when when he was
a child
i joked at my church one time preaching
a sermon about his message to congress
that i can never say anything at 15th
street that's going to be more audacious
wild or radical
than henry highland garnett
frederick douglass william lloyd
garrison thought he was too radical at
times
and disassociated themselves from him
he had made some
comments about armed insurrection
unfortunately they were about 20 years
before the civil war
he was no passivist he was a great
believer
though
different from reverend cook and some
others in the
immigration and
colonization
believe that mexico was a possibility as
well as africa west indies and and even
as i understand it here in the united
states to build colonies
finally a brief word again about the
speech that dr medford spoke so
eloquently about
an invitation came from
lincoln at the prodding of some other
ministers to
address this joint session of congress
in reading descriptions of it it was a
packed house as i understand with both
blacks and whites on that
february 12
1865 a couple of weeks after
the
house had passed it but before the
senate confirmation
mentioned and before of course it was
ratified
by the states two months
before lee surrendered appomattox
and one writer put it this way he henry
highland garnett
entered the hall with a choir from 15th
street presbyterian church
made his way on crutches because of his
limp to the speaker's rostrum
noting that he was an amputee
the writer said now he stood erect where
no man of his race had ever stood before
listening to his choir sing all hail the
power of jesus name
again as as was mentioned i won't
belabor it reverend
garnett
text was matthew 23 4.
they tie up heavy burdens hard to bear
and lay them on the shoulder
shoulders of others
but they themselves are unwilling to
lift a finger to move them
and he proceeded to denounce the
institution of slavery encouraging the
lawmakers telling of his first
experiences
with slavery as a child
another quote from that speech
great god
i would as soon attempt to enslave the
angels gabriel and michael as to enslave
a man made in the image of god for who
christ died
quoting plato socrates ignatius
constantine jonathan edwards
pope leon the 10th
and the words
if not the deeds of
washington and
jefferson and franklin
uh
i'll end with another quote here if i
could from that speech he stated
honorable senators and i don't think
this is repeat
forgive me if it is honor centers and
representatives illustrious rulers of
this great nation i cannot refrain this
day from evoking upon you in god's name
the blessings of millions who were ready
to perish
but to whom a new and better life has
been opened by your humanity
justice and patriotism you have said
let the constitution of the country be
so amended that slavery and involuntary
servitude shall no longer
exist in the united states except in
punishment for crime
surely an act so sublime could not
escape divine notice
and doubtless the deed has been recorded
in the archives of heaven and concluding
as i think was noted favored men and
honored of god
as his instruments speedily finish the
work which he has given you to do
emancipate enfranchise educate
and give the blessings of the gospel to
every american citizen
thank you
a newspaper a newspaper reported after
the passage of the 13th amendment uh
henry ward beecher the prominent pastor
was in in the white house visiting with
the president
and appeared with lincoln at the window
of the white house said in my wildest
dreams seven or eight years ago i never
expected that i would one day stand in
the window of the white house at
washington and address a crowd that had
come to congratulate the president
united states on the passage of an act
proposing the abolition of slavery and
particularly this president abraham
lincoln though he may be slow he is sure
and has lived to his word
we're going to move the the program we
want to get to the the next piece but i
know that pastor lamar would want you to
know that frederick douglass did
regularly attend
at the
metropolitan ame when he was in
washington as a federal marshal and was
buried from that church at his death but
thank you all very much
appreciate this and i will begin now to
introduce frederick douglass but thank
you thank you very much
[Applause]
there are two excellent books about
washington d.c and this uh the suffrage
movement the african-american church
movement and the underground railroad
published in 2003 uh harold stan stanley
herald published a book called
subversives
which is about the underground railroad
and the d.c players in that significant
movement
and the more recently kate mazur wrote
for
forevermore is a book which describes
many of the african-american
church-related organizations that moved
forward on the suffrage issue
after the emancipation after the 13th
amendment that book is
proclaimed throughout the land
the
kevin mcelveen
was born and raised in dc he's an
award-winning actor who has starred in
such plays as pearly
dream girls keep the faith the adam
clayton powell story
and in the meeting in which he portrayed
at one time or another both malcolm x
and the martin luther king
he's an entertainer a singer historian
with an active interest in youth
education he is currently
based in chicago where he is leading a
project to train young men in the acting
profession
kevin has won a black theater alliance
award for best leading actor
he's been featured in such events as the
democratic national convention and the
national council of negro women so he's
done some big time conventions as well
so
william lloyd garrison would introduce
frederick douglass as excelling in wit
comparison strength of reasoning and use
of language
there is in him that union of head and
heart which is indispensable to
enlightenment of the heart
and a winning of the hearts of others
he compares favorably with patrick henry
for his stirring revolutionary speech in
abusive music to heighten his appeal
may he continue to grow in prose in the
knowledge of god that he may
increasingly be a service to people of
bleeding humanity i have the honor of
presenting mr frederick douglass
[Applause]
[Music]
hmmm
[Laughter]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
freedom
woe
[Applause]
[Music]
be a slave
i'll be buried
in my grave
and go home
to my lord
and
be free
[Music]
do you mind if i say that again
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
freedom
[Music]
me
[Music]
i'll be buried
in my grave
and go
home
to my lord
[Music]
oh freedom
sweet
freedom
how good it is to sing a free song
the melody
that once was as bitter as bile in my
bondage
noun taste of sweet honey and nectar
in my freedom
i
am frederick douglass
i was born a slave
known as frederick augustus washington
bailey
in talbot county on the eastern shore of
maryland
many were the atrocities that i
witnessed there
at the age of seven
i was sent to live with my master's
brother in the city of baltimore
and against my master's objections
i learned to read
and as i read the very thing that he
feared came true
for now i saw the secret roots of all
slavery
i was ready to argue with any man white
or black who argued for slavery for you
see
whether he was kind
or whether he was cruel
the slaveholder
was a slaveholder
with every hour that he robbed of the
men of their just rights by keeping them
enslaved he was sharpening the knife of
revenge
for his own throat
in speaking
of the principles for which our country
was founded
he spoke the very reasons that gave the
slave the right to rebel
i could not stop thinking of freedom
and liberty
i heard freedom in every sound and saw
it in every object
freedom shown from every star it smiled
in every calm it breathed in every wind
it moved
in every storm
and though
i found a better life in baltimore i did
not find happiness
for true happiness and slavery can never
coexist
and as i grew older my desire to escape
grew with each day
and on a monday
the third day of september 1838
i boarded a train to philadelphia i
arrived in philadelphia that afternoon
in new york city the next morning free
black and 20 years old with my slave
days behind me
are you with me
i later settled in new bedford
massachusetts
i had heard
of the abolitionist movement as a child
in baltimore
but i did not know of the work that they
did until i read my first copy of the
liberator
this paper found a place in my heart
second only to the bible
for the writers of the liberator hated
slavery
they demanded the complete freedom of my
race
i love this newspaper
and his editor mr william lloyd garrison
soon afterwards i went to hear garrison
speak i said way in the back and listen
to his mighty words mighty and truth
in mighty and simple earnestness
did not know it then
but a new life
was beginning for me
i became a lecturer and agent
for the massachusetts anti-slavery
society
i began to speak so well and so
eloquently
that many thought that i was never a
slave at all
so to prove
that i spoke the truth
i wrote a book about my life
i named names dates
and places to prove
that i was still
the frederick bailey from talbot county
i changed my name
from frederick bailey
to the character
of sir walter scott's
lady in the lake
i became frederick douglass
and to become
independent i add an additional s
on the end
when
i wrote the book
i had to flee to england
where i stayed 22 months
i spoke so well and eloquently there
that they treated me as a diplomat
the women's anti-slavery society in
england
bought my freedom
i returned to the united states in 1847
officially
a free man
are you with me
let me try it again are you with me
i settled in rochester new york
started a newspaper called
the north star
where right is of no sex
truth
is of no color
god
is the head of us all
and we are all brethren
now
when the war broke out
between the north and the south
i predicted
that this war
would not be fought entirely by white
men
are you still with me
every month's experience
during these dreary years
has confirmed that opinion
a war undertaken and brazenly carried
out for the perpetual enslavement of
colored men caused logically
and loudly
for colored men to help suppress it
only a moderate share of segacity was
needed to see
that the arm of the slave was the best
defense
against the arm
of the slaveholder
[Music]
let
my
people
go
oh press so
hard
they could not
stand
[Music]
go
down
moses
way
down in
egypt
last
[Music]
let
my
people
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
people
god
[Music]
i hope you don't mind if i sing for a
while
i sure would appreciate it
if you would join me along with the
choir
my eyes have seen the glory of the
coming of the lord he is trampling out
the vintage where the grapes of wrath
are stored he has loosed the fateful
lightening of his
terrible swift sword his truth is
come on everybody
[Music]
glory hallelujah
[Music]
glory glory hallelujah
[Music]
his truth is
marching on
give yourselves a round of applause
[Applause]
when first the rebel cannon shattered
the walls of fort sumter
and drove away a starving garrison
i predicted that the war then and their
inaugurated would not be fought entirely
by white people
every month's experience during these
dreary years has confirmed that
opinion or war undertaken and brazenly
carried on for the perpetual enslavement
of colored men caused logically and
loudly for colored men to help suppress
it
only a moderate share of segacity was
needed to see that the arm of the slave
was the best defense
against the arm of the slave owner
hence
with every reverse to the national arms
with every exalting shout of victory
raised by the slave-holding rebels i
have implored this imperiled nation to
unchain against her foes her powerful
black hand
slowly
and reluctantly
that appeal is beginning to be heated
stop
not now to complain that it was not
heated sooner
it may not have been best that it should
not
this is not to time to discuss that
question
leave it to the future
but when the war is over
the country is saved peace is
established and the black man's rights
are secured as they will be
history
with an impartial hand will
dispose of that in sundry
other questions
action
action not criticism is the plain duty
of this hour
words are noun useful only as they
stimulate to blows
the office of speech is now used only to
point out when
where and how to strike the best
advantage
there's no time to delay
from east to west from north to south
the sky is written all over now
or never
are you still with me
liberty
one by white men would lose half its
luster
who would be free themselves must strike
the blow
better even die free
than to live slaves
this is the sentiment of the brave
colored men amongst us
now they are weak
they are cowardly men amongst us
they tell you that this is the white
man's war that you will be no better off
after than before the war that the
getting of you into the army is to
sacrifice you at the first opportunity
believe them not
cowards themselves
they do not wish to have their cowardice
shamed by your brave example
i have not thought lightly of the words
i am now addressing you
the counsel that i give
comes of close observation and with the
deep conviction
that this is your hour
and mine
in good earnest then
and after the best deliberation i now
for the first time during this war
filled at liberty to call and counsel
you to arms
for
by every consideration
that bind us with the enslaved fellow
countrymen and the peace and welfare of
your country
by every aspiration you cherish for the
freedom and equality of yourselves and
your children
by all the ties of blood that make us
one with the brave colored men fighting
our battles in louisiana and south
carolina i urge you to rise up and smite
with death the power
that would bury the government and your
liberty in the same hopeless grave
are you still with me
i wish i
could tell you that new york calls you
to this high honor
for the moment she is silent
but she will speak by and by the
constituted authorities are silent on
this subject but they will speak
doubtlessly
on the right side
but we are not compelled to wait for her
we can get to the throat of treason and
slavery through the state of
massachusetts
she was first
in the war of independence
first
to break the chains of her slaves
first
to make the black man equal before her
laws
first
to admit colored children in her common
schools and she was first
to answer the call
with her blood when its capital was
being minutes by rebels
you know her governor
and you know charles sumner
need i say more
massachusetts now caused you to arm the
soldiers
she has but a small
population so we need you to go quickly
and become the first
black regiment from the north
are you still with me
more than 20 years of unswerving
devotion to our common cause may give me
some humble claim
to be trusted at this momentous crisis
i will not argue
to do so implies hesitation
and doubt and you do not hesitate you do
not doubt
the chance
is given you to end in a day
the bondage of centuries
the day dawns
the morning star is bright upon the
horizon
the iron gate of our prison stands half
open one gallon rush from the north will
fling it wide open while four millions
of our brothers and sisters will march
out into liberty
we can win for ourselves
the respect from common people from all
varieties
of
men do you remember
denmark vesey of charleston
do you remember nathaniel turner of
southampton
remember shields green and copeland who
followed noble john brown and died as
glorious martyrs for the cause of the
slave
remember
that in a contest with oppressors
the almighty makes no attribute that
takes sides with the oppressors
the case is before you
this is our golden opportunity
let us win for ourselves the respect of
the country
and the best blessings
of all posterity
there is no time to delay
do not hesitate
do not doubt
men of color
to arms
[Music]
he
has sounded out the trumpet
that shall never call retreat he
is lifting up the souls of men
before his judgment seat
oh be swift my soul to answer him be
jubilant my feet his truth is
[Music]
glory
[Music]
glory
[Music]
[Music]
glory glory hallelujah
[Music]
oh i wish i could hear you glory
[Music]
hallelujah
his truth
is
is much
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
kevin kevin
kevin mcelveen ladies and gentlemen
republican herbert hoover served as
president from 1929 to 1933 best
remembered for his time in the white
house at the start of the great
depression hoover also monday night at
eight eastern on the communicators on
c-span 2.
up next on the presidency a debate
inspired by the writings and
correspondence of president abraham
lincoln and abolitionist frederick
douglass although the two men met on a
handful of occasions they never publicly
argued their views on slavery the war or
racial politics
actors stephen lang and norm lewis take
on the roles of lincoln and douglas
during this imagined debate and
historian harold holzer moderates mr
holzer is also current chair of the
lincoln bicentennial foundation
the metropolitan museum of art hosted
this hour-long event
[Applause]
[Music]
in their entire eventful lives they met
face to face only three times maybe four
at most
and when they finally did they spent
much of their time together locked in
political combat
one was a proud and brilliant radical an
aggressive advocate for racial justice
who had run out of patience with the
status quo
other was an ingenious gradualist
a master of the
arts of compromise exquisite political
timing leading when necessary from
behind
one would save the union and slowly cure
its major birth defect
slavery
the other would free all slaves
immediately even if it meant destroying
slavery and the union together
they expressed their views when with
uncommon eloquence two of the most
famous orators in an age that prized
great oratory
but they developed a cautious mutual
respect and ultimately
genuine mutual admiration
two great men
whose furious dissonance in pursuit of
what ended up as common goals
made both of them greater
abraham lincoln
and frederick douglass
as these early photographs show they not
only had compelling platforms but
unforgettable faces
no one who ever met either one ever
forgot being in his presence
or
how they expressed themselves publicly
and privately
tonight by using the very words lincoln
and douglas wrote and spoke
to one another
about each other and to the public and
by deploying the portraits for which
they sat at around the time many of
their major meetings and orations
occurred
it's almost possible to see and hear
them confronting each other again over
their shared aspirations and differences
the result we'd like to think is an
authentic lincoln douglas debate
lincoln and frederick douglass that is
in some cases
in actual recollected conversation
but save for a few conjunctions
each and every word you will hear was
actually written or spoken by these
protagonists themselves
tonight we will hear them again just as
readers and audiences did in the 19th
century
beginning with their first attempts
at autobiography i was born
february 12 1809
my parents were both born in virginia of
undistinguished families
second families i should say
my mother died in my tenth year
my father grew up
literally without education
we reached our new home about the time
the state of indiana came into the union
it was a wild region with many bears and
other wild animals still in the woods
there i grew up
there were some schools so-called but no
qualification was ever required of a
teacher beyond reading writing and
ciphering to the rule of three
if a straggler supposed to understand
latin happened to sojourn in the
neighborhood he was looked upon as a
wizard
there was absolutely nothing to excite
ambition for education
of course when i came of age i did not
know much still somehow i could read
write and cipher to the rule of three
but that was all
i have not been to school
since the little advance i now have was
picked up from time to time under the
pressure of necessity
i was raised to farm work which i
continued till i was 22.
i was born in tuckahoe
in talbot county maryland
i have no accurate knowledge of my age
never having seen my authentic record
containing it
by far the larger part of slaves know as
little of their ages as horses know of
theirs
and it is the wish
of most masters to keep their slaves
thus ignorant
my mother was named harriet bailey
colored and quite dark my father was a
white man
it is a common custom in the part of
maryland from which i ran away to part
children from their mothers as of at a
very early age
my mother and i were separated when i
was an infant
and i never saw her more than four or
five times in my life
my first master was a cruel man
hardened by a long life of slave holding
he would at times seem to take great
pleasure in whipping a slave
i suffered little from anything else
than hunger and cold
but my feet had been so cracked with the
frost that the pen with which i am
riding might be laid in the gashes
my next mistress mrs sophia ald proved a
woman of the kindest heart
she commenced to teach me the abcs
after i had learned this
she assisted me in learning to spell
words of three or four letters
but when mr all found out what was going
on he at once forbade mrs all to
instruct me further telling her
a [ __ ] should know nothing
but to obey his master if you teach a
[ __ ] how to read
there would be no keeping him
from that moment i understood the
pathway from slavery to freedom
i set out with high hope and a fixed
purpose
to learn how to read
i am naturally anti-slavery
if slavery is not wrong
nothing is wrong
i cannot remember when i did not so
think and feel i hold that if the
almighty had ever made a set of men that
should do all the eating and none of the
work
he would have made them with mouths only
and no hands
and if he had ever made another class
that he has intended should do all the
work and none of the eating
he would have made them without mouths
and with all hands
whenever i hear anyone arguing for
slavery i feel a strong impulse to see
it tried on him personally
by 1834
lincoln is 25 years old
and finally established on his own
in the little town of new salem illinois
a grocery clerk studying law
aspiring to elective office secure in
his natural right to rise
not so douglas that year
around 16 years of age he is still a
slave and the victim of repeated
whippings by a brutal new owner
one day he decides he must resist or be
killed
and he bravely fights back
douglas is never punished again
but freedom from abuse is not enough to
quench his thirst for liberty
at least he is soon hired out
to yet another owner as a field hand
william freeland
you couldn't invent such a name
recognizes something special not enough
to liberate him of course but at least
enough to allow douglas to start a
school where he is soon teaching 40
other enslaved people how to read
within a few years he is working now in
a maryland shipyard but required to turn
all of his wages over to his owner
he meets a free woman of color named
anna murray
and gets engaged but when his master
orders him back
back to his home as punishment for
attending a revival meeting
douglas believes he will be sold south
and he resolves to take anna and escape
on september 3 1838
he leaves baltimore by train then
switches to a steam bait steamboat
reaches the free city of philadelphia
then heads off to new york
finally he reaches the abolitionist
hotbed of new bedford massachusetts
where free african americans and
anti-slavery whites work together to
keep slave catchers from rounding up
fugitives
he never forgets those first anxious
days of freedom in the northeast
at just around the same time the rising
young illinois politician lincoln
delivers his first major speech in his
new hometown of springfield illinois
to condemn the horrors that had befallen
white and black lovers of freedom
in the northwest
freedom it was a moment of the highest
excitement i ever experienced
i felt like one who had escaped a den of
lions
this state of mind however very soon
subsided and i was again seized with a
feeling of great insecurity and
loneliness
i was yet liable to be taken back and
subjected to all the torches of slavery
this in itself was enough to damp the
order of my enthusiasm
the motto i adopted was this
trust no man
to understand
imagine yourself a fugitive slave in a
strange land
a land given up to be the hunting ground
for slave holders
whose inhabitants are legalized
kidnappers
where he is without home or friends
without money or credit
wanting shelter and no one to give it
wanting bread and no money to buy it
in the midst of plenty yet suffering
terrible hunger in the midst of houses
yet having no home
among fellow men yet feeling as if in
the midst of wild beasts
these were the hardships of the tall
worn and whip-scarred fugitive slaves
accounts of outrages committed by mobs
form the everyday news of the times they
pervaded the country from new england to
louisiana
in mississippi
they commenced by hanging white gamblers
next
negroes
suspected of conspiring to raise an
insurrection were caught up and hanged
then
white men supposed to be lead with the
negroes and finally strangers from
neighboring states going thither on
business till dead men were seen
literally dangling from the boughs of
trees on every roadside and in numbers
almost sufficient to rival the native
spanish moss of the country as a drapery
of the forest
in saint louis a mulatto man was seized
in the street
dragged the suburbs of the city chained
to a tree and actually burned to death
and all
within a single hour from the time he
had been a free man attending to his own
business and at peace with the world
such are the effects of mob law
and such of the scenes becoming more and
more frequent in this land so lately
famed for love of law and order
let reverence
for the laws be breathed by every man
and let it become the political religion
of the nation
for the next 15 years douglas and
lincoln take different paths to
leadership lincoln heads to congress in
1848
but his opposition to the
mexican-american war or conflict he
believes was
instigated by a desire to acquire new
slave territory for the south
cuts short his career there after only a
single term
but not before lincoln takes to the
house floor
to condemn the glorification of war and
those
sp seeking to expand slavery as a bounty
not long afterwards as you will hear
douglas returns from his first tour of
england now an international sensation
to address the anti-slavery society with
his own breathtaking speech that
declares his newfound radicalism
first lincoln now sir
for the purpose of obtaining the very
best evidence as to whether texas had
actually carried her revolution to the
place where the hostilities of the
present war commenced
let him answer fully
fairly and candidly
let him answer with facts and not with
arguments
let him remember
he sits where washington sat
and so remembering
let him answer as washington would
answer
if he cannot or will not do this if on
any pretense or no pretense he shall
refuse or omit it
then i shall be fully convinced of what
i more than suspect already that he is
deeply conscious of being in the wrong
that he feels the blood of this war like
the blood of abel is crying to heaven
against him
that originally having some strong
motive he is trusting to escape scrutiny
by fixing the public gaze upon the
exceeding brightness of military glory
that attractive rainbow
that rises in showers of blood
that serpent's eye
the charms to destroy
i have no love for america as such
i have no patriotism i have no country
the institutions of this country do not
recognize me as a man
the only thing that links me to this
land is my family and the painful
consciousness that here there are
millions of my fellow creatures groaning
beneath the iron rod of the worst
despotism
that could be devised
even in pandemonium
this and this only attaches me to this
land and brings me here to plead with
you and with this country at large
for the dis-enthralment of my oppressed
countrymen and to overthrow this system
of slavery which is crushing them to the
earth
instead in 1854 congress passes the
kansas nebraska act
which overturns the missouri compromise
that at least has confined slavery to
the south the new bill
makes it possible for white settlers in
the new western territories to vote on
whether or not to allow slavery i was
losing interest in politics
when the repeal of the missouri
compromise aroused me again
out of office for six
years lincoln is now ready for his
comeback
he returns to the political stage with a
series of powerful anti-slavery speeches
after one of them on october 27 1854 he
walks down a chicago street with two
fellow republicans
discussing their new cause
when they pass a photo gallery
lincoln's friends talk him into posing
and this image is the result
obviously his bow tie suggests he wasn't
ready for his close-up
he holds an anti-slavery newspaper to
the camera though as if to endorse the
principles of his new party
just days before he had been in peoria
illinois
where he provided words that almost
animate this picture this declared
indifference but as i must think covert
real zeal for the spread of slavery i
cannot but hate i hate it
because of the monstrous injustice of
slavery itself
i hate it because it deprives our
republican example of its just influence
in the world enables the enemies of free
institutions with plausibility
to taunt us as hypocrites
causes the real friends of freedom to
doubt our sincerity
and especially
because it forces so many really good
men amongst ourselves into an open war
with the very fundamental principles of
civil liberty
the doctrine of self-government is right
absolutely and eternally right but
it has no just application as here
attempted
when the white man governs himself that
is self-government but when he governs
himself and also governs another man
that is more than self-government
that is despotism
if the negro is a man
why then
my ancient faith teaches me that
all men are created equal
and that there can be no moral right in
connection with one man's making a slave
of another
douglas expresses
very similar outrage over the new law
that season and an equal determination
to immortalize himself
before the cameras
in the speech in chicago
just two weeks after lincoln's address
in peoria
he has to justify his mere right to
voice his opinion
it is said with much adjointness by the
advocates of the nebraska bill that we
are unnecessarily solicitous for the
rights of negroes that if the people of
the territories can be trusted to make
laws for white men they may be safely
left to make laws for the black man
i branded as a mean
wicked and bitter appeal to popular
prejudice against the people wholly
defenseless
the right of each man to life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness is the
basis of all social and political right
and therefore
how brass fronted and shameless is that
impudence
which while it aims to rob men of their
liberty and to deprive them of the right
to the pursuit of happiness screams
itself hoarse to the words of popular
sovereignty
they have still never met
but they are beginning to sound
astonishingly alike not only on the
issue of kansas nebraska and popular
sovereignty but on the inevitability
of a national collision
it is i think
pretty well settled that the liberty and
slavery
cannot dwell in the united states in
peaceful relations a house divided
against itself cannot stand
i believe
this government cannot endure
permanently half slave and half free it
is pretty well settled to all that one
or the other
of these must go to the wall
the south
must either give up slavery or the north
must give up liberty
the two interests are hostile and are
irreconcilable
the just demands of liberty are
inconsistent with the overgrown
exactions of the slave power i do not
expect the union to be dissolved
i do not expect the house to fall
but i do expect it to cease to be
divided it will become all one thing or
all the other either the opponents of
slavery will arrest the further spread
of it and place it where the public mind
shall not rest in the belief that it is
in the course of ultimate extinction
or its advocates will push it forward
till it shall become a like lawful in
all the states old as well as new north
as well as south
have we no
tendency to the latter condition
there is not a single tendency of
slavery but is adverse to freedom
is lincoln now reading and getting ideas
from douglas's monthly the newspaper
that the celebrated abolitionist begins
publishing in rochester
maybe
maybe not
but arriving here in new york in 1860 to
speak at cooper union
posing once again for a photograph
before he does
this time to commemorate the speech that
some say makes him president
lincoln again seems somehow to intuit
and paraphrase what douglas is saying
slavery is a system of brute force
it shields itself behind might rather
than right
it must be met with its own weapons
neither
let us be slandered from our duty by
false accusations against us
nor frightened from it by menaces of
destruction to the government nor of
dungeons to ourselves
let us have faith that right makes might
and in that faith let us to the end
dare to do our duty as we understand it
as the 1860 presidential election
approaches their positions have evolved
lincoln
seen here in june will tolerate no
slavery expansion but vows that he will
not interfere where slavery where it
already exists
douglas
photographed around the same time
is prepared to embrace the idea of
working within the system to bring about
slavery's ultimate extinction
but as quickly as possible
my position now is one of reform
not of revolution
i would act for the abolition of slavery
through the government
not over its ruins
if slaveholders have ruled the american
government for the last fifty years
let the anti-slavery men rule the nation
for the next fifty years
if the south has made the constitution
been to the purposes of slavery
let the north now make that instrument
bend to the cause of freedom and justice
let the free men of the north who have
the power in their own hands resolve to
blot out forever the foul and haggard
crime
which is the blight and mildew the curse
and the disgrace of the united states
lincoln wins the presidency
and on march 4th 1861 he takes the oath
of office holding out the olive branch
of peace
and compromise
even though seven slave-holding southern
states have already seceded from the
union
douglas as you will hear regards the
oration
which most most contemporaries consider
one of lincoln's best
as a giant step backward
in the fight against slavery my
countrymen one and all think calmly and
well upon this whole subject
nothing valuable can be lost
by taking time
such of you as a now dissatisfied still
have the old constitution unimpaired
and
on the sensitive point the laws of your
own framing under it
while the new administration will have
no immediate power if it would
to change either
one section of the country believes
slavery is right and ought to be
extended
while the other believes it is wrong and
ought not to be extended this
is the only substantial dispute
why should there not be a patient
confidence in the ultimate justice of
the people
is there any better
or equal hope
in the world
in your hands
my dissatisfied fellow countrymen and
not in mine
is the momentous issue of civil war
the government will not assail you
you can have no conflict without being
yourselves the aggressors
you have no oath registered in heaven to
destroy the government
while i
shall have the most solemn one to
preserve
protect
and defend it
i am loaf
to close
we are not enemies
but friends
we must not be enemies
no passion may have strained it might
not it must not break
our bonds of affection
the mystic chords of memory stretching
from every battlefield and patriot grave
to every living heart and hearthstone
all over this broad land
will yet swell the chorus of the union
when again touched as surely they will
be
by the better angels of our nature
it was weak
uncalled for
and useless for mr lincoln to begin his
inaugural address
by prostrating himself before the foul
and withering curse of slavery
the occasion was one for honest rebuke
not for palliations and apologies
the slaveholders should have been told
that their
the barbarous system of sl of robbery is
contrary to the spirit of the age
and to the principles of liberty in
which the federal government was founded
and that they should be ashamed to be
everlastingly pressing that scandalous
crime into notice
some thought that we had in mr lincoln
the nerve and decision of oliver
cromwell
but the result shows that we merely have
a continuation of the pierces and
buchanans
and that the republican president bends
the knee to slavery as readily as any of
his infamous predecessors
mr lincoln is like the great mass of his
countrymen indebted to the south for
both law and gospel
with such declarations before them
coming from our first anti-slavery
president the abolitionists must know
what to expect during the next four
years
by independence day the confederacy has
attacked fort sumter in charleston and
troops are massing for their first
battle in virginia
lincoln
tells congress he is determined to fight
rebellion to the end but he never
mentions slavery as its roots cause or
freedom as its inevitable result
and again douglas is livid this is
essentially a people's contest
on the side of the union
it is a struggle for maintaining in the
world that form and substance of
government whose leading object is to
elevate the condition of men
to lift artificial weights from all
shoulders
to clear the paths of laudable pursuit
for all to afford all an unfettered
start
and a fair chance in the race of life
our popular government has often been
called an experiment
it is now for us to demonstrate to the
world
that those who can fairly carry an
election can also suppress a rebellion
that ballots are the rightful and
successful successors of bullets and
that when ballots have fairly and
constitutionally decided
there can be no successful appeal back
to bullets
such will be a great lesson of peace
teaching men
that what they cannot take by election
neither can they take it by a war
the people at heart are against slavery
none other than wolves hearts can be
otherwise
all they want is a leader with power and
authority
and they are ready to follow where he
leads
they are yet checked by supposed
constitutional objections and by
practical difficulties
president lincoln has only to devise the
mode of avoiding those difficulties of
law and practice and they will have the
joyous support of the great heart of
america and the blessings of those ready
to perish
as the union loses battle after battle
douglas implores lincoln to widen
military opportunity
disrupt the enemy home front and preempt
the threat of european recognition of
the confederacy
by striking a transformative blow
against slavery
unbeknownst to douglas
lincoln indeed drafts an emancipation
proclamation and even proposes it to his
cabinet in july 1862
but they convince him to defer it until
a union victory occurs so the order will
not be interpreted as an act of
desperation
so lincoln tables it
and then begins issuing statements
designed to assure white america that if
he does act
it will be out of military necessity not
humanitarian sympathy he is that fearful
about white public opposition
especially with off-year elections
approaching
douglas at first tolerates this campaign
of disinformation but
not for long
ultimately lincoln's words enrage him
again my paramount object in this
struggle is to save the union
and is not either to save or destroy
slavery
if i could save the union without
freeing any slave i would do it and if i
could save it by freeing all the slaves
i would do it and
if i could save it by freeing some and
leaving others alone
i would also do that i have here stated
my purpose according to my view of
official duty
and i intend no modification of my oft
expressed personal wish
that all men everywhere
could be free
it is true that the president lays down
his propositions with many
qualifications
some of which to my thinking are
unnecessary unjust and holy unwise
there are also spots on the sun
a blind man can see where the
president's heart is
i read the spaces as well as the lines
of his message what good would a
proclamation of emancipation from me do
especially as we are now situated
i do not want to issue a document that
the whole world will see must
necessarily be in operative like the
pope's bull against the comet he was
elected and inaugurated as the
representative of the anti-slavery
policy of the republican party
and yet the actions of president lincoln
have been calculated in a marked and
decided way to shield and protect
slavery from the very blows which its
horrible crimes have loudly and
persistently inspired
he was scornfully rejected he has
scornfully rejected the policy of arming
the slaves he has steadily refused to
proclaim as he had the constitutional
and more right to proclaim complete
emancipation to all the slaves of rebels
to my mind his policy is simply and
solely to reconstruct the union on the
old and corrupting basis of compromise
by which slavery shall retain all the
power that it ever had your race are
suffering in my judgment the greatest
wrong inflicted on any people
but
even when you cease to be slaves
you are yet far removed from being
placed on inequality with the white race
on this broad continent
not a single man of your race is made
the equal of a single man of ours
it is better for us both therefore to be
separated
the president seems to be possessed of
an ever increasing passion for making
himself appear silly and ridiculous if
not worse
his argument is that the difference
between the white and black races
renders it impossible for them to live
together in the same country without
detriment to both
colonization he holds to be the duty and
interest of the colored people
it does not require any great amount of
skill to point out the fallacy and
expose the unfairness of this assumption
for by this time every man who has a
brain in his head even mr lincoln
himself must know that in many places
distinct races live peacefully together
in the enjoyment of civil rights
yet he says to the colored people i
don't like you
you must clear out of the country
slavery has caused this war not slaves
a proclamation
on the first day of january in the year
of our lord 1863
all persons held as slaves within any
state or designated part of a state the
people whereof shall then be in
rebellion against the united states
shall be then thenceforward and forever
free
signed abraham lincoln september 22nd
1862
we shout for joy that we live to record
this righteous decree
free forever
oh
long enslaved millions whose cries have
so vexed the air and the sky suffer on a
few more days in sorrow the hour of your
deliverance draws nigh
no
abraham lincoln will take no step
backwards his word has gone out over the
whole country and the world
giving joy and gladness to the friends
of freedom and progress
he will stand by them and carry them out
to the letter mr lincoln will not budge
an inch we cannot escape history
we of this congress and this
administration
will be remembered in spite of ourselves
the fiery trial through which we pass
will light us down in honor or dishonor
to the latest generation
in giving freedom to the slave we assure
freedom to the free
honorable alike in what we give
and what we preserve
we shall notably save or meanly lose the
last
best hope of earth
the way is played
peaceful
generous
just
a way which if followed
the world will forever applaud and god
must forever bless
its effect will be great and increasing
its changes it changes the character of
the war and gives it an important
principle as an object instead of a
national pride and interest
it recognizes and declares the real
nature of the contest
and places the north on the side of
justice and civilization and the rebels
on the side of robbery and barbarism
upon this act
sincerely believed to be an act of
justice
warranted by the constitution
upon military necessity
i invoke the considerate judgment of
mankind
and the gracious favor of almighty god
in witness whereof
i have set my hand to this final
emancipation proclamation
abraham lincoln
january 1st 1863.
this is scarcely a day for pros
it is a day for poetry and song
a new song
perhaps it is not a proclamation of
liberty throughout the land unto the
inhabitants thereof as we had hoped it
would be
but was one marked by reservations and
discriminations
but it is a vast and glorious step in
the right
direction men of color to arms
words are now useful only as they
stimulate
blows
now
or never
liberty won by white men would lose half
its luster
better even to die free than to live
slaves
and so the recruitment of black troops
begins as does the first military draft
for all
new york responds with bloody draft
riots in which african americans are the
principal victims
around the same same time as those riots
black soldiers died bravely in an
assault on a confederate stronghold in
charleston known as battery wagner in
which douglas's own son
a recent recruit
to the soon to be fabled 54th
massachusetts
fights in the ranks and is one of the
few to survive
but still black troops are paid less
than white
and while white soldiers earn bonuses to
buy uniforms
black recruits must pay out of their
meager paychecks for theirs
on august 10 1863
frederick douglass finally pays his
first call on the white house
his first visit ever to any american
president
to protest
he vividly remembered this confrontation
with the literally larger than life
lincoln whom he found sitting in his
chair waiting
on my approach
he slowly drew his feet in
from the different parts of the room
into which they had strayed
and he began to rise
and continue to rise
until he looked down upon me
then extended his hand and gave me a
welcome
i began with some hesitation to tell him
who i was but he soon stopped me in a
sharp cordial voice you need not tell me
who you are mr douglas
i know who you are
then he invited me to take a seat beside
him
seeing that he was busy
i stated to him the object of my call at
once
mr lincoln i am recruiting colored
troops
i have assisted in fitting up two
regiments in massachusetts and i am now
at work in the same way in pennsylvania
i have come to say this to you sir if
you wish to make this branch of the
service successful you must do four
things
first you must give colored soldiers the
same pay that you give white soldiers
second
you must compel the confederate states
to treat colored soldiers when taken
prisoners as prisoners of war
third when any colored soldier performs
brave meritorious exploits in the field
you must enable me to say
to those that i recruit that they will
be promoted for such service precisely
as white men are
fourth
in case any colored soldiers are
murdered in cold blood
you should retaliate in kind
to this little speech mr lincoln
listened with earnest attention and with
very apparent sympathy i told douglas
about the opposition generally to
employing negroes as soldiers at all
of the prejudice against his race
and of the advantage two colored people
that would result from their being
employed as soldiers in defense of their
country
now
as to pay
we had to make some concession to
prejudice
well there were threats that if we made
soldiers of them at all
white men would not enlist would not
fight beside them
besides
it was not believed that a negro could
make a good soldier
as good a soldier as a white man
and hence it was thought that he should
not have the same pay
as a white man
but
i assure you mr douglas
that in the end
they shall have the same pay as white
soldiers
i met mr lincoln several times after
that interview
i was once invited by him to take tea
with him at the soldier's home
his summer residence
on another occasion while i was talking
to him in the white house the governor
of connecticut sent in his card
i was amused by the way mr lincoln told
his messenger tell governor buckingham
to wait
i want to have a long talk with my
friend douglas
he used those words
i said mr lincoln i will retire but he
said oh no no no no no you shall not
i want governor buckingham to wait
and he did wait
for at least a half hour
in all my interviews with mr lincoln i
was impressed with his entire freedom
from popular prejudice against the
colored race
he was the first great man that i talked
with in the united states freely
who in one single instance reminded me
of the difference between himself and
myself of the difference of color and i
thought
that was all the more remarkable because
he came from a state where there were no
there were black laws
i account partially for his kindness to
me because of the similarity with which
i had fought my way up
we both started at the lowest rung of
the ladder
a few months after lincoln and douglas
first meet
a few days after he sits for this photo
the president heads to a small town in
pennsylvania where a fierce battle in
july the biggest in the history of the
continent
had been fought and won
and here at gettysburg
where we see him in the distance on the
speaker's platform a few hours from
immortality
he finally does provide the poetry for
which douglas yearned after reading the
legalistic prose of the emancipation
the date is november 19
1863
four score and seven years ago
our fathers brought forth on this
continent a new nation
conceived in liberty and dedicated to
the proposition that all men are created
equal
now we are engaged in a great civil war
testing whether that nation or any
nation so conceived and so dedicated can
long endure
we are met
on a great battlefield of that war
we have come
to dedicate a portion of that field as a
final resting place for those who here
gave their lives that that nation might
live
it is all together fitting and proper
that we should do this
but in a larger sense
we cannot dedicate
we cannot consecrate
we cannot hallow this ground
the brave men living and dead who
struggled here have consecrated it far
above our poor power to add or detract
the world will little note
nor long remember what we say here but
it can never forget what they did here
it is for us
the living rather
to be dedicated here to the unfinished
work which they who fought here have
thus far so nobly advanced
it is rather for us
to be here dedicated to the great task
remaining before us
that from these honor dead we take
increased devotion to that cause for
which they gave the last full measure of
devotion
that we here highly resolve
that these dead shall not have died in
vain that this nation under god shall
have a new birth of freedom and that
government of the people by the people
for the people
shall not perish from the earth
thousands of negroes are now being
enrolled in the service of the federal
government
they freely and joyously rally around
the flag of the union and take all the
risks involved in this war
they do it not for the money
for thus far
they pay their pay is less than that of
white men
they go into this war to affirm their
manhood
to strike for liberty and country
if any class of men in this war can
claim the honor of fighting for
principle not for passion for ideas not
from brutal malice the cult soldier can
make that claim preeminently
for he strikes for freedom
there are those who are dissatisfied
with me you say will not fight to free
negroes
some of them seem willing to fight for
you
why should they do anything for us if we
will do nothing for them
if they stake their lives for us
they must be prompted by the strongest
motive even the promise of freedom
and the promise being made
it must be kept
the signs look better
peace does not appear as
distant
as it did
i hope it will come soon
and then
there will be some black men
who can remember that with
silent tongue and clenched teeth and
steady eye and well-poised bayonet they
have helped mankind on to this great
consummation while i fear
there will be some white ones
unable to forget
that with malignant heart and deceitful
speech
they have strove to hinder it
by september 1864 lincoln comes to the
conclusion that he will lose
his campaign for a second term
the north is tired of military failure
and wholesale slaughter
lincoln prepares to turn the government
over to the democrats aware that they
will likely cancel the emancipation
proclamation on their first day in
office
but first he summons douglas back to the
white house and asks him to undertake an
extraordinary new mission
to bring freedom to as many slaves as
possible while they can
lincoln ultimately wins a second term
but not before douglas submits a bold
plan to spread the word of emancipation
since the interview with which your
excellency was pleased to honor me a few
days ago
i have conversed with several
trustworthy and patriotic colored men
concerning your suggestion that
something should be specially done to
inform slaves in the rebel states of the
true state of affairs
we have discussed how
best to warn them as to what will be
their
probable condition should peace be
concluded while they remain within the
rebel lines and more especially to urge
upon them the necessity of making their
escape
i therefore submit the ways and means by
which such persons may be rested from
the enemy and brought within our lives
the plan he asked me to com compose was
evidence conclusive on mr lincoln's part
that the proclamation so far at least as
he was concerned was not offered merely
as a necessity the election
was a necessity
but we cannot have free government
without elections and if the rebellion
could force us to forego or postpone a
national election
it might fairly claim to have already
conquered and ruined us
on march 4th
1865
a visibly exhausted abraham lincoln
makes his way to the capitol to take the
oath of office for the second time and
to deliver the address that many
including lincoln himself judge his best
speech ever
it is overcast as the president waits
his turn on the east portico
for the ceremony to begin
but as he concludes his speech the sun
breaks out an omen that sends an
electric thrill through the vast and for
the first time fully integrated crowd
i was present at the inauguration
i felt there was murder in the air
and i kept close to his carriage on the
way to the capitol for i felt that i
might see him fall that day
it was a vague presentment
i could feel it in the atmosphere
i got right in front of the east
particle of the capital and witnessed
his being sworn in
then i heard mr lincoln deliver his
wonderful address
it was very short
the confederate cause was on its last
legs but he answered all the objections
to his prolonging the war in one
sentence
it was a remarkable sentence fondly do
we hope
fervently do we pray
that this mighty scourge of war may
speedily pass away yet
if god wills that it continue until all
the wealth piled by the bondsman's 250
years of unrequited toil shall be sunk
and until every drop of blood drawn with
the last shall be paid by another drawn
with the sword
as was said three thousand years ago so
still it must be said the judgments of
the lord are true and righteous
all together
with malice
toward none
with charity
all
with firmness in the right as god gives
us to see the right
let us strive on to finish the work we
are in
to bind up the nation's wounds
to care
for him who shall have borne the battle
and for his widow
and his orphan
to do all
which may achieve and cherish
a just and lasting peace
among ourselves
and with all nations
for the first time in my life and i
suppose the first time in any colored
man's life
i attended the reception of president
lincoln on the evening of the
inauguration
as i approached the door i was seized by
two policemen and forbidden to enter
i bolted right past them on the inside i
was taken charge of by two other
policemen who conducted me out the
window on a plank
oh i said
this will not do gentlemen
just say to mr lincoln that fred douglas
is at the door
in less than half a minute i was invited
into the east room
i could not have been more than ten feet
away from him when mr lincoln saw me
his countenance lighted up and he said
in a voice that was heard all around
here comes my friend douglas
douglas
i saw you in the crowd today
listening to my inaugural address
there is no man whose opinion i value
more than yours
what did you think of my speech
mr lincoln i cannot stop here to talk to
you
there are thousands waiting to shake
your hand what did you think of it
mr lincoln it was a sacred effort
i'm glad you liked it
and that was the last time that i saw it
six weeks later just as douglas feared
on inauguration day lincoln falls victim
to an assassin
an assassin who had in fact been in the
capitol on inauguration day and was
restrained by a policeman
then 11 years later on the anniversary
of the murder
douglas rose to deliver the principal
address at the unveiling of a statue of
lincoln
as emancipator
and while the sculpture of the white
leader lifting a kneeling slave seems
politically incorrect by modern
standards
it was in fact commissioned and entirely
funded by free people of color
douglas has enjoyed now more than a
decade to think about lincoln the man
the president
and the liberator he once regarded as
slow but sure
and this is what he says to the white
crowd that day
the race to which we belong
were not the special objects of his
consideration
i concede to you my white fellow
citizens that you and yours were the
objects of his deepest affection
you
are the children of abraham lincoln
we are at best only his step children
children by adoption
children by forces of circumstances and
necessity
he was preeminently the white man's
president
but while abraham lincoln saved for you
a country
he delivered us
from bondage
one hour of which was worse than ages of
the oppression your fathers rose in
rebellion to oppose
we saw him
measured him
and estimated him and in view of that
divinity
which shapes our soul
rough you them how we will
we came to the conclusion that the hour
and the man of our redemption had
somehow met in person of abraham lincoln
under his wise and beneficent rule
we saw ourselves gradually lifted from
the depths of slavery to the heights of
liberty and manhood
he could receive counsel from a child
and give counsel to a sage
the simple approach
the simple approached him with ease and
the learned approached him with
deference
to lincoln the entire struggle
both for the union and black freedom had
been conducted for one reason
to extend and preserve the american
promise of equal opportunity
so he had made abundantly clear in his
final speeches to union veterans before
his death
especially after desperate confederates
proposed recruiting slaves into their
depleted armies
having
in my life heard many arguments or
strings of words meant to pass for
arguments intended to show
that the negro ought to be a slave
if he shall now
really fight to keep himself a slave
it'll be a far better argument why he
should remain a slave than any i have
ever heard before
i've always thought that all men should
be free
whenever i hear anyone arguing for
slavery
i feel a strong impulse to see it tried
on him personally
i suppose you are all going home to your
family
and your friends
for the service you have done
in this great struggle
i present you
sincere thanks for myself
and the country
it is not merely for today
but for all time to come
that we should perpetuate for our
children's children
this great
and free government
i happen temporarily to occupy this
big white house
i am a living witness
that any one of your children
may look to come here
as my father's child has
the nation is worth fighting for
to secure such
an inestimable
jewel
[Music]
[Applause]
take another sure
[Applause]
[Music]
one more
[Music]
up next on american history tv columnist
jamie steem compares the lives and
achievements of frederick douglass and
harriet tubman
she examines how growing up in maryland
impacted their lives and led to their
work as abolitionists the georgetown
public library sponsored this hour-long
event
good afternoon everyone my name is jerry
mccoy thank you for coming out on a very
blustery washington dc day
on behalf of the district of columbia
public library i'd like to thank you
for coming uh
to the peabody room today to hear our
guest lecturer
um just a little bit about the peabody
room the peabody room was named after
george peabody this gentleman in the
oval portrait over here
and he was a merchant uh financier and
philanthropist who got his start in
business here in georgetown in 1812 he
was 17 years old he came here from
a newburyport massachusetts with his
uncle
and they opened up a dry goods store
down on m street
despite his third grade education he was
a financial genius
he moved on to baltimore where the
action was
in the early 19th century was there for
20 years you probably have heard of the
peabody conservatory of music that's his
namesake
he became a multi-millionaire
he was an importer of goods from great
britain so he eventually moved to london
lived there the remainder of his life
and in his will of 1867 he decided to
give all of his millions away
to establish educational organizations
uh this was a generation before andrew
carnegie did the same thing with his
money
so to the community of georgetown he
left fifteen thousand dollars to
establish a library georgetown had no
library at the time
and this room was named in honor of mr
peabody and it serves as a repository
for georgetown neighborhood history
georgetown being the oldest neighborhood
in washington d.c founded in 1751
a full 49 years before the nation's
capital was founded in 1800
today's speaker is jamie steam
we welcome her back uh this is her
second talk in 2016.
the second saturday of each month she's
giving a talk about
um
individual american personages who
really impacted american history and
jamie is a creator syndicate columnist
and contributor to usnews.com
and today she's going to give a talk
about frederick douglass
and harriet tubman
how douglas worked by day under the sun
and harriet tubman worked by night under
the stars
her talk next month will be on rachel
carson
that will be held on
saturday march 12th so please pick up a
flyer on your way out
and i also have these really nice jumbo
postcards that lists her entire 2016
speaking schedule so everyone must have
these two pieces of paper in their hand
before they leave today so thank you
very much for coming and i'll turn the
speaker and the podium over to jamie
thank you
[Applause]
jerry thank you for hosting us in this
amazing space which sets the tone for
the 19th century very nicely
if we could transport ourselves to the
eastern shore of maryland
there harriet tubman and frederick
douglass
the two most known african-americans of
the civil war era were born into slavery
at about the same time
they did not know their birthdays but
their birth places were about 20 miles
apart
perhaps because of his border state
status
maryland's slave owning past is often
forgotten today
and yet as the lives and scars physical
scars of these two figures attest
slavery in maryland could be as
oppressive
as the cotton fields of the deep south
swathes of white family owned farmland
were worked by thousands of enslaved
people who also worked on the water
to bring back the catch of the
chesapeake bay
and in no part of the state was slavery
as brutal
as the eastern shore
conditions exposed by the oddly parallel
lives of these two famous marylanders
on his autobiography's first page
douglas described the harsh land of
talbot county
his boyhood
he said it was marked by the desert-like
appearance of its soil and the general
dilapidation of its farms and fences the
choptank river he wrote was among the
laziest and muddiest of streams
surrounded by a white population of the
lowest order
indolent and drunken to a proverb
get away with words
20 miles away tubman's family lived in
still deeper isolation near cambridge
in a hard scrabble part of the world
with very few fine indoor things
but she had the luck to know and live
with her family
her close-knit family
and douglas was separated from his
mother and grandmother as a child that
was a cut that never healed
he also never knew who his father was
his father was white
at the same time
frederick was a very bright boy who
learned to read at a young age because
of a kind mistress and his playmate
tommy who was the
little lord and master of the wealthy
home
the two of them were very close
and
douglas kind of rode or hitchhiked on
tommy's privilege his schooling his
he in other words got a very lucky break
as a young slave and that's something
that tubman never got such a lucky break
she never had any exceptional privilege
like most people born into slavery she
remained illiterate all her life
she signed her name with an ex
fortunately for both the state's large
population of free blacks and the
presence of sympathetic anti-slavery
quakers on the eastern shore
made it easier to escape from freedom
delaware the neighboring state was a
slave state also so the goal is to get
to the mason-dixon line between maryland
and pennsylvania
that was the board between slavery and
freedom
douglas and tubman fled from bondage as
young adults
he in 1838 and she in 1849
she walked and he took the train
tubman soon became a legendary conductor
on the underground railroad and was the
first woman to later execute an armed
expedition in the civil war as her
biographer kate clifford larson put it
she worked by night in secret silence
stealth
navigating by the north star and the
light of the moon
during the 1850s she led 13 groups
of enslaved family members and kin
to freedom
and she returned to the egypt
of the eastern shore time and again
exposing the risk of capture
on the african-american underground
network
she was known as
moses the spiritual leader of her people
let my people go
she sang in her husky-haunting voice
often in code
she let it be known she carried a pistol
inspiring fear in the hearts of slave
catchers
who never caught up with her
although she was the most wanted
fugitive
they didn't even know what she looked
like
because she traveled in disguise
she let me know that the pistol she
would use her pistol on anybody who
wanted to turn back
nobody in her groups
was allowed to turn back because that
would
need to be tangent match almost certain
betrayal
of the whole party
she was a very very
tough and
resilient
and incredibly
gifted in in navigating land by night if
you can imagine all those like swamps
and the fields and the forests of the
chesapeake bay area that took a lot of
daring do
to not only do once but twice and thrice
and four times
douglas of course became a freedom
fighter in a different sense
he was a brilliant voice on the page
in person
for slave emancipation
strikingly handsome and charismatic
he made his debut as a speaker on
nantucket islands
and he became a sensation almost
overnight
in a way he took the path opposite
tubman's speaking in the sun of the 19th
century public square
it was very much the age of the spoken
wor
word here in washington daniel webster
all over the country people would go to
he'll hear people speak that was like a
civic it's not a duty recreation
and so that's why there's so many great
speakers in the 1840s and 50s
but their lives continue to run parallel
in 1859
douglas and tubman were both asked
independently by john brown to take part
in his raid on the federal arsenal in
harpers ferry
brown regretted not having tubman
fighting on his side he said later
not for nothing did he call her general
tubman
so jet for john brown to call you
general tubman that's saying something
um douglas and hubbard both knew that
that was not going to happen that the
raid would fail they both refused to
have
to take part in it but they were both
confidants of john brown they both liked
and respected john brown enormously
and
douglas was close to the so-called
secret six
who provided funds to brown they're
coming from boston
most likely samuel ward
howe was one of them
and
but by refusing his entreaties
uh they both saved their own lives
and incidentally the colonel who put
down the raid
and who captured john brown for hanging
and
for trial and then hanging
played a pivotal part in the civil war
it was robert e lee
colonel robert e lee who is a career
army officer
who went to west point and so that was
his you know last deed for the union and
when he defected to the south to the
confederacy that did not sit well with
his fellow army officers who went to
west point with him and lincoln the
commander-in-chief was also furious um
that lee should
should
um
you know not report to judy
to the union and uh so all these
characters
are
you know wedded together and have
different um
intersections so i thought that that
might be interesting
to note that robert lee was at the scene
of harper's ferry
that was like the last match in the pa
powder keg of the civil war because
although it failed it succeeded in
alarming
um the whole south and
it just brought
the two sides you know two blows
so in a way john brown succeeded with
his revolutionary raid
um
harriet tubman frederick douglass they
weren't
revolutionaries in the same way but they
were non-violent revolutionaries
by this time then two marylanders knew
each other with mutual friends like
william lloyd garrison the bostonian
abolitionist and the philadelphia quaker
abolitionist and women's rights leader
lucretia mott whom we discussed last
time
tubman once brought a group of 13
runaway slaves to the douglas home in
rochester
new york
where he put them up in his barn before
they got away to canada he was extremely
nervous
about having these runaway slaves
because he thought the slave catchers
were very hot on their heels and if they
were
captured then he would be arrested as
well
so anytime you house sheltered
gave any kind of aid to a runaway slave
you
you could be arrested you could be taken
as well
that was what
another match on the powder keg of the
civil war was the fugitive slave act
um
so both
um douglas and tubman were very much on
the front lines
leading up to the civil war
tubman also stayed as a guest at douglas
house at least once in the run-up to the
civil war
possibly to discuss john brown's plan
his daring plan
but strangely given their chesapeake
connection
and their mutual regard
tubman and douglas never seemed that
close
in public
both continued to play important roles
after the war began
in 1861
advocating for blacks to serve as
soldiers
for strategic reasons as well as
political reasons
douglas actually visited president
lincoln
and had a frank exchange with them with
the president on enlisting
african-american soldiers and paying
them equal wages
lincoln took his advice on one point but
not the other
tubman likewise urged legions of young
men to enlist as colored volunteers
using the force of her persuasion and
her influence
but she also found herself seeing
military action as a union spy
and scout across enemy lines in south
carolina the heart of a confederacy
so the story of her life was crossing
enemy lines she was an outstanding spy
for that reason
the plain broad-shouldered woman was
small but reportedly as strong as any
man
and when she wasn't working as a spy she
was also an army nurse and lawn dress
she later collected a military pension
tubman's most impressive mission was to
guide colonel james montgomery
and about 300 black troops
as they raided plantations
seized harvests and livestock and
destroyed and burned a bridge
along south carolina's
compti river
in june of 1863.
the civil war had gained new meaning by
that time with the emancipation
proclamation of january 1st that year
and
along the way of their their raid
montgomery and tubman invited and urged
hundreds of slaves in south carolina to
climb aboard their union steamboats for
freedom
tubman raised her voice
she sang
she cut the air as she urged the
escaping slaves
to
join them
and that's proof that she was no slouch
as a public figure
a charismatic speaker or presence
herself
a wisconsin state journal reporter on
the scene praised her singular
patriotism sagacity and energy
that's a contemporary account
in the end
tubman's critical role in civil war era
events cannot be traced as clearly as
that of douglas
the eloquent douglas
in recent years some grumbling has
surfaced on and beyond the eastern shore
because people say with some justice
that
douglas the native son gets all the
glory
leaving tubman's character in the
shadows
much as he did in life
douglas said it best in an 1868
letter to dear harriet
1868 three years after the civil war
ended
he commented on her nocturnal journeys
harriet the difference between us is
very marked
most that i have done and suffered in
the service of our cause
has been in public
i have wrought in the day
you in the night
i have had the applause of the crowd
while the most that you have done has
been witnessed by a few trembling
scarred and footsore bond men and women
the midnight sky and the silent stars
have been the witnesses of your devotion
to freedom and of your heroism
yet
douglas himself did not give tubman the
light of day
in his voluminous autobiography
ironically her name is missing
from these pages of his magisterial life
story
the few words that he left in that
letter i just read
however go a long way
in telling her tale
so
so those are the few words that i had to
say and i also would like to read you
some passages from douglas's
autobiography
and i can take questions after that on
their lives and
their their times and
they both lived to great old age and
were celebrated um
by
the nation
they both lived in upstate new york
interestingly
because upstate new york was a very it
was a haven actually for free thinking
for for progress as chautauqua's
as you may know and douglas did end his
days here in washington
i'll tell you about that in a moment um
and
our friend sarah jenks has been to visit
frederick dallas's home many times so
maybe you could say a few words about
that
later
frederick douglass described the great
house of the plantation that he lived on
as a boy
and very
almost like as a rembrandt painter that
all the flesh and the and the foul and
the swans and the beef and the carriages
and the stables and the fruits of the
garden the tender asparagus he had this
gift for capturing
in memory
sort of a vanished way of life of
extremely privileged
slave plantation life i was able to
visit the plantation where frederick
douglass was born
the same family is living there
the 11th generation of the lloyd family
and there were some stories that they
that mrs lloyd who was 87 she took me
into her parlor and told me a few
stories
that they had kept you know handing down
through the ages
about frederick
so he is very
descriptive not only in the um
what's on the table
but the sociology of the plantation
the aristocracy he said of the house
servants
um he was one of them or he was mostly
in the great house
and how
you know working in the fields was what
such a incredibly
trying and brutal and
he when he got older he found out what
it was like to be
under the lash
of an overseer because he was a very
strong and very spirited
slave and he was actually sent to a
slave breaker
to break his spirit fortunately he
didn't succeed
let's see
here the graceful swan the black-necked
wild goose partridges quails pheasants
pigeons and choice waterfowl with all
their strange
varieties were caught in this huge net
beef field
mutton and venison
we get the idea he summed it up by
saying
immense wealth and its lavish
expenditure filled the great house
filled the great house
with all that could please the eye
or tempt the taste
so that's a vivid memory from
you know his early childhood
um
he did get another lucky break which is
that he was sent to baltimore
to
still he was still a slave but he got to
do wage work on the docks of fells point
so as a waterfront worker
he
all he had to do to observe his slave
status was to give his master most of
his wages at the end of the week
but he had more freedom
day to day as a young man
he belonged to the east baltimore mental
improvement society
so that was a informal
network of young
black male workers who you know read
each other newspapers traded news
traded thoughts ideas news it was kind
of like a survival strategy
and he was his early early 20s he was
plotting his escape
and because he was in baltimore
it was easier than walking across you
know the vast
you know frontier of the chesapeake bay
how did he
how did he make his escape he borrowed a
sailor's
outfit and cravat and you know hat he
dressed as a sailor
and he said because he worked on the
waterfront as a cocker
you know what a cocker is
okay a cocker is um you put they put
cork and rubber
on chips to make them more buoyant to
make them
you know more more sea worthy
that was a skill that was a skill that
he was
you know able to
take anywhere he went
um and where he went was he took the
train
from baltimore
up to philadelphia
not as easy as taking amtrak because at
the susquehanna river there was a ferry
boat
there were you know many more stops
along the way
and he was acutely conscious that any
moments you know if anyone saw him and
recognized him and betrayed him that was
that he would be arrested and probably
sent back to the the country to the land
and be or even ship down south
so he writes in here a critical moment
in the drama of my whole future depended
upon the decision of this conductor
when he came to check his papers
all
blacks were required to have free papers
which he didn't have but he had his
sailors document his and he kind of
traded on the goodwill that people had
towards sailors and the conductor kind
of let him go
taking his word for the fact that he was
a slave that he was a sailor
so
that voyage to philadelphia and then
farther north to new york and then
up to new bedford massachusetts
that was the end that kept his slave
narrative
and he he says to the reader
thus ends you know my experience as a
slave other chapters will tell the story
of my life as a free man
1838
a free man a free young man but the
1830s and 1840s were a very rough
mean
nasty decade where there's a lot of mob
violence
so
he was told don't stay in new york
don't stay in new york because someone
will give you up
go farther north
to massachusetts
so in new bedford which is on the water
he could take his skill he could make a
living and all of a sudden he was a free
man and he was a safer
from the south
um than he would have been if he'd
stayed in in new york
so gradually he
has prominence you know grows as his
reputation as a speaker
makes the newspapers and
he became like
the
main attraction on the abolitionist
network because he was a he was an
orator he had a gift for orally oratory
as well and for
capturing and
um humanizing the plight of the slave
it was a testament from his own personal
experience and he was the first
one to
address northern audiences with that
power
has the power of his personal story
which he told so well
and he just kept becoming more and more
sought after as a speaker he went to
ireland he went to
london he went to scotland he met the
great politicians of the day there like
daniel o'connell
and he
even met thomas clarkson
who was really the founder of the
abolitionist movement
in the united kingdom
because clarkson was a journalist who
got hold of he observed what happened on
slave ships and he wrote about them
documented them so in a way douglas
documented in spoken words what clarkson
had told of the horror
in the in the united kingdom and when
clarkson finally met him
he said
god bless you frederick douglass
if i had another 60 years to live i
would continue to vote to devote myself
to that cause our cause
so he was a young man compared to
clarkson being the old grand
man of the movement
moving on to
the civil war
um frederick douglass was
by now a newspaper publisher
in rochester new york
but he was very much involved in the
nation's business and he was the first
visitor
to abraham lincoln
in 1863
to urge the president to have black
soldiers enlisted in the union army
he had three sons that all enlisted in
the union army and he said that when he
met lincoln for the first time
the president said i know who you are mr
douglas
mr seward has told me all about you
i am glad to see you
please sit down
so with those very simple words of
welcome they got right to
the the subject at hand
and um
douglas recorded that he was never so
quickly or completely put at ease by a
great man as he was by abraham lincoln
the two established a camaraderie
and they had a substantive discussion
and
as it had as it turned out black
soldiers were very important to
to the rest of the civil war
the 54th
massachusetts regiment
was commanded by
robert gould shaw
there's a freeze of that of them in the
national gallery of art so
they were very heroic they served
incredibly well
camp william penn in pennsylvania was
near lucretia mott's house as a matter
of fact and even though she was a quaker
pacifist she made it her business to
bring over pies and
knit things to the soldiers and
it was very good for morale and cohesion
and to expand the meaning of citizenship
that president lincoln said yes let's
have
colored soldiers
fighting for the union
despite that despite their very um
cordial
exchange when the
second inaugural address came round
that was in march of 1865. so lincoln is
just given a magnificent
sort of a spiritual
healing
address and
frederick douglass was the first person
to socially
you know knock on the door of the white
house and say you know
i'm an invited guest may i come in he
was actually thrown
the guard threw him out and said you
don't belong here
and he said yes i do tell president
lincoln that frederick douglass is here
so he didn't take no for an answer and
then lincoln
went over to him and personally took him
by the hand and arm said come here
douglas there's no what did you think of
my speech today i saw you listening in
the audience
there's and he says mr president you
don't need to know my opinion of your
sacred effort and he said oh yes douglas
there's nobody whose opinion i would
rather have
than yours
now why was that seen not in steven
spielberg's movie
why
that's a terrible omission
in my opinion
so
the two of them connected on many levels
and seem to have a
friendly
understanding mutual understanding
and yet when
after
lincoln was assassinated in 1876
there's a colored memorial
um
not far from the capitol
and it was
a throng of people
freed slaves who
had
gathered on the 4th of july
1876
and
and douglas was you know he now by now
he is a senior statesman he's also was
an ambassador to haiti he was many
things the recorder of deeds in the
district of columbia
so here he stands and he gives his
assessment of lincoln which is not
altogether flowery
or rosy
he said and i quote
he was preeminently
the white man's president
he was ready to protect slavery
in his early years
he said we are like his step-children
not his children
and i
think this is important for us to um
note here today
because he also sympathized with lincoln
he said he was assailed by abolitionists
when he came to washington and he was
also assailed by slave owners
he was catching
you know anger from both sides
like another president we know
um but he said at the end of the day our
faith in him did not fail
because mr lincoln hated slavery
he loathed slavery and we know that to
be true
as a young man lincoln witnessed
bondage i think he was on the
mississippi river
in new orleans and he personally hated
the peculiar institution
when he got off the train to become
president in 1861
his goal was not to free the slaves
what was his goal
his goal was
to keep the union together
it was it was real estate
it was just whatever i have to do i will
do to keep the union together
and
in
a year and a half
there was a revolution going on inside
lincoln himself
he was transformed
by the civil war
so in the fire
in the crucible of the civil war
lincoln
moved his position
to making it about freedom
and douglas had a lot to do
with that
he was
most certainly
the most uh respected confidant that
lincoln had that could tell him what's
happening you know on the
the slave and the free black
networks he freed four million slaves
with the stroke of a pen
and
and douglas was in that struggle from
1838
all the way until 1863 and then some
um
he was also involved in other rights
movements
um he was at seneca falls
in 1848 what happened at seneca falls in
1848
the first women's rights convention
thank you
lucretia mott was the main speaker
elizabeth katie stanton had drafted this
declaration of sentiments
but frederick douglass was one of the
400 people who came to
this little town in upstate new york in
july and he urged the participants
who included james mott lucretia's
husband to include the ballot the vote
suffrage
on the list of duck the deco
declarations
and they did
but if you hadn't been there
that might not have happened it makes it
makes it ironic to look forward to
1865 when the political settlement of
the civil war did not include women's
suffrage
as it was supposed to because so many
people
women worked on both they were like one
in the same
those two
movements
at least in the minds of some
and uh the the chorus of the
hour was
the this is the negros hour
so ladies just step aside
and wait your turn so that was a long
wait from 1865 to 1920
when women finally won the vote so that
that is a
that is a very important episode in our
progressive history that i i'm
disappointed disappointed with frederick
douglass
for falling down on the job because i
think he could have made a difference
the other way
too
if he had supported women's suffrage
so he wasn't perfect we know that
lincoln wasn't perfect
um but
they
they were um
you know tremendously
determined spirits
and
they put their own lies at risk lincoln
lincoln's life was obviously at risk he
was the ultimate casualty of the civil
war
so
douglas led a very storied life and up
until the 1890s
when
he had a beach house in highland beach
which
is a beautiful little resort near
annapolis to this day you can go see the
house that he had and he was fond of
saying that
i i can stand here
on my porch a free man and look across
the water
to where i was born into slavery
so he he was always
reminding people reminding himself
of his long journey
on the last day of his life
he's vindicated i'm happy to say because
the last day of his life in the 1890s
here
she came home
to cedar hill
in anacostia
and he had just been to a women's rights
meeting
with susan b anthony
so
that was the last day of his life
and can you think of a better end for a
great man
so the struggle never really ended
um harriet tubman also lived to be very
old and celebrated storied she lived in
auburn new york
auburn
and uh
secretary of state seward
actually gave her or
rented
a house to her
she lived in a very nice house that
seward
wanted to make sure that she had a
comfortable old age for all her great
service to the union and she had um
aged people so it was like
for the colored and aged
and she lived to about 1912.
she had beautiful snow white hair have
you ever seen a picture of her in her
old age
she's she's striking and um
so she was like the woman of action
and he was like the man of words
and i'm happy to take any other
questions you have now thank you
[Applause]
yes sir
going back to harriet tubman
do we have do you have any idea for your
research or from
writings about her
given the
geography and
both the eastern shore and southern
maryland
the approximate routes
that she would lead her
underground railroad bands through i
know there was a stop here in georgetown
a couple a couple blocks away but
that may not have been one of hers do we
do know
how they got not exactly no and i don't
think they were the same each time
because
she would not replicate the journey
we didn't know exactly who her
you know the kind helpers were that
sheltered them but
um for the presence of maryland quakers
that um
that made all the difference in the
world but
as i said last time when we spoke about
lucretia mott
quakers don't really um
they don't brag about they don't make a
fuss about their their good deeds they
kind of do them more um just just to do
them
so we don't and and because she didn't
leave any written records we don't know
what the maps were of her
journeys but they were a long way they
were very arduous i mean they might have
to get down on their hands and knees
you know and crawl
over
certain you know
little rivers or all the obstacles in
their way and if you can imagine doing
that at night
um
under cover dart just
it just you had to have this incredible
um
you know deep desire to be free at all
costs
and that's why she took small groups
that was safer that way but if anyone
returned
to the that was that that was like all
of them being betrayed because they
would probably be whipped and tortured
until they
until the truth was told
um
she she just had this incredible iron
will and discipline and physical
capability
to um
this is more than stamina i think it's
the heart soul body mind everything
and
there in in the past there have been
reports that she's rescued as many as
400 or 500 from slavery it was probably
a smaller number
and there were kin these were her people
she wanted to let them
go
so that she earned the respect of people
like
john brown
who who knew the inc
you know what she what she had been
through and
there was no other woman like her
in during the civil war she was like
this
a standalone
and he was too
marcia
[Music]
um they liked each other they respected
each other
marcia they were like comrades in the
same
war fight but but they don't i do not
believe they were personal friends
they didn't
necessarily hang out together but they
knew that each each what could be relied
on to do their part and in the
you know in the fight forward but i
don't think they had that much
personally in
in common
he was raised very differently
and um
how many of you seen pictures of harriet
tubman
yeah how would you describe her
tiny strong
yeah
um i think she was no nonsense
um i don't i don't know this for a fact
but she might have thought okay well you
have you know you play your part on
stage but i i do
the dangerous work at night
um
they just didn't have that much in
common but
but who could have written such a
beautiful ode to her
as he did that's why i read that because
i think so from from a distance
he realized that her part in the whole
struggle and our cause was just as
valuable as his
does that answer your question
yes
i have a question and i guess in a
statement too i'm listening to you um
talk about the relationship between um
[Music]
as i'm listening to you i'm thinking
about malcolm x and martin luther king i
think they both knew they had two
different jobs to do
and their fight was they had the same
cause but that their fight was different
thank you that's a great insight yeah
so um the contrast between malcolm x and
martin luther king and the man who was
a pacifist
nonviolent resistance and malcolm x who
was fiery and more of a of a
revolutionary in a hurry and more maybe
more militant yeah i think just two
different the same fight with two
different ways of fighting and my
question is um i
wrote i dread scott and they were
working on the screenplay and i've been
trying the last 10 years and cannot find
any
documentation regarding
frederick douglass i know he made a
great speech about dred scott in new
york in 1857 but my question is and
we're still trying to figure out if
frederick douglass actually
talked to lincoln or anyone in
washington trying to agree dred
i don't believe so no
no
but i know that um as i'm sure you've
discovered that that that again was
another like final uh
sort of catalyst for the civil war
because lincoln and douglas and um all
the people
on the
union side
the emancipation side were absolutely
inferior that was such an incendiary
decision
that that was also like
the civil war was coming closer and
closer at the nail of the dred scott and
let's just say
that roger tawney
who was the supreme court
the chief justice
he's from maryland
he was a maryland slave owner a very
wealthy maryland slave owner and his
brother-in-law was whom
francis scott key
was his brother-in-law
yeah but during the time before
the blow family actually freed drinks
scott after the dread scott decision you
don't know if there was any
communication
with
frederick douglass and
the chief justice or the president
believes i i don't believe so i haven't
i haven't come across that i would
remember that's that's an excellent
question
well it is i think i missed you when you
said that lincoln was the ultimate
casualty of the civil war did i hear
that no yes okay
yeah that's
uh my our friend sarah jenkins actually
works at ford's theater
and i've learned a lot from going to
your programs there
did you have anything you wanted to say
about douglas and
lincoln or
cedar hill
sarah jenks the only thing i have to say
is that if you're really interested in
douglas today is the celebration of his
birthday at cedar hill
and it goes on until 4 30 and i
encourage you to go and and find out
more because it's wonderful
and there are all sorts of events
happening all day
today and tomorrow no it's just today
unfortunately i thought it was tomorrow
also because he celebrated his birthday
as february 14th he didn't know when his
birthday actually was but he celebrated
it as february
i know but the events are today i looked
it up on the web so everybody
you know where to go next
thank you sarah
yes
is there any evidence or
rumor that she actually
used her pistol
not in
not in the biographies i've read not in
the documents i've seen
and i i've actually met some of her
family too in cambridge
and
the fact that she had one
and it was loaded that sent a very
strong signal she would use it if she
had to
and in baltimore
there was a mural that depicted her with
a gun
in the street mural and
a lot of neighborhood organizations were
upset
to see
gun violence um depicted on a community
wall and the artist said this is my
vision of harriet tubman i'm not taking
the pistol away do you remember that
marcia um
that was a fascinating dialogue you
could see the point of view from both
sides but the the pistol was an
important part of
of her
leading to freedom
but
do you think that her most her biggest
concern was that if someone started out
on the journey with them and then they
got ready to go back um she had to kill
them because they could tell the route
yeah
absolutely
they would be whipped and tied and they
would be abused until they told the
truth
um slavery was a very
but i would you learn from douglass's
accounts is how physical slavery was you
know his but his back was
bruised and
scabs and
scars and
uh
harry tubman had a lot of bruises
bruises and scars to show for slavery
too it was a very fit is a physical
ordeal
almost it could be every day out in the
fields
uh someone yes sir
i'm astounded
did i hear you right the family who
enslaved frederick douglass still owns
the property yes they own this beautiful
they do gina genealogy
research
to try to determine his father and is he
within the family
the lloyd family could could well be but
not that
i don't think they've done any
any dna tests to prove it but it was an
extraordinary experience like in a time
capsule to go
to this
incredibly well preserved place it was
still owned by the family it wasn't a
museum
and mrs lloyd took me into the parlor
with
and she said when frederick was an envoy
he came sailing down the top tank with
some of his friends
so here he's a distinguished
you know
statesman and
he told his friends
that that's the house where he was born
the great house
and uh
he still thought of it you know it was
his boyhood home and he stopped
and
the young the latest but young mr lloyd
took him in and his friends
welcomed them
and served like mint juleps on the porch
or something
just because they happened to be sailing
and because frederick douglass had some
warm feeling about his past even though
you know he was a slave
and he
was separated from his mother and
grandmother still he had
certain certain
link
to this place and
the young man who took
him and his friends in
was the grandfather of mrs lloyd that i
was talking to
so you know one or two degrees of
separation and they kept passing down
that story on kind of a sense of
an accord
reconciliation
and um there was even a sense of pride
that frederick douglass was was born
there
in his book his autobiography he said
that he was
there are few people that he was closer
to than tommy his childhood playmate but
when tommy got older he became
he took on the errors and privileges and
just
he became
a master and he was still a slave so
that relationship was
defined by the society that they lived
in
and tommy's father
called frederick douglass to his death
bed because he wanted to have a
a last word with frederick and to ask
his forgiveness
so he he went
and
he went to say goodbye and he said well
fredrick i would have done the same
thing in your place
so he captures a lot of dialogue and
conversation and characteristics
this is not
the greatest autobiography in
african-american literature this is one
of the greatest autobiographies
in american literature
i often go back to it i found it at a
used bookstore in san francisco it went
to baltimore with me and um
here it is
and then there was a man who called
himself fredrick douglas iv
who looked just like him on the on the
fells point waterfront so he signed it
for me
are there any other questions yes
and susan the anthony are buried just
about next to each other up in the
rochester uh uh public and not public
but maine uh
uh
where are you
terry that sounds right i i'm sure
that's probably just a few times they
were comrades too yes and her she
celebrates her
i don't think her actual birthday is
february 15th
he's coming up this weekend and
lincoln's was the 12th yeah
i have quite a
a concentration
um yes
michelle while i love history
i would love to know what the models we
have in the present they are
for what character did and what
frederick that first did
so
the the notion that you can work
underground
and on a
one-to-one almost basis
and
as opposed to standing up in front of a
crowd
what are the models that we have today
that meet the needs of those two
lives of hurricanes
does the floor have any answers to that
question
what i would say is we would look at
what are the
oppressive
state
now
you know what are the laws
that exist
that is
unequal
and
designed to keep people of african
descent
down absolutely so and then
who's out there
making the greatest effort
to change that reality that's my plea i
want to know who they are
making a case to the public i would say
immigration would be another
cause
and just lacking someone who can put it
forcefully and eloquently the way
frederick douglass did from his own
experience
um
you know i that's an excellent question
i don't have an answer for you i'm sarah
do you well i don't have an absolutely
of course you can't have an absolute
answer but um i
it on twitter and
if frederick douglass were alive today
he would be a master of social media
if frederick douglass was alive he'd be
a master of social media
just as lincoln would be because they
both were masters of
communication of their day and there are
figures
on
who are using social media especially
twitter really effectively as means of
conveying their messages and i think
i can't remember any of the names right
now but i i follow them you know if you
go online and start following people who
are dealing with social justice issues
um
especially in the black lives matter
movement
you can find these people and
often i think they are people
like douglas and to some extent of
course the thing about harriet tubman is
she was
she was a
doer of deeds not a speaker of words in
quite the same way so you're like so
finding her is more complicated you're
finding her
does social media have the same force
does it
bring people together
the same way as being in the same space
and sarah would say yes
i would say maybe not
[Laughter]
and we have a woman over here who hasn't
had a justice beginning
movement i don't necessarily see that i
know in history we focus on individuals
but i do feel like there was a movement
that harriet tubman was involved in she
was the leader but i would say um
parallel to
her movement would be the black lives
matter movement the resistance the
underground and i would see like
frederick
douglass the contemporary being
electoral politics
someone who's involved in the life
because he was going that way
yeah
thomas coates
i don't know i'm just
what his ideology would be yes well all
right and frederick douglass also like
lucretia mott spoke in the inspiration
of the moment
he didn't prepare his words ahead of
time he was there's a certain
urgency and fervor that that he brought
to his message that lucretia mott did as
well
and the age of the spoken word
was
singular it it it
achieved its purpose in a way because so
many there was so much ferment there's
so many
movements and there was so much um done
in
you know
violence and non-violence and finally
wartime but um here in washington you
know senators would stand on the floor
and speak for hours you know liberty and
union now and forever
clay as well as webster there was there
was just a lot of
speaking and listening and
having words um penetrate
in person
and and sarah i have to say i think
that's
that's what is missing from social media
is the power of the spoken
word and the assembly
the congregation
yes let me nominate one other person who
i've heard speak who at least could
partially fulfill the frederick douglass
role and that's the reverend william
barber down in north carolina the moral
mondays movement where they are
confronting
retrogression going back to the days of
the black codes and
and denying the right to vote
and
reverend barber is marshalled tens upon
tens upon tens of thousands with his
rhetoric with his speeches with his
urgency of now to use old media
barack obama's phrase to get people on
the street that is not barack obama's
phrase
whose phrase is it
it's martin luther king okay
but
my point is that reverend barber would
be a good candidate for
the douglas role right now
[Music]
so there you go that's thank you for
adding that
so
is it that there is no harriet tubman
because she was quiet
i mean
i'm trying to get my head around it
well she was secret too i mean she was
known not to all but to few and that was
part of her power
is that she
she was kind of a mythical figure in her
own time
moses
maybe there is somebody like that that
we don't know about um
quietly because
they're they're having to defy the law
of the land
is there a question from this part of
the room
we got that book my husband and i and
have found that it doesn't work for us
to read it to ourselves
so we're taking a half hour a night or
more and reading it to each other
aloud because the words
resonate in a way that is
not just literary
it's not just good writing there's a
power that is very
thank you for adding that
yes
[Applause]
it's like when printing was invented
it was a way of transforming the written
word
rather than
taking days hours years it was print
print
technology and social media and whatever
form it takes
what we're doing now recording this
digitally whether it's on facebook or
twitter this now enables
people from everywhere
to have a soapbox which never happened
before for instance we didn't have cars
you can imagine oh i'm gonna go to
baltimore
you can imagine how long that's going to
take today in this weather
it's not going to happen very quickly so
it's it's transforming this planet and
even though you see
[Music]
and here it it it's bringing
all those things that these people have
been square
the public square has expanded radically
anybody on the planet is
you know you can go on on on to youtube
and put music on there all of a sudden
you bubble up and become viral and go
famous nobody knew who you were last
week
so similarly whereas in the past we had
these individuals that really had to be
monumental in order to make an impact
and whether they did it secretly by
physical uh means
man did or whether they
uh as this gentleman did change the
political scene you know which is is a
different power of the individual voice
right so now that individual voice is
it gives an opportunity to sell the
media of something but
the means of social media that we have
now is global and it's changing us
yes indeed
thank you very much it's been a
fascinating exchange
[Applause]
you're watching american history tv all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3
and is brought to you today by your
cable or satellite provider
up next the national archives here in
washington dc holds a reading of an 1852
speech by former slave and abolitionist
leader frederick douglass on the meaning
of american independence to slaves
sometimes called what to a slave is the
4th of july this is about an hour 10
minutes
good afternoon
and happy almost fourth of july
my name is tom nastic i'm a public
program producer here at the national
archives in washington d.c
and it's my pleasure to welcome you
today to the william g mcgowan theater
for
today's performance and discussion
frederick douglass the meeting of july
4th for the negro
and a special welcome to those of you
watching on the national archives
youtube channel as well as on c-span
today's program is just one of many
programs and events the national
archives will present in washington and
at presidential libraries nationwide in
celebration of the 241st
anniversary of the adoption of the
declaration of independence
if you're here in washington dc this
building is the only place to begin your
july 4th as we will present our annual
declaration of independence reading
ceremony out on constitution avenue that
will begin at 9am with a live musical
performance by brass connection
and then our honored guest thomas
jefferson benjamin franklin john adams
abigail adams and private ned hector
will read the declaration and the names
of the signers
speaking of signers this year laura
murphy a descendant of signer phillip
livingston of new york will make remarks
following the ceremony there will be a
hands-on activities for all ages until 4
pm inside the national archives building
and the museum will remain open until 7
pm
if you're not here in dc uh the reading
ceremony which begins at 10 will be live
streamed on the national archives
youtube channel
then on thursday july 6 we will conclude
our celebratory week with a noon program
here in this theater discovering the
sussex declaration
harvard university researchers danielle
allen and emily sneff will discuss the
recent identification of a second
parchment manuscript of the declaration
of independence this one dating to the
1780s
you may have heard or read about this
important discovery so now you can learn
the whole story
by coming to this theater on thursday or
again watching the live stream on the
national archives youtube channel
to learn more about these and all of our
public programs and exhibits consult our
monthly calendar of events in print or
online at archives.gov
there are copies in the lobby along with
a sign up sheet so you can receive it by
regular mail or email
you will also find brochures about other
national archives programs and
activities another way to get more
involved with the national archives is
to become a member of the national
archives foundation the foundation
supports the work of the agency
especially its education and outreach
programs
pick up your application for membership
in the lobby or become a member online
at archivesfoundation.org
and now on to our program it's my
pleasure to welcome our three special
guests today actor writer and producer
phil darias wallace who will perform for
us very shortly nathan johnson who is
supervisory park ranger at the frederick
douglass national historic site here in
washington d.c
and who will moderate our discussion
later
and last but not least to get us started
today robert s levine distinguished
university professor from the university
of maryland college park
professor levine has been an influential
force in american and african-american
literature for over 30 years and more
recently has contributed important work
to the burgeoning field of hemispheric
and transnational american literary
studies he is the author of the 2016
book the lives of frederick douglass and
following today's program we'll be
signing copies of the book upstairs
outside the archive store would you
please welcome professor robert levine
thanks for the introduction tom and my
thanks to todd for organizing this event
i'm
it's a real honor to be here my guess is
that you would rather hear an actor over
an academic so i'm going to be
relatively brief with the introduction
about five minutes so as a lot of you
know frederick douglass was born into
slavery in 1818 in the eastern shore of
maryland
for the first 20 years of his life he
was a slave moving back and forth
between the eastern shore and baltimore
he escaped from slavery in 1838 taking a
train from baltimore while dressed as a
sailor
and he eventually made his way to new
bedford massachusetts
he worked in the shipyards there and and
as a minister staying relatively quiet
about his anti-slavery views in part
because he was still a fugitive slave
and was afraid of being remanded back
into slavery
but in 1841 he spoke out against slavery
at an anti-slavery meeting in nantucket
massachusetts and the great abolitionist
william lloyd garrison was in attendance
garrison signed him up on the spot as an
anti-slavery speaker with a good salary
and douglas with the help of garrison's
anti-slavery organization moved with his
wife and two children to a house in lynn
massachusetts
over the next several years he emerged
as an electrifying anti-slavery speaker
for garrison's massachusetts
anti-slavery society
responding to skepticism that someone as
eloquent as douglas couldn't possibly
have been a slave
douglas in 1845 published what remains
his most famous work his narrative of
the life of frederick douglass an
american slave
this slave narrative or autobiography
made douglas so famous in his own time
that he had to flee to great britain or
otherwise risk being captured as a
fugitive slave
while in england ireland and scotland
from 1845 to 1847
douglas became an international
celebrity as an anti-slavery speaker
british supporters bought him out of
slavery in 1846
and in 1847 douglas now a free man
returned to the united states
but he decided to go to rochester new
york instead of back to massachusetts
because his british supporters had given
him money so he could buy a printing
press and start up an anti-slavery
newspaper which he called the north star
he didn't want to stay in massachusetts
and compete directly with garrison's
anti-slavery newspaper the liberator
which up to then was the most widely
read anti-slavery newspaper
rochester would remain douglas's home
base for many years until he relocated
to washington d.c around 1870
but to return to 1847
garrison a white man was angry at
douglas for starting up a competing
black anti-slavery newspaper and in 1850
the two men publicly broke with each
other
this is significant for the 1852 speech
that is the focus of the program today
garrison argued for non-violence or what
he called moral suasion and he believed
the constitution was a pro-slavery
document
thus he argued that anti-slavery people
should not become directly involved in
the political system
in 1850 douglas announced his rejection
of garrison's moral suasion position
arguing that slavery was an act of
violence against black people which on
certain occasions should be met by
violence
he also argued that it's important for
free blacks to become involved in the
political system
accordingly in 1850 he also declared his
new belief that the constitution was in
spirit an anti-slavery document
in short in 1850 douglas emerged as a
radical abolitionist
i should add the precipitating douglas's
break with garrison in the emergence of
this new more aggressive political
stance was congress's passage of the
compromise of 1850
which strengthened the fugitive slave
laws that were already on the books
following the passage of this firmed up
fugitive slave law people in the
northeast where slavery didn't exist
were nonetheless legally obliged to
return fugitive slaves to their masters
from douglas's point of view the
compromise of 1850 with its fugitive
slave law
nationalized slavery and showed the
importance of political resistance
for douglas the greatest example of
political resistance in american history
came from the revolutionary fathers and
mothers who chose in 1770 in 1776 to
declare their independence from great
britain and to fight for their
independence
that takes us to 1852 the year that
douglas gave what many regard as the
greatest anti-slavery speech ever to be
delivered in this country what to the
slave is the fourth of july an address
delivered in rochester new york on july
5th 1852
douglas was invited to give this july 4
speech by the rochester ladies
anti-slavery society and he delivered it
at a large hall in rochester
and 600 people whites and blacks paid 12
cents each to hear the speech which back
then i think was significant money
an oratory was public entertainment
during the the pre-civil war years and
people were willing to pay to hear great
speakers
very importantly douglas insisted on
giving
the speech on july 5th and not july 4th
he felt that until all african americans
were free he could not celebrate july
4th on the 4th
for those of you who think that this
country still has a ways to go to
achieve all of the ideals of the
declaration of independence which of
course begins with the assertion that
all men are created equal it's therefore
significant and in the great douglas
tradition that were that were having
this event on july 3rd and not july 4th
just before douglas gave his july 5th
speech rochester's rev robert r raymond
read the complete text of the
declaration of independence then
frederick douglass walked to the stage
ladies and gentlemen
the meaning of july 4th for the negro
otherwise known as what to the slave is
the 4th of july
friends
and fellow
citizens
he who could address
this audience
without a quailing sensation has
stronger nerves than i have
i do not ever remember to have appeared
before anyone more
shrinkingly
nor with greater distrust of my
abilities than i do this day
the fact of the matter is ladies and
gentlemen the distance between
the platform
and the slave plantation from which i
escaped
is considerable
and the difficulties in getting from the
latter to the former are by no means
slight
that i am here today to me
is a matter of astonishment
as well as of gratitude
with little experience and less learning
i've managed to place my thoughts
hastily and imperfectly together
entrusting to your patient
and generous indulgence
i shall proceed to lay them before you
this for the purpose of this celebration
is
the fourth
of july
it is the birthday of your national
independence it is to you what the
passover was to the emancipated people
of god it carries your minds back to
that day into the act of your great
deliverance
may the patriot not hope that high
lessons of wisdom
of justice
and of truth
shall yet guide her in her destiny were
america older
the patriots heart might be
sadder
the reformers brow
heavier america's future might be
shrouded in gloom
and the hope of her prophets go out in
sorrow
there is consolation in the thought
that america is young
fellow citizens
pardon me and allow me to ask
why am i called upon here to speak to
you today
what have i or anyone i represent to do
with your national independence
are the great principles of political
freedom and natural justice embodied in
that declaration of independence
extended to us
am i to confess the benefits and express
devout gratitude resulting from the
blessing of independence to us
would to god
for both your sakes
and ours
an affirmative answer would truthfully
be returned to the question then would
my labor be light and my burden easy and
delightful for who would not lend this
voice to the hallelujahs of a nation's
jubilee when the chains of servitude had
been torn from its limbs
but
such is not the state of the case
i say
with a sad sense of disparity between us
i am not included within the pale of
your glorious anniversary your high
independence only reveals the
immeasurable distance between us the
rich inheritance of life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness bequeathed by your
forefathers is shared by you
not me
the sunlight that brought life and
health to you brought stripes and death
to me
this
fourth of july is yours
not ours
you may rejoice
we he must mourn and to drag a man in
fetters and the grand illuminated temple
of liberty and call upon him to join you
in joyous anthems is inhuman mockery and
sacrilegious irony do you intend to mock
me fellow citizens by calling me here to
speak to you today by the rivers of
babylon yay we sat down yay we wept when
we remember dying we hung our hearts on
the willows in the midst thereof for
they who led us away captive required of
us a song and they who wasted us
required of us saying sing that song of
zion but how shall we sing the lord's
song in a strange land oh jerusalem if i
forget thee may my right hand forget her
cunning and if i do not remember thee
may my tongue cleave to the root of my
mouth
fellow citizens
beyond your national and tumultuous joy
i hear the mournful wailing of millions
whose chains
grievous yesterday are today rendered
more intolerable by the jubilee shouts
that reach them
if i
do
forget
if
i do not remember
the bleeding
children of sorrow
may my right hand forget her cunning and
may my tongue cleave to the roof of my
mouth
to forget
them
and to class lightly over their wrongs
and chime in with the popular theme is
treason
most scandalous and shocking and would
make me a reproach before god and the
world my subject then fellow citizens is
american slavery
the simple story is
that 76 years ago the people of this
country were british
subjects
your fathers deemed the english
government as the home government and
england as the fatherland the home
government did impose upon its colonial
children such burdens and restraints as
it deemed wise right and proper
but your fathers who had not chimed in
with the popular idea of the day of the
infallibility of government begin to
differ with those burdens and restraints
they went so far in their excitement as
to pronounce the english government as
unruly
unjust and oppressive and all together
such as not ought to be quietly
submitted to and i scarcely need save
fellow citizens that my opinion of those
measures fully accords with that of your
fathers
to say now that america was right in
england wrong is exceedingly easy
for there was a time when to pronounce
against england and in cause of the
colonies tried men's souls
those who did so were called
makers of mischief
agitators
rebels
dangerous men
but your fathers were brave men
statesmen
patriots and heroes and for the good
they did and the cause they stood for i
will stand with you to honor them in
their memory
feeling themselves unjustly treated they
earnestly sought redress they petitioned
and they remonstrated they did so in a
decorous loyal and respectful manner but
oppression makes a wise man mad
your fathers were wise men and if they
did not grow mad they grew restive under
this treatment they felt themselves the
victims of grievous wrongs wholly
incurable in their colonial capacity it
was just at this time that the idea of
total separation of the colonies from
the crown was born resolved that these
united colonies are and of right ought
to be free and independent states that
they are absolved from all allegiance to
the british crown and that all political
connection between the colonies and the
state of great britain is and ought to
be dissolved
friends
your fathers made good that resolution
they love their country better than they
love their own private interests they
stake their lives their fortunes and
their sacred honor all in the calls of
liberty they seized upon eternal
principles and set a glorious example in
their defense mark them their solid
manhood stands out all the more as we
contrasted with these degenerate times
shall we
take a look at this day
with its popular characteristics
from the slaves point of view
what to the american slave
is your fourth of july
i answer
it is a day that reveals to him more
than any other day of the year
the gross conduct and cruelty to which
he is the constant victim to him your
celebration is
a sham
you know what is a swine drover
i'll show you a man drover
they inhabit all of our southern states
they paramulate the country and crowd
the highways of the nation in droves of
human stock
armed with pistol whip and bowie knife
driving a hundred men women and children
these wretched souls are to be sold
singly or in lots to suit purchasers
their food for the cotton field and the
deadly sugar meal marked the sad
procession as they move along and the
savage wretch who drives them
see
the old men
with locks thin and gray
see
the young woman
whose shoulders are bear to the
scorching sun her briny tears falls on
the brow of the babe in her arms
see two
the young girl
of 13
weeping as she thinks of her mother from
whom she's been torn
mark the sad procession
heat and sorrow nearly consumes their
strength
suddenly you hear
a quick snap
like the discharge of a rifle
the fetus clank
the chains rattle
your ears are saluted with a scream that
seems to have torn its way into the
center of your soul
the crack you heard was the sound of a
whip
the scream you heard
was the mother
with the babe in her arms
her strength had faltered under the
weight of the chains and the child and
the gash in her shoulder tells her to
move on
follow
the procession
to new orleans attend an auction there
see
men examined like horses see the frames
of women rudely and brutally exposed to
the shocking gaze of american slave
buyers tell me citizens where under the
sun can you witness such a spectacle
more fiendish and shocking yet this is
but a glimpse of the american slave
system as it exists in the ruling part
of the united states but it is just in
this moment when i hear someone in my
audience say it is just at this time
that you and your fellow abolitionists
failed to make a favorable impression
upon the public mind if you would argue
more and denounce less if you would
persuade more and rebuke less your cause
might be much more likely to succeed
but
i submit
where all is plain
there's nothing to be argued
what point in the anti-slavery creed
would you have me argue
am i to argue the point that the slave
is a man
the point is conceded already nobody
doubts it
slaveholders themselves acknowledge it
in the enactment of the laws of their
government they acknowledge it when they
punish a slave for disobedience there
are 72 crimes in the state of virginia
which if committed by a black man may
subject him to the punishment of death
while only two of those same crimes if
committed by a white man may subject him
to like punishment
what is this but the acknowledgement
that the slave is a moral intellectual
and responsible being southern statute
books are filled with enactments
teaching the slave under severe fines
and penalties how to read and to write
when you can point to any such laws as
it relates to the beasts of the field
then i will consent to argue the manhood
of the slave americans
your
republican politics
as well as your republican religion
is fragrantly inconsistent
you boast
of your love for liberty
your high civilization
your pure christianity while all the
while the whole political power of the
nation conspires to hold in bondage
three million of its countrymen
you celebrate fugitives from abroad you
honor them with banquets you toast them
you salute them you bless them but of
your own fugitives at home you advertise
you hunt arrest shoot and kill
you mourn
fallen hungry
you make her wrongs
the subject
of your poets your orators and your
statesmen but of the 10 thousand wrongs
committed against the american slave you
enforce the strictest silence
and would deem him an enemy of the
nation that would make their subject
public discourse
you say that all men are created of one
blood and that all men everywhere should
love one another yet you notoriously
hate those whose skin
is not colored like your own
you proclaim before the world and before
the world proclaim we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal and have been endowed by
their creator with certain inalienable
rights and that of life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
yet you hold in bondage
a seventh part of the inhabitants of
your country
friends
the existence of slavery
in this country
branch of republicanism
a sham
your humanity
a base pretense
your christianity
a lie
it destroys your moral power abroad
it corrupts your politicians at home
it saps the very foundation of religion
it makes your name a hissing
and a byword
to a mocking
earth
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you
all right well thank you darius that was
riveting oh thank you as always thank
you thank you so much for that thank you
my name is nate johnson i'm the
supervisory park ranger at the frederick
douglass national historic site which is
right here in washington d.c we're just
about three and a half miles from the
site so you have an opportunity to get
over there
if you would like
and i just got to say this is a really
cool opportunity because i can't believe
what we're saying right here in the
national archives we are mere feet away
from where the declaration of
independence is today and we are just a
few miles from frederick douglas's house
we have so much right here at our
fingertips and you really brought that
to life um i thought it was amazing
thank you so i'm going to uh ask some
questions of you gentlemen
and uh first of all i think
bob i want to thank you for your
introduction too and i believe you had
some things you wanted to say about how
this was how this speech was given back
when federer douglas did it in 1852.
yeah actually i actually wanted to
comment on the way it was given right
now that i thought this was the finest
performance that i've ever heard of the
douglas speech and then i want to kind
of step
i want to step back to the 1850s because
things were different then i you were
pretty quiet and dutiful and polite and
all that but there were a few moments
maybe one moment that stood out where
people laughed
and i've read a whole bunch of
transcripts of douglas's speeches and
newspapers and you'll have a few
sentences and then you'll have
parentheses laughter
or a few sentences and parentheses tell
them frederick you know stuff like that
so um
back in the 1850s when douglas gave
speeches people were really kind of
worked up uh he was known not just as a
passionate person speaking out against
slaver but as one of the great
comic performers and you did some
mimicry early on that i thought was
really terrific
um the other thing i i just wanted to
say and not to embarrass you at all i
when douglas gave his speeches and this
really annoyed the abolitionists who
sponsored him
women lined up to meet him
and there's stuff in print in which the
abolitionists say particularly they want
the white women to stay away from
douglas and they didn't
and i was thinking you had a certain
charisma that was douglas lake and i'll
leave it at that
be careful my wife's in the audience
she
she brought a shotgun yesterday
and when my wife buys things she tends
to like to use it real quick
and in this particular speech when
douglas gave it in 1852 and we might
disagree a little because we have talked
about this
um
people in rochester loved it i mean
that's that's my understanding and
there's a chapter or section in william
mcfeely's biography about this
particular occasion which he says
quoting from newspapers that people at
the end of the speech just there was a
wild applause on someone said uh you
know let's endorse this speech as an
audience and there was unanimous
approval for that
and then someone said could we have a
copy of the speech and uh douglas sold
700 copies of speech on the spot
by subscription so i wanted to say that
because the speech the things that that
you were you were performing and stating
speech is quite radical
and
i'm around as i said in the introduction
around 1850 our abolitionists got a bit
more radical following the passage of
the compromise of 1850 and douglas
himself
was participating in
rallies against the fugitive slave law
and in the early 1850s about a year
before he gave the speech he's saying
that you would be doing god's work if
you were to kill a fugitive slave hunter
and in his 1855 biography autobio
autobiography my bondage and my freedom
he said something to the effect of uh
any slave who kills his masters doing
nothing very different from what the
american revolutionaries did to their
british oppressors and so douglas really
makes a major shift around 1850 in terms
of his willingness to advocate violence
but it was it was measured i mean and it
was rhetorical he's not out killing
people uh
but
a lot of things that are in the speech
that sound kind of shocking to us you
know that douglas was saying this we
know douglas is this kind of iconic
figure connected to william lloyd
garrison who was a moral suasionist
was kind of where abolition was going
post compromise of 1850.
i think since we talked about your
performance too darius i think that
would be good uh and i asked what what
is your process for how did you first of
all it's a really long speech and uh you
memorized portions of it um what is your
process for doing that and then how on
you choose to present because i really
do i think in my readings of his mimicry
his use of that it seemed like that was
probably right about where he did it so
what is your whole process for
researching and then presenting uh
that's a very good question um i
well a couple of things one i know that
when frederick douglass presented
early on he presented like an actor
almost like it was a one-person show he
would become
the characters that he he would talk
about because he was a master mimicker
he could impersonate
and so i understood that and there's a
another performance that i do where i do
become different characters in his life
uh that i did perform um off off
broadway but basically i approach it the
way that an actor approaches it we don't
really know well we know through writing
how frederick douglass potentially
sounded but we don't have any recording
of it so
i always like to go for trying to find
the the man the human being
the person behind the image
uh
where the heart lives and where the soul
lives and where the passion lives is one
of the things that i think about the
most and then it isn't easy uh
memorizing frederick douglass's words
because we don't you know we don't talk
like that anymore we don't even write
like that anymore
um and so i it it took a while to get
comfortable with his words but
trying to get at the heart at
it uh thinking about him as a human
being has helped out a lot and then as
far as memorization you know my
technique is just repetition
this over and over and over and over
again so yeah
i think it's a i think watching the
recitals is so important because we can
read frederick douglass's words of
course he is never videotaped we don't
have any audio of him but to actually
watch you bring that speech to life um
is something so important to do
when you guys
well listen to the speech when you've
done your own research what do you think
what do you think is the main message of
fire douglas's speech what do you think
he's trying to get across um here
uh in general just the speech in
particular the the fourth of july speech
that fired douglas delivers what is what
is he
kind of since you talked about the
difference in language and how we don't
speak like he does today what is in
modern terms what is he trying to say
um
i think he's he's really
um
he's doing it he's doing several things
i believe in the speech one is he's
really painting the the
graphic picture of
hypocrisy
how can you stand for liberty and
independence and freedom and yet hold
human beings in bondage
and then to understand
where we as slaves should be
think about
where your founding fathers were
it's the same situation
and so i believe that frederick douglass
took
the opportunity and advantage of the
opportunity to promote
the liberation of the slaves based on
that everything that the founding
fathers was standing for
as it relates to freedom and
independence
so i don't think he was
i think there was no
uh
bitterness or maliciousness in his
speaking i think he was very
compassionate and had a tremendous
amount of heart for the people he was
speaking to
but he wanted them to see
in a
graphic manner
the need for
these human beings to be free
and so i his i believe his goal was to
use it as another opportunity to promote
the freedom of the slaves
i mean i basically agree with that on
i think he's basically saying that the
american revolution is unfinished uh
it's incomplete as long as there is
slavery and that was a very profound
message in the 1850s uh pastor i mean uh
darris
excerpted from a two-hour speech um
according to people who were there it
took about two hours and i could imagine
enjoying hearing you talk for two hours
the speech ends with frederick douglass
it's very powerful uh moment that you
know you could add in other variants or
perhaps have
it's all about hope i mean he uses the
word hope despite everything i'm saying
i have hope so i think part of the power
of the speech and here i might sound
like you know i'm doing a july 4th kind
of number but part of the power of the
speech is that he is tapping into
american ideology and saying this has a
lot of potential
uh ideology about equality for one so
it's a highly
critical speech he's angry because of
the fugitive slave law uh he's invoking
the american revolution and he's saying
the ideology here
might not be so bad it might actually be
precisely the ideology we need to bring
about the freedom of the slaves which is
kind of looks forward to where abraham
lincoln was coming from
near the end of the civil war
i think it's in the same in the speech
too he also refers to the constitution
quite a bit and he talks about as being
a freedom-loving document
um and that's quite a different view
than the garrisonians correct yeah so so
garrison
believed with good reason that the
constitution
was pro-slavery because it had a
three-fifths clause built into it which
is to say
that slaves count as three-fifths of a
person for representation so from from
garrison's point of view the
constitution was supporting the slave
power it was pro-slavery and thus he was
arguing
against working within the political
system he's kind of working against it
or beside it
and
that as i said in the introduction is an
important
kind of point that douglas breaks from
garrison on and i think it has to do
with what i was talking about with this
idea of hope they said sure there's a
three-fifths clause but the spirit of
the constitution is anti-slavery
because he links the constitution to the
declaration of independence so it's
about equality it's about human equality
once he makes that assumption he can get
involved with politics
and
he starts to vote and he starts to work
for political parties and
yeah so so right around this time
actually is the point where he's saying
uh the constitution offers some hope
this changes ideas about politics about
the use of violence yeah and then he has
a personal
kind of dispute with garrison so you
know if you want to be a little bit
cynical you could say he came to hate
garrison garrison believed this about
the constitution therefore i believe
this about the constitution which was
the opposite of garrison
so i think still today too this is a
speech that like intellectually it still
makes us think and emotionally it still
makes us feel and it's still a very
powerful speech
why do you all think it still remains so
relevant today to us it's been 165 years
since federer douglas delivered this
speech and still i mean you can feel it
in the crowd it's still something that
affects us today why is that
i think for a couple of reasons there's
um there's this speech and if you don't
mind my mentioning there's another
speech
a year before he died called lessons of
the hour why the negro is lynched
which if you read that speech and i do
perform that speech also it
will make you think of today some of the
things that he's saying
and i think there's so many parallels to
today and there's so many things in the
atmosphere i will say
that if uh it were maybe 15 or 20 years
ago
i don't think we would
feel the heat of the speech the way that
we do today in 2017
because of some of the events that has
taken place in the past three three or
four years
and so i think that throughout the
course of time and throughout the
decades because there's still
these elements
in our country
we relate to this fourth of july speech
because it resonates with a lot of the
the things that have been happening um
the past few decades yeah today's
washington post had an article about the
kind of renewed popularity of james
baldwin
and i think that baldwin is popular
people are reading him today for similar
reasons
which is odd given that our president
loves frederick douglass apparently
but they're both they're both talking
about black humanity and blindness to
black humanity both this speech and and
a lot of baldwin's writings
and i i think uh with what's the slave
is the fourth of july which is the title
that that douglas used for it
um
you know as i've already said it's also
kind of tapping into american ideology
and arguing that there is a powerful
reform side to american ideology and
that history can change things can
change
or else he wouldn't have given the
speech yeah
so jerusalem mentioned lessons of the
hour
as being another speech that you do and
bob i know you've written a lot about
frederick douglass and his three
autobiographical uh writings and what
other speeches and writings do you think
are important that
we do need to look at to understand fire
douglas's life one of the things that
the context of that question is one of
the things i think at the site we
discuss often is i think
we're kind of in danger sometimes when
we look at one speech so much of that
person like martin luther king we just
think instantly if i have a dream speech
well what does that speech mean does
everybody still know the meaning of it
which i think we do but martin luther
king's life for example there's many
more speeches he gives frank douglas
gave many many more speeches he wrote a
lot so what other speeches and writings
do you put right up there along with
fourth of july
i would say that the the speech that i
believe he was the most popular for back
there in a time is a speech that had
nothing to do
with abolition and that was a self-made
man
and the idea of the self-made man back
during that time is different than today
when we think self-made men today we
think of
self-made millionaires
but back during that time the self-made
man was a reformer someone that would
change as their knowledge grew and then
they would use that knowledge to reform
and frederick douglass had this great
speech called self-made man and it's all
about and at the end of the day it's all
about overcoming
what your given limitations are
as
he did in his life he was born into
chattel slavery but he overcame those
um those limitations
and
that message to me is extremely powerful
because it's a universal message it does
two things one
it shows the um amazing potential in
a human being
uh regardless of whether he's uh black
or white
but then it also shows the
what a human being can do
with that
potential
and even though it was called self-made
man back during that time
we should take we should also take that
out and think about women that it speaks
to women too which toward the end of his
life he began to fight for women's
rights
with the same passion as he did against
slavery so it's a speech that teaches us
how to overcome or talks about how to
overcome our given limitations
and the potential
that we have within us
douglas had a his fatal heart attack
about three hours after he gave a speech
at a women's rights convention so i mean
he did do a lot of speaking about
women's rights i i
and taken with the speech he gave just a
year later the claims of the negro
ethnologically understood it's just kind
of
a fascinating scientific study of race
and racism but mostly of race like
uh what do racial scientists know where
are they coming from why are they saying
things about black people as if they're
you know radically different from white
people and the really interesting thing
about the speech is that he gave it at
case western reserve he was invited to
give the phi beta kappa speech and i i
need to learn i want to learn more about
that you know how is it that these white
students
came to know douglas well enough to
invite him there to give this speech
uh
two other things i would just quickly
mention in terms of uh works that have
interested me and they aren't speeches
in 1853 douglas published a novella that
not many people know called the heroic
slave which was
uh his it's always a response to uncle
tom's cabin
uh and it's a kind of fictionalization
of an 1841 slave rebellion on
on the creel ship and it's a douglas
that a lot of people don't know you know
douglas who writes fiction
and
uh
as as mentioned in the introduction to
me i'm very interested in douglas's
autobiographies which would make me
different from a 19th century person
because 19th century people basically
loved the speeches and you know some
people knew the autobiographies but not
many
i i love his last autobiography the life
and times of frederick douglass where
there are chapters on uh his involvement
with john brown chapters with his on his
friendship with abraham lincoln
and
i i think that there is a problem in the
way that a lot of us understand douglas
in terms of that very famous first
autobiography the narrative of uh
of the slave frederick douglass
published in 1845 when he was all of
like 28.
he lives to 1895 he has this fascinating
life and he has this massive
i think very readable 650 page
autobiography uh that covers so many
aspects of his life and and so i hope
that my own work on that autobiography
will lead others to to read it and and
for a greater recovery because i think
you know year by year he's just so
fascinating and we tend to focus on the
pre-civil war years i'm glad you
mentioned the anti-lynching speech
attention on that what are some of the
lesser-known aspects of frederick
douglass's life that interests you the
most and having researched ferrari
douglas and
portraying frederick douglass
there will be time for questions uh we
will um i will let you audience members
know when to stand up and go towards the
microphone but i'll give a very quick
response um
douglas was
an ambassador to haiti in
i guess it's it's the late 1880s and he
became friendly with haitian leaders and
he lost his job because american
governmental people thought he was too
sympathetic to haiti and
haiti tapped him to be the person who
runs overseas the haitian pavilion at
the 1893 chicago world's fair that's a
whole different story about douglas
douglas about the southern americas
about haiti these very interesting
political friendships and
kind of his problems of actually being a
politician because he couldn't hold on
to the job
he started a bank um it didn't it didn't
do well but he did start a bank
um
he
really frederick douglass was
a rock star he was like the jimi hendrix
of his day
um he
back during that today everybody wants
to be a basketball star football star a
rap star well public speaking was that
it was he was the sydney party of his
day he was the great actor of his day as
far as his fame
um and so a lot of times we don't know
that frederick douglass had that kind of
party and he was the most photographed
man
of that century too it's something to
know about frederick douglass absolutely
so at this time i'm going to let
audience members know if you have any
questions to
please you can begin to line up at the
microphones i'm going to ask one more
question here
and then we'll take some questions from
the audience
but i just wanted to mention too when
you're talking about especially freddie
douglas's life and times
that he wrote that while he was living
in the house that is now protected as
part of the frederick douglass national
historic site so today i actually got to
sit on fire douglas's porch and read
portions from his life and times and
think oh man he was just sitting right
inside this house uh writing that book
and uh he was actually while he was
serving as ambassador in haiti he was
living in that house
um
so it's a it's a really interesting
place to visit and i just wanted to let
everyone know too that during the
following year 2018 here is the
bicentennial of frederick douglass's
birth and so there are going to be a lot
of programs at the site and probably
internationally nationwide to recognize
frederick douglass's life and legacy and
so that's what my last question is going
to get at
is that why do you think it's important
that we recognize the life and legacy of
frederick douglass today
i believe that it's important
for one of the reasons why i mentioned
earlier is
he represents freedom and liberty
universally
he represents it for me as an
african-american man and my wife as an
african-american woman
but he also represents freedom as it
relates to all the different aspects
that we go through in our life
being able to overcome our limitations
some of us
are
experiencing certain bondage as it may
relate to addiction it may relate to a
relationship it may relate to a job it
may relate to
a certain aspect of how you're living in
life and what i've noticed is when i
perform frederick douglass
my audiences are normally like this is
very diverse and i believe it's like
that because
the message of liberty and the message
of freedom speaks
to our spirit speaks to our heart and so
i believe that is the reason why we
should continue to remember frederick
douglass's legacy and also to remember
that
you know one of the things that he said
after one of his speeches is
this discussion is not over
the discussion of slavery is not over
the discussion of racism is not over the
discussion of discrimination
is not over and so because it is not
over we should continue to remember
and i would
agree with everything that that you said
so i don't want to repeat that i'll just
say that i'm a literary historian so
in addition to everything you said i i
value the fact that he's a great writer
and i work in the 19th century and i
think of him as someone who really opens
up so many aspects of the 19th century
and one of these 19th century people who
think that if you know the 19th century
you know the 20th and the 21st century
so you know for all these reasons i
think he's he's such a compelling figure
i also like to read him in relation to
other writers so i think
i don't want to simply celebrate douglas
all by himself actually i have a book i
edited book on douglas and hermann
melville and they were in conversation
in in very interesting ways
so i'll stop there
well bob andrews thank you so much we're
gonna now take some questions
from the visitors
was this mike on thank you
my name is john del pino i have a
comment first and a question about
pleasure douglas and thank you very much
for those organizing this and especially
you sir for recruiting the passions of
our douglas
as a young man born in colombia who was
raised in washington syria i would just
say i was not someone who
was designed to be a basketball star or
a rabble i admire those but someone
would deeply admire history especially
us history and having studied us history
and public policy in chicago
but that is near relevant actually my
questions related to the relationship
between lincoln and douglas
since those who know douglas know
especially douglas was the first black
man by the white house
i like all your thoughts especially with
lincoln's
treasure and but also um his inspiring
message and my belief that the best
speech ever american president second
inaugural what are your thoughts all of
you there on
how does himself evolved on the very
topic today the fourth of july given
what he later experienced in life and
through the hope experience but also the
lesson passions that he himself had
thank you
do you want me to answer i think bob
maybe uh yeah i
i have a kind of revisionary chapter on
the douglas
lincoln relationship in my in my new
book so
i
i think the the story that's been told
is kind of
inherent implicit in your question that
lincoln very much admired douglas
douglas very much admired lincoln
they had profound interactions during
the civil war those interactions had an
impact on both people
and douglas in particular was arguing
very vociferously
for the right for black
men to
fight in the civil wars part of the
northern army
uh so
and then i mean douglas loves lincoln
i'll say all that and then the
revisionary part of my reading from
kind of picking up on douglas's
autobiographical writings and on his
speeches is i think that this
relationship relationship has been
overly mythified
they met several times my estimate is
they met for a total of one hour over
four years of the civil war
douglas has speeches about lincoln that
are highly critical
douglas never voted for lincoln
which is really interesting even in 1864
he doesn't vote for for lincoln
he thinks that lincoln is committed too
much to the union and doesn't care as
much about the slaves and
there's fascinating material in
douglas's journals in douglas's magazine
called douglas's monthly
in which month by month he's just going
after lincoln
and he's concerned that lincoln wants to
colonize blacks to
central america so
i the revisionist part of my reading is
that this was a more prickly
relationship than
has been previously
been thought
that doesn't mean that by
1865 that these people haven't
profoundly influenced each other so i
think that that's also
there i i think that it's one of the
more fascinating stories about the civil
war this
relationship
um lincoln was
keeping an eye on douglas
in the early 1860s and reading what he
was saying there's evidence of that
and douglas was following the lincoln
douglas stephen douglas debate soon in
1858
so
to make a long argument short what i
argue in my book is that there's a more
profound human connection between
frederick douglass and john brown than
there is between frederick douglass and
lincoln at least to the time of the
second inauguration but i still see
profound influences on both sides and
when lincoln is assassinated douglas
gives
he's speaking of great speeches i mean
he gives some great speeches about
lincoln and about his love of lincoln
and about lincoln as the great savior of
the country so i think it's a kind of
complex prickly and ultimately still
very moving relationship between these
two great figures
we have another question
yeah i have two questions and it may be
anyone on the panel can answer
one is about the relationship between
douglas and harriet tubman because they
were both from the eastern shore
although they were from different
counties i'm not sure about the dates on
that and the second one is
i've thought more about this over the
years as i've studied
african-american history my history
when douglas was making his speeches
about
slavery
what were the thoughts of native
americans what what
did douglas think about the status of
native americans because slaves weren't
citizens
free blacks weren't citizens
and and indians weren't native americans
were not in uh citizens so we had three
categories where there were no
citizenship
um so i'll go back to harriet tubman
since
harriet tubman is real big right now
in dorchester county
so did they meet did they
have similar thoughts uh any any
thoughts on that
i can answer this a little bit about
that um i don't know too much about his
relationship with harriet tubman how
close it was but we definitely know that
they knew each other they spent time
together and particularly when frederick
douglass lived up in rochester new york
he's fairly close to the canadian border
and where is harriet tubman trying to
take the people that she's helping to
escape but across that border and she
spends time in canada herself so she's
going through rochester staying at the
douglas home then
and i know i've seen in our collection
we have a collection of thousands of
objects that belong to frederick
douglass among them as at least one
biography on harriet tubman
from her time
so we know frederick douglass connect
collected other people's narratives and
that included harriet tubman's um
i don't know bob do you know more about
that
commenting on harry tubman in his
autobiographies which is why maybe i
haven't further explored that
relationship
douglas was always someone who argued
for citizenship for people who were
disenfranchised
and
i think very powerfully not to deflect
too far away from your your question
but in the
1870s to 1890s at the time of his death
he was arguing for citizen citizenship
rights for asian americans for so-called
coolies and that put him in the real
minority you know of of voices during
that time so
i know less about
his interest or championing of native
americans more about other
immigrants who he was championing for
citizenship and was arguing for
citizenship and voting rights for women
though he accepted
the
constitutional amendments that initially
gave black men and not
white women
the right to vote and that led to
extraordinary friction for a couple of
years between douglas and women's rights
advocates
um yeah and not just um
with the
uh native americans
but we know for sure the mexicans as
well as asians women
and then he became very famous in
ireland
because of the
oppression some of the arts were having
there they looked to frederick
douglass's writings for inspiration and
hope and when he was overseas there he
was very famous
for speaking to
what was happening with them
but he did his speeches and his ideas
did inspire and connect with people
outside of uh african americans and then
he did have a relationship with harriet
tubman and there were letters
um or some kind of correspondence
between the two of them and i believe
she sent him a gift
of one of her walking sticks
and he also had a probably even more of
an intimate friendship with sojourner
truth
thank you yeah that's a good question
yes sir
i was wondering um
massachusetts uh
made slavery outlawed slavery almost
immediately after
uh independence and several other states
were felt it was incompatible with the
declaration of independence also seemed
like washington and
jefferson were aware that slavery was
supporting slavery would be hypocritical
but it looked like
they're more than just simple hypocrisy
they
their
greed so to speak to what the lifestyle
they wanted to maintain overrode what
they were aware of
uh how uh
by the time douglas was speaking
how much had the does it seem like the
south had convinced itself totally
that uh
they were justified
or were they still aware to some degree
that that there was a hypocrisy there
i think uh generally so
in the context and the circumstances
change by the time that douglas gives
his speech and and i certainly do think
some of the founding fathers
maybe did see that maybe that if slavery
did not extend it would die
um but they could not foresee the cotton
gin they could not foresee before the
abolition of the international slave
trade that slave chairs would bring a
lot more enslaved people into the
country they couldn't foresee all that
that really
strengthened the nation and the south in
particular's commitment to slavery
they could not foresee that but we do
know then by douglas's generation
generally what the founding fathers had
called
slavery was a necessary evil by the time
of douglas they're referring to it as a
positive good something that is good
socially economically
and politically for the country so
by the 1830s slavery was not going to go
away in the south
i
i recently held a visiting fellowship at
a southern university where they're all
saying
oh you know why why'd they fight the
civil war uh slavery was going to just
end naturally i just don't see that
slavery didn't just end in the northeast
in any kind of natural way too there's
no specific
kind of moment in massachusetts where
they said slavery is over
it was like a series of court cases
through the late 18th century slavery
was legal in new york state until 1827
which is kind of remarkable um new
jersey had slaves up to the 1840s so
when douglas is concerned about the
national nationalizing of slavery
through the future of slave law you
could also look
to the north and even in places where
there wasn't slavery like uh
philadelphia uh there's extraordinary
segregation and racial
strife
uh to the point where
uh
you know pros pro-slavery people could
say to black people you know run away to
philadelphia at your peril uh you're not
going to meet a very nice state
but with jefferson in the 1780s and
those in the state of virginia he
imagines the end of slavery uh by the
1810s 1820s that's over uh interestingly
washington freezes slaves on his death
so that's you know this great symbolic
action but it didn't do much in in
virginia beyond being that kind of
symbolic action
the issue too was it it was it was
really about the money
you know it was about the money that
that slave i mean you had
me just think about it if i'm
a slave owner
and each of you are on my plantation
and everything that you're doing is free
labor imagine what that that does for me
and imagine what it can do for
uh
an economy
so even with even with lincoln you know
lincoln's argument to frederick was you
know
we can look toward ending slavery but
it'll take at least 100 years
so lincoln's idea of ending it was we'll
end it but it's going to have to be set
up to end 100 years later
because nobody could connect to the idea
of it just abruptly
ending
and so a lot of times we forget about
the economic part of the reason why
slavery existed
as
slavery still exists today
with children
with women
with one of the things i think frederick
douglass would have stood up for in this
day the injustice
in the criminal system
criminal justice system
uh injustice in the prison system
frederick douglass would have been just
as controversial today as he was
yesterday as it relates to some of the
things that we're experiencing right now
um
there's there's slave labor that's going
on right under our nose
right now
and the reason why it's here is because
of the money that it brings in
and so that's that's the reason why um i
i believe that it was hard for them to
let go of during that time because it's
hard for us to let go of it today and
just as we don't know much about it
and we kind of looked the other way
it's how the public was looking away and
didn't know much about it back during
that time and it took people like
frederick douglass william lloyd
garrison
john brown and many others to bring it
to public attention of what was actually
going on
and then you go to other countries and
there's chattel slavery in other
countries
so
so that concludes the program
thank you very much to everybody
all right thank you darius and thank you
bob thank you i appreciate it
hello
you